euh ce qui se passe pour ce début de
manifestation la manifestation n'est pas
partie encore vous voyez là-bas le
cortège de la terre cervicale qui ouvre
en fait cette manifestation derrière les
ballons de la CFE c'est de la CFDT de
solidaire l'ordre de passage des des
différents syndicats dans cette
manifestation vous le savez donc c'est
la 12e et c'est à la veille de la
réponse décisive en fait du Conseil
constitutionnel qui sera demain et ça
c'est très important on en parlera avec
les manifestants on en parlera aussi
avec les hommes politiques bien
évidemment qu'on croisera tout au long
de ce parcours et en attendant je vous
laisse retrouver sur le plateau de
Figaro live Vincent
à tous effectivement nous sommes sur le
plateau de Figaro live avec vous
Marie-Cécile Renaud merci beaucoup
Vincent va revenir vers vous assez
souvent tout au long de l'après-midi
pour avoir l'ambiance pour prendre le
coup des manifestants apparemment
l'ambiance est plus vieux sur la place
de l'Opéra qui est le point de départ de
cette manifestation et qui doit arriver
place de la Bastille
Marie-Cécile on voit les syndicats ici
on voit les les défauts en Calico les
ballons les camions mais qu'on ne voit
pas une chose mais ça peut-être que vous
allez pouvoir nous indiquer
nous donner quelques réponses quelques
éclairages quel est l'état d'esprit des
syndicats aujourd'hui
et bien mon cher Vincent on se retrouve
pour une douzième journée ça me donne le
plaisir de pouvoir faire une
conversation avec vous partager
au meilleur sources
et le
moral des syndicats reste le même enfin
leur état d'esprit reste le même leur
mot d'ordre reste le même c'est à dire
il réclame toujours le retrait de la
réforme et rien d'autre rien de plus
mais rien de moi
alors 12e journée de mobilisation
Sophie Binet la nouvelle patronne de la
CGT appel à ce que ce ne soit pas la
dernière donc ils n'ont pas l'intention
d'arrêter même si donc on attend cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
demain et Laurent Berger le patron de la
CFDT a dit qu'il y aurait aussi encore
le grand rendez-vous annuel du 1er mai
traditionnel rassemblement de des
syndicats mais quand même ça devrait
être le point d'orgue enfin de ce
mouvement il y a une forme d'épuisement
je suis ravie de vous retrouver tous les
tous les semaines mais mais bon
mais il y a quand même une forme de
ras-le-bol des soufflement d'envie de
passer à autre chose
et bon c'est vrai de les syndicats
restent sur les mêmes mots d'ordre que
le l'intersyndical reste unique mais on
voit bien regarder ce ces images le
cortège n'est plus le même que au mois
de janvier le 31 janvier quand il était
très serré et que la queue de cortège
n'était pas encore partie que le début
arrivait enfin qui piétinait qu'il
faisait du surplace là ça paraît quand
même clairsemer les autorités prévoient
quoi entre 400 000 et 600 000 personnes
dans les rues aujourd'hui on est loin du
million dépassé du début
le million dépassé du 23 mars ou du 7
mars
à chaque fois une forme
bien sûr les syndicats eux toujours des
chiffres supérieurs mais enfin la
tendance est effectivement à la baisse
ça c'est pour la mob utilisation côté
grève c'est un peu mou aussi alors bon
il y a un peu d'inquiétude du côté des
éboueurs parisiens parce que la CGT a
appelé à nouveau une nouvelle grève des
poubelles donc ça ok mais côté on va
regarder pardon je vous coupe parce que
là sinon vous avez tout mangé comme ça
et quand même le plaisir vous le disiez
c'est d'avoir la conversation et surtout
de l'avoir avec vous bonjour Christian
Léon et qui vous salue également Marie
Cécile merci Christian Leon d'être
toujours fidèle et merci chers
internautes d'être fidèle à au Figaro
live et je je j'en profite pour vous
dire que
il y a un autre événement au Figaro qui
est en train de se préparer vous l'avez
déjà esquissé c'est le lancement d'une
notre arrivée sur la TNT
Île-de-France et sur les Box à partir du
à partir de lundi prochain à 19h chaîne
34 de la TNT Île-de-France et puis
également sur sur les Box on vous
donnera d'ailleurs les différents
chiffres
à ce moment-là et également Figaro life
bien sûr ça continue avec le plaisir de
l'interactivité c'est grâce à Christian
Léon que j'y pensais et que j'ai pu
faire cette annonce ici donc nous sommes
place de l'Opéra vous le voyez sur ces
images tout près du Figaro devant le
café de la Paix
et effectivement l'ambiance n'est pas
encore à la à la paix sociale
question
avant peut-être d'aller plus loin sur
l'état d'esprit des syndicats
Marie-Cécile les points que qui reste
sensible dans le contenu de la loi en
tous les cas au plan constitutionnel
puisque ces deux mains on ne sait pas
encore à quelle heure c'est la fameuse
on se croirait dans un conclave une
fumée blanche peut être de la rue
Montpensier du siège de la du qui n'est
pas une fumée de fumigène
demain donc on ne sait pas à quelle
heure sortira la vie mais enfin on sait
sur quel point oui on parle de 15 € 18h
la décision est prise demain après-midi
donc je rappelle pour nos auditeurs que
le Conseil constitutionnel a été créé en
1958 qu'il est le garant du respect de
la Constitution donc là en l'occurrence
il doit vérifier la conformité de la loi
par rapport à la constitution donc le
Conseil constitutionnel est constitué de
neuf membres il y en a trois qui sont
nommés par le Président de la République
trois par le président du Sénat trois
par le président de l'Assemblée et ils
sont élus pour 9 ans donc c'est comme ça
qu'on retrouve par exemple Alain Juppé
Laurent Fabius Jacqueline le Gouraud qui
était une ancienne ministre
ministre de l'orphelie voilà tout à fait
elle était en charge des territoires et
puis on retrouve aussi deux droits les
anciens présidents de la République
mais donc Nicolas Sarkozy qui en faisait
partie à démissionner et François
Hollande a dit qu'il ne voulait pas ici
j'ai donc voilà et donc les les
syndicats estiment que le gouvernement a
détourné la procédure parlementaire en
utilisant un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative vous savez qu'à chaque
automne on vote le budget le budget de
l'État le cadre le cadre normal
le véhicule législatif qui a été utilisé
donc on a les textes budgétaires de
l'automne
législatif et qui n'a rien effectivement
de la semaine
qui veut dire projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
est voté chaque automne et là c'est un
projet de loi rectificatif on rectifie
le budget qui a été voté à l'automne
dernier et on en profite pour mettre
cette loi cette loi retraite donc les
syndicats mais attendez un texte ce
n'est pas un texte budgétaire c'est un
texte c'est une réforme la réforme des
retraites ça mériterait un texte de loi
à part
et pourquoi pourquoi le gouvernement
fait ça c'est parce que sur les textes
budgétaires il peut utiliser le 49-3
il a le droit d'utiliser le 49-3 sur les
textes budgétaires autant de fois qu'il
veut et il a le droit à une fois par
session parlementaire sur un autre texte
donc il avait pour pouvoir se donner la
possibilité de garder la possibilité
voilà il était sur pouvoir PC par le
49-3 sans gâcher une cartouche qu'il
pouvait garder pour un autre texte par
exemple l'immigration que sais-je et
donc il a utilisé ce véhicule législatif
alors après donc les gouvernements
disent ça n'est pas ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas normal donc ils attaquent sur
ce sur ce fondement le gouvernement dit
mais attendait la réforme des retraites
bon c'est une argutie mais c'est le
financement de la branche vieillesse de
la sécurité sociale donc ça trouve
pleinement sa place c'est vrai que là
cette réforme elle doit faire faire des
économies et donc ça doit remplir les
caisses de la branche retraite
puisqu'on en est là au monde le
financement de la retraite aujourd'hui
on a une retraite principale on a une
retraite complémentaire ça c'est et
ensuite
les retraites sont se réparties le
financement des retraites se répartit
commence c'est-à-dire que il y a une
espèce de caisse générale pour pour tout
le monde et après il y a des caisses
complémentaires alors oui il y a la
retraite de base la retraite sécurité
sociale et puis ensuite par exemple pour
les salariés
il y a la branche santé comme vous dites
pour rembourser les frais de santé il y
a la branche vieillesse qui paie les
retraites il y a la branche famille qui
paient toutes les cotisations familiales
les allocations familiales etc
les minima sociaux il y a la branche
ATMP sur les accidents du travail et
maladies professionnelles et on a
longtemps été avec quatre branches et le
gouvernement Macron premier quinquennat
a rajouté après le covid d'une cinquième
branche la branche autonomie qui doit
financer la dépendance l'autonomie
mais donc la sécu elle finance les
retraites donc cette loi retraite je ne
pense pas que le Conseil constitutionnel
puisse retoquer contester le fait
qu'elle puisse être dans un plfs
sensibles il y a on va peut-être les
passer en détail mais avant ça il y a
quelque chose qui
qui frappe c'est que j'ai pas vu en tous
les cas que l'âge de la retraite le
report de l'âge de la retraite lui
constitue un point litigieux d'un point
de vue constitutionnel
je ne pense pas enfin difficile de
préjugés mais a priori non en soi est-ce
que c'est pourtant c'est quand même le
syndicats de la réforme mais je pense
pas que d'un point de vue
constitutionnel on puisse enfin bon je
suis pas spécialiste de droit
constitutionnels
oui il y a par exemple le CDI senior
vous savez cette mesure
qui veut faciliter les fins de carrière
en permettant de faire un contrat qui
avec moins de charges moins de charges
chômage bien sûr en chômage notamment et
donc les syndicats attaquent en divisant
que ça permettrait des exonérations pour
les entreprises et que
eux sont pas favorables à ce mécanisme
parce qu'il pense que ça aura un impact
assez nul sur l'emploi des seniors donc
voilà il y a des points de détails donc
mon pronostic moi c'est que le Conseil
constitutionnel ne sanctionnera pas le
véhicule ne sanctionnera pas la loi il
peut revoir des points de détail mais a
priori je
je suppose je fais le pari qu'il
validera voilà
et je pense que certains on entend une
petite musique qui montre certains des
noms le fait que les juges ne serait pas
totalement indépendant j'ai rappelé tout
à l'heure comment ils étaient nommés
mais moi je pense qu'il faut se garder
de décrédibiliser les institutions on a
des des institutions qui fonctionnent et
qui ont fait leur preuve on a une crise
sociale actuellement profonde je pense
que on n'a pas besoin de rajouter une
crise institutionnelle par dessus alors
le message en tous les cas est bien
passé
il y a une autre question qui se pose
avant qu'on retrouve Vincent Rozon sur
place on pense ça s'affiche un peu
d'autres calme peut-être un peu de monde
ça c'est le signe dans tous les cas
quand on n'arrive pas à avoir des flux
très très fluides qui nous reviennent de
la rue c'est que généralement il y a
beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de monde
autour et donc est-ce que c'en est le
génial et ben on verra ça dans le cours
de la journée notamment avec Arthur
bijouta du Figaro data une question
alors là il y a que vous qui pouvez me
répondre Marie Cécile combien va
rapporter cette réforme si elle était
adoptée
alors combien on sait plus hein
donc moi je repars du document de base
qui avait été diffusé en janvier quand
la Première ministre Elisabeth borne
avait lancé la réforme la réforme à
l'époque devait rapporter 17,7 milliards
d'euros donc ça permettait de couvrir
les 13 milliards et demi du déficit des
retraites attendu en 2030 sa laissait
même un petit peu de mou il y avait 4,8
milliards de marge bon pour faire des
concessions des mesures pour
d'accompagnement social
mais je vous rappelle que au fur et à
mesure des semaines il y a eu tout de
nombreuses concessions qui ont été
lâchées sur les 1200 euros de pension
minimum avec le au départ ça devait
concerner le flux c'est derrière les
nouveaux retraités puis finalement ça a
été appliqué aux anciens traités ce
qu'on appelle le stock il y a eu des
élargissement des mesures sur les
carrières longues etc bref
Olivier du soft qui disait que le
déficit ne serait plus couvert
totalement ce qui aurait 300 400
millions le ministre du Travail qui
disait qu'il y aurait
il y aurait toujours 300 400 millions
d'euros de déficit en 2030 alors on est
loin d'être 13 milliards et demi on
comble quand même le trou mais on est
loin de ce qui avait été annoncé au tout
départ en fait cette réforme ne rapporte
plus en fait
de combler les 13,5 milliards mais il y
a plus de marge
on est plus tellement à l'équilibre avec
cette réforme on va en ayant on est à
peine ouais alors et puis c'est surtout
que derrière le déficit continuera à se
creuser les années suivantes et que le
déficit après 2030 ça va continuer et
donc ça c'est dans ces temps normalement
si la réforme est adoptée en état on l'a
dit on la redit mais enfin on a
tellement dit que on a oublié donc on
refait un point si la réforme est
adoptée en l'état si elle est validée en
l'état par le Conseil constitutionnel
d'ici 2030 donc le déficit ne prévoyait
et puis si de prévisionnel du des
caisses de retraite devrait être
à peine comblé ça permet d'éponger mais
c'est tout sera à refaire à partir de ce
moment-là alors Christian Léon vous
remercie du rappel de fonctionnement du
fonctionnement du Conseil
constitutionnel qui que vous avez fait
merci effectivement c'était très
pédagogique et merci de vous plonger
dans tous ces points techniques parce
que parfois on a du mal à comprendre et
grâce à vous en vous entendant c'est
pour ça qu'on vous sollicite on ne
comprend mieux on va peut-être retrouver
Vincent roserand qui est sur place
puisque l'image ne fige plus l'image
bouge ce qui nous réjouit toujours en
vidéo Vincent quel est l'ambiance là où
vous trouvez
alors
je sais pas si vous entendez bien ou pas
si vous avez notre image je le trouve à
côté de temps pour forcément ça fait
beaucoup de bruit je sais pas si vous
voyez bien notre image en tout cas nous
sommes toujours au point de départ de
méditation qui ne s'est qui ne sait pas
élancé pour l'instant cette
manifestation comme vous pouvez voir sur
les images je veux dire Leclerc qui
m'accompagne là manifestation c'est pas
les lancer vous voyez le point de départ
là-bas sur les images de Julien avec un
panneau c'est l'interfe syndical qui
ouvre la route avec Sophie Vinet et
Laurent Berger qui ont exprimé
effectivement Marie-Christine Renault en
appareil tout à l'heure ils ne vont pas
arrêter la manifestation ils vont
ils vont continuer à alors qu'il y a les
explosifs qui viennent de sauter mais
c'est rien c'est des petits pétards
voilà en tout cas une manifestation qui
pour l'instant n'a pas démarré on attend
on attend que cette manipulation démarre
vous le disiez tout à l'heure
apparemment le réseau ne passait pas
très bien et pourtant on n'a pas
l'impression qu'on est sur une immense
influence donc voilà on va vous faire
vivre en tout cas cette manifestation de
l'intérieur
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Vincent effectivement on
va se cortège donc la CFE-CGC on
rappelle ce que c'est le syndicat
c'est assez inhabituel de les trouver
dans les grandes manifestations et là
ils ont joué enfin ils étaient à fond
très remontés et
il y a eu une forme de de radicalisation
de on l'a vu chez Laurent Berger on l'a
vu aussi chez le syndicat des cadres
[Musique]
un troisième et dernier mandat François
Hollande
en revanche
ce qu'on voit moins aujourd'hui je sais
pas si vous avez pris le métro Vincent
aujourd'hui ça circule plutôt bien et ça
fonctionnait on voit quand même
des grands absents dans cette
mobilisation on l'a constaté au fil des
semaines c'est que la RATP fonctionne
plutôt bien le train bon il y a quelques
perturbations mais globalement ça va et
alors que ce sont eux les faire de lance
des mobilisations habituelles qu'en 2019
ils avaient fait une grève très dure et
ils n'ont pas vraiment été au
rendez-vous cette fois-ci on a eu
l'impression que la la greffe c'est un
peu sans eux alors pour plusieurs
raisons
les régimes spéci était monté au créneau
les fois précédentes et ils avaient
l'impression un peu de faire la grève
pour les autres alors que l'opinion
finalement
leur est assez défavorable l'opinion
trouve injuste l'existence de ces
résidus spéciaux et très favorable à
leur suppression
et cette fois-ci non pas énormément ils
ont moins à perdre parce que certes ils
devront travailler deux ans de plus
comme les autres mais avec la réforme
Touraine ils sont déjà obligés et les 43
nuités ils sont déjà obligés de retarder
un petit peu leur âge de départ donc en
fait il y avait moins de convictions et
puis surtout
on a dit depuis le début que ce qui est
quand même absolument frappant c'est
cette union syndicale cette personne qui
ne sait absolument pas fissuré on
n'avait jamais vu ça depuis 1995 et
pourtant ce que vous dites est
intéressant parce que ce qui est vrai
c'est que c'est la première fois depuis
1995 qu'on voit que les
[Musique]
pour les vacances de Noël ce serait
entre guillemets venger en allant
travailler cette fois-ci pas venger mais
ça pesait sur leur fiche de paix là ils
ont ils avaient moins de raisons on les
a senti en tout cas moins présent mais
alors c'est vrai que l'interdyndicale
reste unie qui a un front unique il y a
pas eu de dissensions entre les uns et
les autres mais et c'est vrai que les
syndicats mettent en avant qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde dans les rues mais
c'est oublier qu'à chaque réforme des
retraites il y a du monde dans les rues
donc là ils ont dans le discours dans le
verbatim on a beaucoup dit que c'était
des grévistoriques historiques il y a eu
du monde en 1948 mais 1968 il y a du
monde en il y avait du monde 2003 il y
avait du monde toujours du monde et les
syndicats ont mis en avant aussi qu'il
faisait un regain d'abonnés de d'abonnés
d'adhérents Laurent Berger parlait de
une hausse de 50% d'adhérents en janvier
c'est vrai mais c'est le cas pour tous
les syndicats la CGT a gagné aussi et
c'est le cas à chaque à chaque grande
mobilisation puisque des gens qui
peuvent pas les manifester qui sont qui
sont pas disponibles et tout ça c'est
une façon de de voilà puis ça met les
problèmes sur la table donc les gens
sont plus propres à s'engager mais ça ne
doit pas cacher quand même la
désaffection pour les syndicats je
rappelle que dans les années 70 la CGT
avait 2 millions d'adhérents et penser
atteindre les 3 millions et en 2020 la
dernière comptage les derniers chiffres
officiels ils sont à 600 000 en quartés
bon et puis on a vu il y a eu le je sais
pas si vous avez suivi si bien sûr le
53e congrès de la CGT à
clermont-ferrandit l'élection les
discours de de Sophie donc Sophie Binet
première femme à être élu à la tête de
la CGT depuis sa création il y a 128 ans
on a vu que ce congrès était très
violent ils en sont presque venus aux
mains
les organisateurs du Congrès ont coupé
les caméras enfin c'était un feuilleton
on va voir ça dans un instant de Pierre
Lopez qui nous attend en régie et qui va
nous rejoindre mais est-ce que
finalement on a vu ce front syndical
intercelical très unis etc mais est-ce
que ça ne cache pas
une recomposition une autre
configuration peut-être un Français
syndical générationnel mais parfois des
dissensions assez fortes à l'intérieur
des syndicats autrement dit la
confrontation elle est plus entre
syndicats mais elle est à l'intérieur
même des syndicats
oui il y a une dissension au sein des
syndicats c'est on le voit par exemple
c'est ce que je vous disais avec la CGT
et là Sophie Binet
oui c'est moins fort c'est plus
plus
ça a été beaucoup plus fort notamment en
la CGT Sophie Binet elle a du pain sur
la planche parce que c'est une féministe
écologique elle va devoir changer
l'image de la de la CGT qui reste un peu
masculine et machiste c'est une cadre
aussi elle doit devoir faire avec le
mouvement
la CGT entre la base ouvrière masculine
et industrielle versus
cette gauche sociétale qui est en train
de qui a pris le pouvoir avec aurait pu
le prendre encore plus fort avec Sophie
buisson avec Marie buisson et qu'il a
pris quand même en a l'impression en
tout cas avec Sophie Je pense que c'est
un peu fort mais en tout cas il y a des
courant très différents qui s'affirme on
l'a vu
durant le congrès et voilà on va devoir
unifier tout ça
quelques petites questions
sur le je voudrais qu'on revienne quand
même sur une institution donc tout le
monde parle depuis le début
depuis le début de cette séquence depuis
le 19 janvier notamment c'est le comité
d'orientation des retraites en fait on a
tendance toujours à utiliser le corps
comme un organisme en tous les cas on
parlait comme un organisme d'experts
indépendant c'est pas complètement ça il
y a de tout il y a juge est parti à
l'intérieur le corps oui c'est un peu
compliqué le comité d'orientation des
retraites en fait tout remonte à 1995 la
réforme Juppé avortée
donc le gouvernement Jospin qui est
arrivé ensuite a demandé un état des
lieux savoir où on en était sur les
retraites il avait chargé le
Commissariat aux plans de de faire un
rapport ça a été le rapport Charpin de
1999 et ce sera pour Charpin a donné
lieu à maintes controverse les experts
n'étaient pas d'accord sur le diagnostic
même sur le sur le constat même sur le
sur le diagnostic du coup le
gouvernement a créé le corps en 2000 qui
a vu le jour en 2000 avec pour mission
de au moins mettre tout le monde
d'accord sur le le diagnostic sur le
constat et alors ce corps était composé
d'experts
d'une quarantaine de personnes avec des
parlementaires sénateurs députés des
experts et des représentants enfin des
syndicats et du patronat bon vous
comprenez bien que cette quarantaine de
personnes qui est là pour se mettre
d'accord pour faire du consensus dans
les gènes même dans l'ADN du corps de
faire du consensus
faire du consensus à 40 c'est un peu
compliqué et
voilà donc le corps il est là pour
finalement ne fâcher personne entre
guillemets alors l'exercice est
compliqué aussi ils font des projections
sur des sur des sur les retraites qui se
pilotent à 50 ans c'est assez compliqué
il doit tenir compte du taux de chômage
du taux de croissance de la productivité
et en plus il y a plus je sais pas si
vous avez déjà regardé un rapport du
corps donc qui sort tous les ans alors
vous avez des vulgarisation du rapport
du corps et je vous assure qu'il valait
mieux que je vois la vulgarisation parce
que déjà j'avais du mal à m'y retrouver
il y a toujours plusieurs il y a
plusieurs scénarios est-ce que seulement
de productivité du du voilà et en plus
il y a plusieurs convention en de si
l'État continue à verser le même taux de
subvention ou pas donc vous avez plein
de scénarios possibles
comme il faut dégager du consensus les
choses sont dites il y a plusieurs
intérêts il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs opinions il y a plusieurs
intérêts il y a plusieurs sensibilités
de scénario en fait voilà et un rapport
qui est assez indigeste pour les non
avertis et tout le monde parle du
rapport du corps mais je vous assure
qu'il y a à mon avis très peu de gens
qui l'ont qui l'ont lu non moi je trouve
qu'il y a un organisme qui est qui est
plus opérationnel c'est le CSR le
conseil de suivi des retraites qui est
lui
chargée de conseiller le gouvernement
sur les mises en oeuvre sur la politique
à suivre et donc c'est il y a une
mécanique très bien huilée au mois de
juin le corps rend son avis sa façon
rapport le corps fait un rapport et
début juillet avant le 14 juillet tous
les ans le CSR dis ce qu'il faut faire
et le CSR ne puis plusieurs années elle
a dit qu'il faut agir qu'il faut
réformer alors il y a eu tout un débat
sur les propos de Pierre Louis braque le
président du corps qui a qui ont chacun
y a vu ce qu'il voulait c'est à dire que
Pierre-Louis il y a pas de plusieurs
ministres de gauche voilà il est
président du corps il a été au au
Parlement et il a dit il y a pas de
problème sur les dépenses de retraite
effectivement il n'y a pas de problème
sur les dépenses mais ce qu'il faut
regarder c'est le solde c'est-à-dire
c'est pas simplement les les dépenses et
enfin les dépenses les entrées et les
sorties pour garder ce qui reste dans la
caisse or il y a un problème de soldes
et donc chacun c'est un peu attribué ses
propos en les tirant dans le sens qui
lui convenait bref
[Musique]
effectivement il y a plusieurs scénarios
plusieurs
vous avez répondu à ma dernière question
qui était est-ce qu'il y a des
expertises fiables et bien grâce à vous
et voyez vous avez bien fait de venir
parce que ça c'était quelque chose qu'on
n'avait pas encore mis complètement en
lumière mais c'est le effectivement la
référence du conseil de suivi des
retraites dernière question ma chère
Marie-Cécile qu'est-ce que vous guettez
cet après-midi qu'est-ce que vous allez
guetter sur ces images sur ce mouvement
sur les informations également qui nous
avions parviennent en dépêche et bien
sûr sur le live texte du Figaro de
violence parce que moi je pense aussi à
tous les commerçants qui sont sur ces le
passage de ces cortèges
je discutais avec une
pas trop de magasins de chocolat vous
voyez récemment qui me disait qu'elle
était désespérée elle avait une
désaffection des
de sa clientèle enfin que ça perturbe
donc je pense qu'il y a quand même une
volonté de tourner la page de passer à
autre chose parce que
voilà il y a tellement de sujets le pays
endetté il y a tellement de réformes à
faire la réforme de l'école réforme de
l'hôpital des endettés de pays donc
belle activité
et donc on attend demain cette décision
du Conseil constitutionnel alors il y a
un sujet dont on n'a pas parlé c'est le
Riponne les images de Vincent
reconnaître recommence à bouger parce
que elles ont encore pris la glace le
référendum d'initiative populaire le
Conseil constitutionnel doit aussi se
prononcer sur ce sujet donc je rappelle
que il a été déposé par des
parlementaires de gauche et c'est
parlementaires de gauche demandent dans
ce rythme que l'âge de la retraite soit
fixé à 62 ans donc
si les sages valident le principe du Rip
on rentre dans un très long processus on
va être amené encore à se voir
régulièrement parce que il faudrait que
le rip recueille 4,8
millions de signatures de soutien et
donc pour cela ils ont 9 mois donc vous
voyez que ça ouvre encore une une
fenêtre mais c'est assez bon on verra
là encore faisons un pari que
ça va être compliqué de valider parce
que ça c'est
le rythme ne serait pas suspensif de la
loi donc ça veut dire que la loi alors
retraite le gouvernement suspendent
normalement c'est pas suspensif donc la
loi s'appliquerait des septembre ça veut
dire que dès septembre il y a des gens
qui partiraient en retraite avec les
nouvelles parce que c'est ça les gens il
y a des gens qui vont partir en retraite
avec les nouvelles règles la CNAV les la
Caisse d'assurance retraite elles vont
calculer les nouvelles retraites et soit
avec un RIP au dessus de la tête qui
pourrait remettre les règles en cause
c'est assez compliqué et en plus le rip
en fixant l'âge de la retraite à 62 ans
mais il revient sur la loi Touraine la
loi Touraine de 2014 qui a été votée et
qui avait en portant à 43 à nuités le la
durée de cotisation fait que beaucoup de
personnes partent au-delà de 62 ans donc
on rentre dans un truc hyper compliqué
avec des conséquences opérationnelles
quoi comment font les caisses de
retraite en attendant c'est compliqué
c'est très compliqué c'est une question
on va on va avancer sur ces questions là
notamment tout au long des live cet
après-midi c'est pour ça que vous allez
rester avec nous on reste sur ces images
le cortège parisien qui s'était lancé
cette deuxième journée de mobilisation
il est 14h39 et un bonheur ne vient
jamais seul puisque je revois Vincent
Rozon qui est en face de moi
Vincent le cortège s'est élancé là où là
où vous êtes si vous m'entendez et pour
l'instant il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt grincheux en
tous les cas comme le temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le temps de reprendre justement
de se réinstaller effectivement il y a
toujours quand même quelques panneaux
avec quelques slogans qui qui sont
toujours
ce que sont des slogans manifestations
de slogans forts on va dire à minima
une question peut-être avant de avant
justement de se quitter Marie-Cécile
c'est que en aura un petit peu plus de
d'informations sur le sur le rythme en
tous les cas sur
ces chances
de voir le jour
peut-être non seulement avec la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel mais
également avec le soutien que que les
Français sont prêts à lui apporter parce
que le Figaro a fait un sondage dont on
connaîtra les résultats aux alentours de
17h et vous en aurez la primeur à la
fois sur le site et en direct avec
Gaëlle Slimane de l'institut odoxa qui a
fait ce sondage avec backbone Consulting
alors le rip est rentré en vigueur en
2015 et en fait aucun est allé jusqu'au
bout du processus il y en a eu plusieurs
mais aucun étalé jusqu'au bout du
processus il y en a qu'un seul qui avait
été qui a franchi l'étape du Conseil
constitutionnel c'était celui sur la
privatisation de la société Aéroport de
Paris mais sans aller jusqu'au bout mais
il avait franchi le barrage du Conseil
constitutionnel
très intéressant de voir les réponses à
la question rendez vous à partir de 17h
sur le site du Figaro merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous apporter ces réponses
on va regarder un petit peu comment ça
se passe dans dans les rues il y a des
questions qui ne peut qui nous sont
posées sur la sur la sociologie et l'âge
des manifestants certains ils sont
plutôt âgés ils sont plutôt jeunes
écoutez je vous laisse vous rendre
compte
[Musique]
sur les images la jeunesse on regarde je
vous laisse vivre ces images et on se
retrouve dans dans moins d'une minute
avec Pierre Le Peltier du service
politique du Figaro merci beaucoup
Marie-Cécile
c'est pas très c'est pas tellement
raccord avec ce qu'on entend à l'Opéra
Garnier qui est le problème de départ de
la station mais effectivement dans le
cortège en tous les cas la partie du
cortège la CFDT il y avait l'ambiance
disco qu'on retrouve dans ce genre de
manifestation à ce point-là de la
manifestation alors peut-être qu'on va
voir marine tondeuier tiens vous allez
commander ça si on l'entend
marine tondeude
responsable d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
qui est en train de parler
[Musique]
en fait ça m'arriverait rien à ni
légitimité de cette réforme 9 français
sans compte sur 10 actif depuis le début
ça continue on est très très nombreux
dans la rue non je peux pas
j'entends même pas ce que je dis
moi-même
[Musique]
on regarde pour le médecin
pourquoi le journal alors marine
Tondelier donc leader d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts justement même si elle était
couverte par le bruit qui avait autour
d'elle ce qu'elle vient de dire est
quand même assez intéressant pierre de
Pelletier bonjour bonjour
au service politique celui qui suit avec
Sophie de Ravinel
Lego les douches pastèques rouge et vert
les gauches radicales est-ce que je
voudrais vous faire revenir sur ce que
vienne dire marine Tondelier parce que
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu le
mot d'ordre de cette partie de la gauche
de la et de la nupesse par rapport au
Conseil constitutionnel oui en effet en
fait marine Tondelier vient de résumer
tout l'enjeu c'est de savoir est-ce que
la mobilisation se poursuivra après la
réponse entre guillemets du Conseil
constitutionnel si le Conseil
constitutionnel valide à 100% la réforme
des retraites est-ce qu'il y aura encore
des foules comme on peut le voir cet
après-midi à Paris
est-ce que les Français
c'est pas trop la foule mais disons
qu'il y a des cortèges est-ce que ça
sera encore en encore plus sur le déclin
c'est toute la question et donc la
gauche espère que voilà que même si
c'est approuvé
ça continuera malgré tout c'est pas
gagné marine Tondelier a dit quelque
chose qui m'a frappé parce qu'il m'a
semblé l'avoir lu également peut-être
sous votre plume
[Musique]
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
sera peut-être constitutionnelle mais
elle ne sera pas cette loi de toute
façon et cette loi sera peut-être
constitutionnelle mais illégitime
comme si il y avait une anticipation
par rapport à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel une anticipation si je
me place du point de vue des syndicats
et du point de vue de la gauche
pessimiste oui et c'est vrai que mine de
rien ce genre de discours il faut faire
aussi attention je trouve puisque on
sait très bien que dans notre pays il y
a quand même une défiance des
institutions avec le Conseil
constitutionnel donc garant de notre
Constitution le critiquer comme ça aussi
ouvertement le dire qu'il est illégitime
c'est quand même un petit peu risqué
même si ce que Marine Tondelier veut
sans doute aussi dire c'est que voilà
même si c'est approuvé par la
Constitution
il ne reste néanmoins possible de le
combattre dans la rue en continuant de
faire des mobilisations
[Musique]
voilà
est-ce que il y a
on sent qu'il y a des fissures en ce
moment à l'intérieur de la nupesse et
que certains se sont raggaardy je pense
notamment à Fabien Roussel et à son
sacre du week-end dernier où il a été
massivement investi patron lui Parti
communiste oui et en plus il a quand
même des familles aussi là de bonnes
enquêtes d'opinions pour lui il a réussi
à se faire un nom chez les Français tout
le monde sait à peu près qui il est et
il apparaît comme quelqu'un qui se
démarque un peu au sein de la nupaisse
par ses positions aussi critiques les
insoumis n'ont pas forcément aidés
pendant la les débats dans l'hémicycle
puisqu'il n'arrêtait pas enfin il y
avait beaucoup de coups d'éclats etc on
se rend compte aujourd'hui avec un peu
de recul que les Français n'ont pas
forcément approuvé ces méthodes et que
du coup ça pose la question de la
stratégie de la nupes que toujours
centré sur elle ETI le PS les Verts et
les communistes disent maintenant bon
les insoumis vous avez montré quand même
vos limites à l'Assemblée maintenant
on peut peut-être changer de méthode on
va revenir justement sur sur les
insoumis cette limite de méthode je vous
propose d'écouter marine tandelier cette
fois-ci il y a moins de bruit on
l'entend
mais après elle est votre bloquer même
après les procédures accélérées même
après 49,3 et elle le sera aussi après
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
et donc ce pays est un état très grave
quand il préoccupe beaucoup on a plaidé
auprès d'Elisabeth borne c'est
d'apaisement et cet apaisement ne peut
passer que par un recul de leur part sur
la réforme des retraites en tout cas
nous on ne reculera pas et quand je dis
nous c'est pas moi c'est pas les Verts
c'est pas les partis politiques c'est
l'ensemble des syndicats de ce pays
l'ensemble des partis progressistes de
ce pays et beaucoup beaucoup de
travailleurs de salariés même de
retraités de de soutien et de personnes
qui trouvent inadmissibles qu'on veuille
faire en fait prendre aux personnes les
deux plus belles années de leur retraite
et leur mettre à la place les deux
premières années de leur vie active
[Musique]
mais évidemment parce que ce mouvement
il d'ailleurs il dépasse largement la
question des retraites c'était quelque
part l'humiliation de trop qui a fait
que la France a relevé la tête et
descendu dans la rue mais très
sincèrement ça ne passera pas et je vois
les trésors d'énergie qui sont dépensés
par ce gouvernement de consultation
c'est trop tard de une dans Playboy dans
Playboy s'est déplacé ils sont tout pour
faire diversion pour tourner la page
pour passer la suite mais ça ne marchera
pas les Français le pays les parties les
syndicats ne sont pas prêts à passer par
la suite
il y a pas de la citrouille
j'ai l'impression que la sono n'est pas
lassée continue elle est toujours plus
fort derrière moi
un commentaire peut-être sur ces propos
de Marine tour de lier
on a l'impression qu'on s'accroche quand
même au mouvement et quand je vous
écoute je comprends mieux parce que
sinon c'est c'est pas le moment c'est il
y a moins de de d'occasions d'union
maintenant qu'il n'y en avait il y a un
an et qu'il n'y en avait à travers ce
mouvement oui on entend aussi encore une
fois Marie étant donné qu'il dit voilà
c'est pas nous c'est les syndicats qui
portent le mouvement et effectivement on
parlait de la nupaise bah voilà ce cette
réforme cette lutte contre cette réforme
des retraites c'est aussi un moyen pour
la nupette de tenter d'apparaître au
premier plan de montrer que ils sont
dans la rue et qu'ils sont assez Unis
s'il y a bien droit où ils sont assez
Unis c'est dans la rue parce que
ailleurs c'est quand même plus compliqué
même si voilà on voit des limites et
nous pour rencontrer pas mal de
responsables de gauche on voit qu'il y a
aussi beaucoup de frustration de voir
qu'en fait finalement c'est le
rassemblement national qui tire quand
même aujourd'hui les marrons du feu donc
il y a un peu de frustration il y a
peut-être aussi de l'incompréhension
est-ce que justement en voyant le
rassemblement national tiré les marrons
du feu en tous les cas dans les sondages
cette gauche
c'est gauche
se remettre en question ou son corps
dans la posture qu'on leur connaît le
mieux en disant
dans la déploration c'est assez partagé
en fait et c'est vraiment partagé entre
les insoumis et le reste de ce qu'on
observe c'est que voilà les insoumis
étaient persuadés qu'il fallait faire
monter au front à l'Assemblée quitte à
ce que ça crée un peu le bordel et les
socialistes les écologistes disent
aujourd'hui regardez le résultat
et ils disent les socialistes et les
écologistes disent regardez le résultat
au final on en profite pas du tout et
c'est Marine Le Pen et les siens qui en
profitent tous les socialistes dis ça ou
bien Olivier Faure il y avait pas une
tendance à Olivier fort à supporter les
les attitudes insoumises et puis
l'attitude la tendance meilleure Signol
d'Elga qui elle est franchement lassée
alors effectivement il y a les opposants
d'Olivier fort en interne qui n'en
peuvent plus et qui le répète
systématiquement mais on sent aussi chez
Olivier Faure et les siens donc dans le
courant majoritaire qui a quand même une
remise en question de la stratégie
insoumise il le disent et beaucoup dans
l'entourage du premier secrétaire
l'incite à se démarquer à régulariser en
condamnant un peu plus fermement les
latitudes d'insoumise alors ça c'est
avec les insoumis mais quel est
l'ambiance à l'intérieur de la nuit
certains admettent avec du recul et un
peu à froid que effectivement ce n'était
peut-être pas la meilleure stratégie
et que c'était quand même assez partagé
alors tout ça se fait sous couvert
d'anonymat parce que chez insoumis il y
a une un grand respect du collectif mais
en grande peur une grande peur du grand
chef et potentiel oui voilà aussi
potentiellement mais tu auras du grand
chef mais en tout cas certains elle le
reconnaissent et se disent effectivement
les citoyens qu'on rencontre dans la rue
ou sur les marchés nous disent vous avez
vraiment fait voilà on comprenait plus
rien ce qui se passait dans les débats
ils savent qu'ils ont une responsabilité
là-dedans
puisque vous êtes nos gauchologues j'ai
pu gauche radicale au log les plus les
plus affûtés les plus avertis j'en
profite de votre présence la mise en
scène de de de Jean-Christophe Rufin par
Mélenchon il faut il faut le français
c'est très intéressant
alors beaucoup et moi le premier c'est
vrai que j'ai un peu vu un contre-feu en
fait de Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce qu'il
faut se souvenir que cette semaine ça a
été aussi le retour d'Adrien catenin
c'est par un vote du groupe insoumis et
que ça crée quand même beaucoup de voilà
de critiques et de reproches au sein de
la nupesse et Mélenchon dit bah regardez
je fais un tweet où je dis que je peux
potentiellement me retirer pour François
Ruffin je sais que vous l'appréciez donc
c'est quand même un moyen d'allumer un
contrefeu c'est assez courant chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dès qu'il y a une
polémique de mettre ça sur un autre
terrain ce qui est très étonnant c'est
que au-delà de ça si c'était ça
Mélenchon
offre deux tabous le premier c'est dire
je ne suis plus candidat à la
présidentielle
on le lit comme ça
autour d'une virgule oui c'est ça un
tweet ça fait bizarre et en plus il nous
a habitué à toute cette ambiguïté je me
rappelle il y avait une émission sur
France 2 où il disait qu'il ne serait
pas candidat à ses succession mais en
fin d'émission il disait que ça dépendra
des circonstances enfin c'est toujours
un discours voilà il y avait beaucoup
d'ambiguïté d'interprétation chacun
l'interpelle comme il veut enfin voilà
et deuxième tahou qui sera en France
c'est surtout
apparemment François Rufin c'est quand
même une tendance qui est plutôt en
opposition avec avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et puis la tendance encore social et pas
sociétal des insoumis pourtant Mélenchon
vous avez plutôt montré qu'il suivait
plutôt cette tendance Clémentine
Otta sociétal jusqu'à présent vous voyez
peut-être qu'il observe en fait tout
simplement qu'il y a des limites en fait
à accès systématiquement sur le sociétal
et que il voit tout simplement que Rufin
en portant une voix effectivement plus
sociale en parlant des des métiers de
long invisible la ruralité la ruralité
notamment en évoquant des sujets comme
la police et ça c'est un effet c'est un
effet un petit peu d'ambiance de
manifestation c'est un effet ça c'est un
effet pierre justement manifestation
aussi peut-être
c'est vrai qu'on entend plus un François
Ruffin il est plus audible qu'une
Clémentine Autain dans ce contexte de
réforme des retraites alors que
Clémentine Autain fait également les
manifestations mais François Ruffin
incarne plus cette France qui qui entre
guillemets se lève tôt cette fois cette
gauche du travail voilà il vient de
Picardie c'est un peu il sait de quoi il
parle qui a été quand même pas mal mis à
l'écart quand même ces dernières années
enfin toute la tendance François coq et
Chantal Mouffe et Georges qui a quand
même été poussé vers
cette gauche là et incarnée par par
François Ruffin est-ce que pour autant
les insoumises considèrent comme les
vainqueurs de la séquence
c'est difficilement et parce que il le
voit bien dans les enquêtes d'opinion
donc c'est Marine Le Pen en cas de
dissolution qui qui voilà qui gagnerait
donc c'est compliqué il y a beaucoup il
y a beaucoup de frustrations quand même
alors est-ce qu'ils se disent en fait il
faut être encore plus radical ou bien
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais il faut
qu'on se calme j'ai l'impression que
c'est à discuter un petit peu avec eux
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt la
deuxième option la deuxième option qu'on
a peut-être été plutôt l'apaisement un
peu trop loin et qu'on arrêtera de faire
du salut de désormais de transformer les
rassemblée nationale en âgé de fac
justement est-ce que la jeunesse aussi
c'est pas
la contestation qui prend la jeunesse
les blocages des facs enfin tout ce que
la gauche radicale s'est fait et très
bien fait dans justement dans cette
frange de la population constitue pas un
autre enjeu pour pour ces insoumis la
gauche radicale qui se retrouvent à se
demander qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
rapport à ça et je crois qu'il y a une
frustration aussi de voir que finalement
effectivement on envoie des jeunes mais
il y a pas eu non plus des blocages de
lycée d'université massif comme on a pu
connaître dans le passé
oui c'est vrai mais en tout cas il y a
quand même une frustration que ce soit
pas un mouvement qui soit dans la durée
fin et et ils ont pas réussi à mobiliser
les jeunes
il ils ont des liens avec les syndicats
étudiants mais on voit qu'il y a moins
d'emprise qu'avant
comment on réagit à gauche face à
l'émergence de Laurent Berger
et ben alors en berger il s'en méfie un
petit peu ils savent que pour le coup il
sait pas le plus radical de la gauche
mais en même temps ils ont vu qu'il est
il dirait plutôt bien son affaire
qui avait réussi à amener des
manifestations des grandes
manifestations au début ce qui était une
surprise parce que beaucoup disaient que
les syndicats étaient morts notamment
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il avait théorisé
en disant finalement c'est fini et que
ce sera à notre tour maintenant les
insoumis de faire un grand front
populaire parce que les syndicats ça ne
se pourra plus se passer comme ça pour
un tas de raisons bon il s'est trompé
Laurent Berger l'a approuvé qu'il s'est
enfin lui a démontré que s'il était
possible donc mais il y a des il y a des
liens il discutent un peu il y a du
dialogue tout ça encore une fois
hors caméra antenne mais a priori ça se
passe plutôt bien en tout cas le
dialogue il y a un dialogue
je vous pose la question parce que il y
a quand même un phénomène que l'on voit
émerger c'est Pierre Adrien Bartoli
d'Harry s'interactive qui le fait
remarquer sur le plateau de point de vue
avec Alban Barthélemy Hardy c'est que on
voit point de en tout cas une
Macron perd énormément de soutien c'est
dans son électorat du centre gauche donc
on voit point là et en tout cas émerger
un centre gauche qui qui sortent les
mises si vous me permettez l'expression
de de Macron peut-être l'incarnation la
tendance Barbara pompidouilles ce qu'on
est en train de voir qui prend ses
distances avec Renaissance et puis
les
exaspération par rapport à la aux
insoumis et à la gauche radicale et aux
frasques des insoumis est-ce qu'il y a
pas de la création d'un espace qui
inquiète à gauche
pourraient profiter et que pour incarner
Laurent Berger bah beaucoup vont se
barrer enfin Laurent verger faisait
peut-être se parler mais beaucoup
d'autres à gauche transparer de dire
qu'il y aura un espace entre les
héritiers d'Emmanuel Macron qui seront
plus sans doute de droite Gérald
Darmanin Bruno Le Maire Édouard Philippe
et la gauche insoumise et qu'entre ces
deux entre ces deux camps il y a quand
même un large espace qui se libère et
c'est pour ça qu'on voit pas mal quand
même beaucoup de structures de structure
qui se mettent un peu en place le nom de
Laurent Berger effectivement revient
beaucoup mais il y a aussi Bernard
Cazeneuve dans cet après-midi ce qui
considère que il faut remettre une
gauche responsable de gouvernement pour
effectivement parler à tous ces
électeurs qui vont se retrouver orphelin
Carole delgat à la prison de la région
Occitanie aussi donc tout ça se
structure
c'est un peu tôt pour le dire mais il
faudra voir effectivement est-ce que ça
prend ou pas dans l'opinion
il y a une polémique qui a été en tout
cas lancé enfin autour de propos de
Gérald Darmanin et autour de la Ligue
des droits de l'homme et les subventions
qui sont versées à la Ligue des droits
de l'homme mais apparemment un franc
commun au gouvernement sur cette
question
l'humanité a lancé une pétition
en faveur de droits de l'homme contre
l'arrêt de la subvention hydro de
l'homme
il y a un front commun à gauche autour
de cette question oui quand même je
crois que c'est assez partagé beaucoup
s'en sont indignés même si voilà et
encore une fois beaucoup disent à gauche
attention par contre de ne pas trop
s'éparpiller ce qui est important c'est
ce qu'on voit là et le soutien de la
Ligue des droits de l'homme par exemple
au manifestations du du CCIF qui est
musulman radical et et islamiste enfin
en tout cas l'islam l'islam politique et
l'islam radical et
antisémite
ne suffit pas de débat et c'est
d'ailleurs une des fractures et une des
divisions de la nupes qui ce qui n'est
pas qui n'a jamais été vraiment réglé
c'est tout ce qui concerne ces questions
régaliennes ou finalement jusqu'à
présent tout ça est un peu mis sous le
tapis toutes ces questions liées à
laïcité parce qu'il y a pas vraiment eu
des débats qui se sont imposés dans
l'actualité et donc chacun essaie de
dire bon on en parlons pas trop etc on
verra ça plus tard mais on voit des voix
comme encore une fois Bernard Cazeneuve
Carole Delia qui sont quand même assez
ferme sur ces questions là et qui se
singularisent par rapport au reste de la
gauche
dans la question quelle est la suite
quel est l'enjeu pour la nups en général
et la gauche radicale en particulier il
y a une manœuvre ils ont un outil un
dernier outil c'est un peu la dernière
carte à jouer c'est le référendum
d'initiative partagée donc il doit être
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel et
si c'est le cas il faudra recueillir 4,7
millions de signatures de français pour
entre guillemets exiger un référendum à
Emmanuel Macron beaucoup commencent à y
croire et il est sondages il y en a un à
17h sur le Figaro qui est assez
intéressants sont très très intéressants
et c'est assez intéressant de voir qu'en
fait les Français déjà connaissent
l'outil et se disent prêt à s'en emparer
donc ce sera à suivre dans les prochains
mois merci beaucoup pierre et merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous nous apporter
ces éclairages c'est toujours très
intéressant et c'est toujours très
intéressant de vous lire et de lire
également les articles de caravinel vous
suivez ensemble les gauches au service
politique du Figaro ben on va peut-être
les retrouver dans la rue non peut-être
pas au niveau de la CFTC encore que il y
en a peut-être aussi des militants de
gauche dans le célèbre syndicat chrétien
on va retrouver Vincent roseron qui lui
est du côté de sud et effectivement là
la tendance est toujours un peu plus à
gauche dès que le monsieur qui est
devant lui Laura l'aura laissé par les
Vincent quelle est l'ambiance là où vous
vous trouvez
[Musique]
et bien l'ambiance est calme l'ambiance
c'est des festives ici où je me trouve
actuellement le cortège est parti depuis
à peu près trois quart d'heure
maintenant je me trouve au niveau comme
vous l'avez dit de sud sud solidaire on
a vu passer la CFDT devant la cfcgc vous
allez voir sur les images de Julien
Leclerc
vous allez voir sur ces images de Julia
on vous montre c'est ce boulevard de
l'opéra en fait on est parti de la place
de l'Opéra là c'est la suite du pouvoir
de l'Opéra qui va jusqu'à la au Louvre
au
à la rue de Rivoli que les manifestants
vont prendre ensuite et comme d'habitude
ce qui se passe c'est que le cortège
principal donc il prend la route
principale avant assez lentement et sur
les côtés sur les trottoirs si vous
pouvez le voir les gens avancent
beaucoup plus vite et donc finalement le
cortège se vide en fait par les côtés
mais il y a encore pas mal de monde même
si on a vu en arrivant que là où il y a
son semblait en baisse que le cortège
était plus clairsemé il y a toujours pas
mal de monde on essaiera un peu plus
tard mais on n'arrive pas vraiment à
l'atome parce que vous avez vu qu'il y a
quelques problèmes de réseau en ce
moment d'atteindre un peu les les
leaders politiques pour essayer de leur
poser des questions on a vu Elsa aussi
Yannick Jadot tout à l'heure qui
répondait à des questions de de
journaliste on ira aussi les voir après
et si on retourne pour voir la la place
de l'Opéra vous allez voir il y a encore
pas mal de camions qui sont stationnés
notamment les camions de FO et de la CGT
qui sont sur place avec un cortège qui
défile dans le calme avec une ambiance
ouais plutôt festive même on peut le
dire depuis maintenant 45 minutes pour
rejoindre la place de la Bastille il y a
encore pas mal de monde en tout cas sur
cette place de l'Opéra
Vincent
ce cortège en tout cas ce trajet que sur
lequel vous trouvez a été le trajet
d'une précédente manifestation celle de
fin mars du 28 mars de mémoire
et il y avait eu pas mal de
[Musique]
destruction des actions sur sur ce
parcours là apparemment vous me le
confirmez rien de tel dans ce que vous
voyez
oui rien de tel pour l'instant et pour
de ce que j'envoie parce que moi cette
manifestation du 28 mars j'y étais aussi
mais en fait quand on est à l'arrière on
ne se rend pas vraiment compte puisque
il y a vraiment 90% d'un cortège qui
avance dans le calme et ou qui ne voient
pas en fait je pense ce qui se passe
plus à l'avant pour en avoir discuté par
là avec des collègues qui eux vivent les
les manifestations à l'avant on se rend
compte que les gens à l'arrière ne
voient pas en fait tout ça ne
comprennent pas vraiment ce qui se passe
et vous parlez du du même itinéraire
c'est le alors c'est le même c'est le
même point de alors le point de départ
et le point d'arriver ont été échangés
puisque c'était un Bastille opéra là on
fait Opéra Bastille et on ne passe pas
on a changé le le chemin et c'est ça qui
est intéressant parce que le chemin
d'habitude c'est de passer par les
grands boulevards République faisait la
Bastille là on passe par la rue de
Rivoli en partant de l'Opéra et en fait
il y a un bâtiment qui est assez
important sur le chemin ou pas loin de
ce bas là c'est ce qu'on appelle le
Conseil constitutionnel vous avez bien
parlé tout à l'heure effectivement les
manifestations vont passer tout près du
Conseil const itutionnel qui ont
l'imagine qu'on passera devant tout à
l'heure est assez barricadé pour
empêcher les manifestants de manifester
devant en tout cas
merci beaucoup Vincent bonjour
Christophe cornovin je veux pas faire de
nouveaux esprits mais effectivement vu
comment est le plan de circulation
maintenant rue de Rivoli on peut mettre
des manifestants parce qu'il y a plus
aucune voiture dessus il y a pas trop de
commerçants
de ce fait
Vincent disait l'ambiance est calme
c'est un peu ce qui nous remonte des
autres
des autres en tous les cas
journalistes et envoyé spéciaux du
Figaro qui sont sur le terrain et qui
alimente en ce moment le live texte qui
est au-dessus de ce player autour de ce
player
l'ambiance c'est ce qui remonte
également au niveau de vos informations
alors
pour pour Paris manifestement bon ça
commence à la manifestation est partie
avec 14h27 nous explique les les
meilleurs sources parce que là vous avez
la musique précise
ça c'est l'état-major de la préfecture
de police qui a qui a acté le départ de
ces manifestants aujourd'hui alors pour
l'instant évidemment il est encore un
peu trop tôt pour savoir si on va si
Paris va brûler a priori ça n'en prend
pas la forme et ça va pas être un
dossier comme tel par les services de
renseignement en province il y a quand
même faut quand même faire attention il
y a quand même des petits signaux vous
voyez des images à Rennes tout à l'heure
sur certaines
chez certains confrères et l'ambiance
était quand même extrêmement tendue
notamment aux sources de certains
véhicules
où il y a eu
des mises qui est assez nouveau
généralement ils attendent vraiment la
fin de la manifestation la fin du
cortège le moment de la ce fameux moment
critique de la dislocation là à Rennes
et à Nantes il y a eu des heures assez
marqués par endroits avec les forces de
l'ordre dans un rituel qui est désormais
assez bien établie ou on a d'un côté des
blocs je crois qu'il y a de Nantes
c'était ils attendaient un bloc de
350 élément radicaux donc quand on parie
des morts radicaux on entend
cette cette constellation faite de de
d'activistes d'ultra gauche de membres
antifa de de radicaux des gilets jaunes
et de et de syndicalistes qui veulent
aller jusqu'au bout
ce que aussi la police s'appelle entre
elles les les énervés donc il y en a 350
là notamment les énervés et
et donc ce qui devait se passer arriva
donc jette bouteille jette de mortier et
puis réplique gaz lacrymogène grenade
des encerclement enfin hélas on a
presque l'impression qu'en France est
devenu une espèce de classe de rituel
qui est d'ailleurs filmé par la caméra
du monde comme une espèce de curiosité
tant maintenant ça fait partie de notre
paysage je salue Christian Léon qui nous
a qui nous a quitté à l'instant mais qui
nous disait quelque chose d'intéressant
il me posait la question
je donne cette observation il reviendra
plus tard dans les autres live mais
curieux que les syndicats ne parlent
jamais des humanitaires expatriés qui
n'ont pas leur trimestre comptabilisé
retraite
expliquer Christian Léon que il a fait 6
années et
quatre trimestres si 24 trimestres qui
ne sont pas acceptés pour des ONG que
médecin du monde et Médecins Sans
Frontières ça c'est une question
intéressante effectivement on peut-être
Marie-Cécile Renaud aussi par exemple la
procédure du Rip est accepté et que
un nombre suffisant de signatures il a
focale que 4000 et demi
auront été récoltés en faveur d'un tel
texte chassure et qui aime fortune qui
est là-il
et bien bonjour laquelle et merci d'être
avec nous on va continuer à discuter
avec vous peut-être enfin un petit point
sur les estimations quelles sont les
estimations à l'heure où on se parle
qu'est-ce qui est attendu alors
désir en fait le renseignement
territorial donc qui qui a un certain
nombre de capteurs dans les
organisations professionnelles
sur les réseaux sociaux avait estimé
véritablement une une forme de de
d'essoufflement du mouvement entre 400
et 600 000 personnes à travers le pays
et à Paris
entre 40 et 70 000 manifestants ce qui
est
ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est un vrai
recul parce qu'on est quand même c'est
presque deux à trois fois moins que le
pic du 7 mars où on était presque à 1,28
millions de manifestants
c'est-à-dire qu'on est vraiment sur une
décélération tout à fait manifeste du de
la mobilisation elle est alors elle
s'explique les raisons c'est il y a un
recul du du taux de grévistes il y a les
vacances scolaires qui viennent se
greffer à ça il y a donc vacances
scolaires pour les employés pour les
pour les fonctionnaires en particulier
les enseignants qui à un moment était
faisait le gros des troupes et qui
maintenant bon ben sont partis se
reposer en famille il y a aussi
peut-être le phénomène que dans la
mesure on est au troisième pas de
mobilisation en tout cas c'est ce qui
estime les analyses de la place Bovo ils
pensent qu'il y a une partie des
manifestants qui ont quand même regardé
leur fiche de paye et qui se sont rendus
compte quand même que la manifestation
la traduction de tout ça se réduit par
une chute du pouvoir d'achat et enfin
les caisses même les caisses de
financement des grévistes Ben se
poperise on est quand même et de 12
c'est la deuxième journée là donc il y a
tous la conjugaison tous ces événements
font que
on a moins de monde dans les rues
puisqu'on parle justement de chiffres
c'est le fil data qui fait déjà cette
qui nous donne cette information les
manifestants étaient
174000 dans les rues de l'Hexagone à 15h
contre
253000 le 6 avril dernier ce qui fait
quand même à peu près 80 000 quasiment
100000 pas 100000 mais enfin 80 au moins
80000 de moins je vous casse plus de ça
de tête et je suis lit de formation mais
et 617 mars donc
617.000 le 7 mars
253000 le 6 avril
174000 en ce moment
/ 4 par rapport au 7 mars
division par 4 par rapport au 7 mars et
ben justement c'est la conjonction de de
ce qu'on vient de dire que
il ne reste finalement que que que que
les syndicalistes peut-être les plus
endurcis on a vu que les familles
notamment en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que les les
notes de renseigne du dernière note du
service de renseignement dit que
finalement la mobilisation syndicale a
atteint un plafond qu'elle ne le
dépassera plus donc on est sur un peu
une espèce de noyau dur là qui
d'ailleurs s'est réduit à mesure que les
zones de vacances s'étendent là et
c'était la zone A on va passer à la zone
B je crois à partir de vendredi
et donc les syndicats essaient de les
organisateurs essaient de trouver une
nouvelle bouffée d'oxygène un relais de
un relais de mobilisation notamment
auprès des retraités et des familles qui
a vous en souvenez au pic au plus fort
de la mobilisation était là ils étaient
ils étaient dans les rues il y avait des
parents des enfants il y a des personnes
âgées etc mais dans la mesure où à
partir du 15 mars dernier vous avez eu
le ciel c'est tout d'un coup chargé de
nuages assez sombre et la violence a
fait un perso dans le lit de la capitale
mais des grandes villes de France ben
les gens ne viennent plus aux manifs ils
ne prennent plus aucun risque donc là
vous avez
une question que je voulais vous poser
c'est est-ce que la violence qu'on a vu
lors des dernières manifestations
effrayent certains manifestants ou bien
est-ce que comme le disait Vincent
roseron la plupart se manifestants c'est
vrai qu'ils sont parfaitement
scientifiques sont à l'arrière des
cortèges il ne voit pas ce qui se passe
à l'avant et
son
en tout cas il y a un sentiment des
appartements par rapport à ce qui se
passe et continuer leur chemin bah en
fait c'est un
peu les deux j'ai envie de dire c'est à
dire que quand vous êtes dans la
manifestation effectivement vous êtes
dans un défilé qui est encadré par les
services d'ordre des organisations
syndicales donc
ça se c'est un parcours qui est assez
maîtrisé les casseurs ils sont souvent
devant ils sont en tête de manifs à
Paris on a pu voir des têtes de cortège
donc de de casseurs avec cette
constellation
rouge et brune et le gilet jaune en plus
radicalisés brune
rouge
plutôt rouge parce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a des mails
extrêmes parce qu'en fait l'antifa les
antifas viennent parce que ils pensent
que notamment il peut y avoir des
militants d'extrême droite qui
électrisent
un peu la salle pour
pour essayer de rajouter un peu de un
peu peut-être quand je Recep mais en
tout cas dans la pour les antifas si les
antifaviennes c'est que eux sont
persuadés que il y a ça tout le monde en
a l'intime conviction si les
antifaviennes c'est qu'ils ont là ils
ont la conviction qu'il y a certainement
des gens qui viennent du camp d'en face
et
ce qui alors
justement ça m'amène à vous poser une
question il y a une polémique en tout
cas
dans une partie de la presse dans
littérature on voit ça en ce moment au
niveau de l'incendie de la porte de la
mairie de Bordeaux du palais de Rouen
on a un criminé à un moment des
groupuscules d'extrême droite ou en est
l'enquête sur ça a priori pour l'instant
c'est en fait on est que dans de la dans
de la supputation rien n'indique ce soit
effectivement des groupuscules
d'ultra-droite qui soit à l'origine de
ces de ces faits je crois pas qu'il y a
de de personnes qui soient qui soit
passé aux aveux et que des éléments
techniques a mis en évidence
l'implication formelle de tel ou telle
personne dans ce dans ce dossier donc je
pense qu'il faut toujours être prudent
surtout en matière d'incendie ce qui est
clair c'est que pour revenir sur les
violences dans les manifestations
donc quand on est dans la manifestation
on est protégé par le service d'ordre et
on voit pas trop ce qui se passe en
amont donc Vincent roseron a tout à fait
raison comme toujours
mais
en revanche ce qu'il faut observer c'est
que quand vous êtes
devant votre poste de télé notamment
quand vous regardez les chaînes tout
info ou même quand vous regardez parfois
le notre notre chaîne du du Figaro vous
pouvez voir évidemment des scènes de
violence qui elle dissuadent parce que
tout d'un coup vous êtes à proximité du
du fait et ça ça peut être de nature à
des mobiliser notamment les retraités et
les familles alors effectivement les
scènes qu'on voit voilà ça c'est la
caméra de Julien Leclerc puisque l'AFP
pour l'instant nous prive de ces images
mais on voit effectivement une ambiance
plutôt compacte ce qui explique aussi
que ces images ont été un petit peu
mais également c'est extrêmement calme
et vraiment c'est pas un mot plus haut
que l'autre et c'est vraiment en plus on
sent que là c'est vraiment de la
déambulation
en revanche on a quelques informations
qui nous parviennent il y a eu des
interventions de force de l'or plutôt en
tête de cortège avec des tentatives de
personnes qui enfin en tout cas ont
tenté de s'en prendre à des à des
vitrines et qui essayait de saisir des
pavés ce qui m'amène à la question ce
que ça c'est en lisant votre excellent
papier forcément excellent mon cher
Christophe dans le Figaro de ce jour
datait de ce jour que le dispositif lui
sécuritaire
n'a pas baissé c'est-à-dire qu'on est
avec 4200 policiers gendarmes dans la
capitale un dispositif qui était
comparable à ce qui se passait la
semaine dernière alors que je vois je
pense que c'est Yann brossa qui est au
micro de Vincent roserand on va le
prendre bien dès que
Vincent lui donne la parole
Vincent si vous nous entendez c'est à
vous et après on on y revient
oui bonjour oui je suis avec Yann
Brosset effectivement merci d'être avec
nous première question comment vous
juger la mobilisation aujourd'hui il y a
encore du monde en tout cas ce que je
vois je suis ici depuis une heure à peu
près il y a encore beaucoup de monde qui
défilent il y a beaucoup de colère et en
tout cas si le gouvernement imaginait
pouvoir tourner la page de la réforme
des retraites il se trompe il y a encore
une mobilisation qui est là et surtout
une grande colère des Français
aujourd'hui
c'est est-ce que demain si le Conseil
constitutionnel valide cette réforme
qu'est-ce qui va se passer là la
mutation ne sera pas terminée d'abord on
verra bien ce que dit le Conseil
constitutionnel mais quoi qu'il arrive
ça ne change rien au caractère
scandaleux de cette réforme sur le plan
social le Conseil constitutionnel il
juge en droit mais enfin après la
réforme peut très bien être légale et
avoir été légalement adopté et être tout
ceci scandaleux sur le plan social donc
je ne pense pas du tout que la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel fermera la
page de de la colère qui s'exprime côté
côté parti politique on imagine que vous
continuez à être unique auprès d'emmener
en fait est-ce que vous demandez à être
une nouvelle fois au Superman Macron
honnêtement le président de la
République peut nous recevoir mais tout
ça ne sert à rien on a surtout besoin je
crois maintenant de redonner la parole
aux Français c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons avec l'ensemble
des composantes de la gauche un
référendum sur ce sujet faire en sorte
que ce soit le peuple français qui
tranche du gouvernement passe son temps
à dire c'est pas la rue qui décide et
mais en faisant parler les urnes et
permettons aux Français de dire ce qu'il
pense de cette réforme oui donc ce
serait ce référendum d'initiative
partagée qui va être aussi validé par ou
pas par le Conseil constitutionnel c'est
l'autre recours que vous avez finalement
effectivement je souhaite bien entendu
que le Conseil constitutionnel valide
cette proposition de référendum
d'initiative partagée mais enfin quand
bien même ce ne serait pas le cas le
gouvernement a toujours la possibilité
d'organiser lui-même un référendum pour
permettre
aux Français de trancher cette question
qui est importante pour eux parce
qu'elle les concernent au premier chef
très bien merci beaucoup voilà Vincent
pour l'interview de Yann Brossat qui
comme vous l'avez entendu même si il
devait pas de pronostic sur ce qui se
passera demain avec le Conseil
constitutionnel nous dit que la
mobilisation n'est pas terminée et qu'il
y a encore des recours effectivement
vous n'êtes pas loin du Conseil
constitutionnel et de la rue montentier
ou les deux laberrations ont lieu en ce
moment merci beaucoup Vincent et on
l'image était parfaite on revient vers
vous des que vous avez de nouvelles
personnes à interviewer à interroger
ambiance calme dans cette partie
ambiance calme également ici place de
l'Opéra c'est partout pareil
ça parce que manifestement ce qu'on
pouvait redouter c'est comment ça à
arriver là notamment rue de rue de
Rivoli donc dans la dans cette boucle
police là en fait tu as de premier acte
de vandalisme qui ont été commis sur un
sur un magasin donc le saccage commence
on est parti on se rappelle à 14h27 donc
moins d'une heure après le départ il y a
déjà des casseurs qui
rentrent dans la qui qui passe à
l'action donc intervention des forces de
l'ordre après bon c'est peut-être un
événement sporadique mais avant même le
début de ce cortège il y a eu
sur Paris plus de
2240 et 2240 contrôle faut savoir que
ces contrôles c'est pour essayer de de
récupérer toute arme par destination
possible et utilisé par les par les
émeutiers potentiels donc la parole le
dernier jour ils avaient derrière
manifestation le 6 avril il y en avait
retrouvé des couteaux des engins de
mortiers
des cutter de la drogue bon ça c'était
pour pour les pour les les
participants aussi il y avait ils
avaient retrouvé aussi des pièces de
vélo notamment des pédales qui pouvaient
être lancé sur les sur les sur les
forces de l'ordre et
et il faut quand même se souvenir que la
semaine dernière il y avait eu plus de
150 blessés quand même dans les rangs de
la police et de la gendarmerie à travers
le pays
donc il paye quand même un assez lourd
tribu alors moi il y a une question qui
me
taraude à chaque fois que je vous
entends et à chaque fois qu'on voit les
entre quelles les scènes que vous avez
évoqué effectivement quand on va sur le
terrain c'est très fréquent de voir ses
scènes c'est une manifestation
extrêmement calme et puis un espèce de
groupuscule de Nervie qui
pillent enfin tous les cas qui cassent
qui pillent
certains commerces certains magasins de
façon très froide très extrêmement
violente
et puis il y a le phénomène de Black
Bloc pourquoi est-on toujours autant
démunis face au Black Bloc quand même on
a un pays qui combat le terrorisme et
qui est capable de les convoiter le
terrorisme en Syrie en général les
services de renseignement dans cette
performance là et bien au sein et on
n'arrive pas à savoir qui est black bloc
à infiltrer le blog et bien les ADD
comme à notre mélange alors la
folle
la difficulté en fait elle est elle est
double c'est-à-dire que en fait les
mêmes services de renseignement qui font
ça
c'est la radicalité c'est le
renseignement territorial et donc mais
la DGSI peut aussi s'occuper de certains
groupuscules de gauche ou d'ultra gauche
particulièrement
dangereux notamment ceux qui peuvent
être impliqué dans des actes de sabotage
de pylône de deux centrales électriques
etc etc il faut considérer qu'il y a à
peu près de atteint
l'écosystème de de de l'ultra gauche en
France c'est entre deux et trois mille
personnes
autour de noyau Candy ultra gauche c'est
à dire qu'il y a véritablement c'est une
constellation il y a les
les anarchos autonomes les antifas
les tous les toutes les gens qui sont
situationnistes les amis les proches du
Guy Debord enfin de la philosophie Guy
Debord enfin d'ailleurs c'est un milieu
assez
qui a pas de hiérarchie qui a une
culture du secret de la clandestinité
qui remonte aux années de plomb donc
très difficilement pénétrables à la
différence de d'autres mouvements plus
structurés hiérarchisée donc difficile à
pénétrer deuxièmement c'est des c'est
des mouvements maintenant qui
travaillent sous de plus en plus par
réseau crypté c'est à dire que ils ne se
rend compte quasiment jamais
physiquement uniquement au moment de au
moment de la manif et pour passer à
l'acte hier qu'en fait on est sur sur
des constellations des petites des
petits groupes d'un coup qui s'agrègent
pour pour passer à l'action et après ils
ont des ils ont des stratégies ils sont
très organisés c'est-à-dire que dans la
rue par exemple ils ont ce qu'on appelle
des stratégies de recomposition
perpétuelle c'est à dire que
ils sont jamais en mouvement en dans des
groupes compacts ils peuvent avoir une
forme de modularité et et et partir en
se vaporiser dans la dans parmi les
manifestants au coup de sifflet au
claquement de main il se regroupe il
passe à l'action en une minute ou deux
et après il se décidait c'est à dire
qu'il change d'allure il se rem dans le
dans le parmi les manifestants
par exemple
imaginer qu'il y a des infiltrations le
la
difficulté qu'a le préfet de police mais
quand toutes les autorités en France
c'est que pour l'instant on ne peut pas
procéder à des interpellations
préventives ce n'est pas autorisé
et les lois anti-casseurs qui avaient
été notamment
édicté ou en tout cas imaginer quand la
droite était encore aux affaires a été
cassé par le Conseil le Conseil
constitutionnel donc il y a donc c'est à
dire qu'en fait il y a quand même les
forces de l'ordre sont quand même
relativement encore démunis par par ça
et donc l'idée c'est qu'il faut
il faut attendre
hélas le passage à l'acte pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir agir une forme de
réactivité
pour ne pas avoir d'anticipation comme
dans les lois antiterroriste ENI et ni
pour ENI les lois anti-oiganes ou par
exemple vous avez des interdits de stade
là on peut pas faire on va pas qu'on
puisse imaginer qu'il y a des
interdictions de paraître à une
manifestation
en tout cas moi je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
connaissance de ce genre de de fait
peut-être une dernière question
deux dernières questions allez la
première c'est que apparemment sur
l'histoire de la dissolution des braves
m pour l'instant Gérald Darmanin veut
pas en entendre parler et là il y a ce
petit absolu d'une mise à l'intérieur à
ceux qui a absolu du ministre de
l'Intérieur puis un soutien absolu du
préfet de police Laurent Nunès il faut
quand même rappeler que les Braves ont
été créés
au moment où Paris était véritablement
au bord de l'insurrection
qu'il fallait trouver une solution pour
pour aller au contact des casseurs
essayer de ce qu'on qu'on appelle dans
le langage du maintien de l'ordre briser
les blocs briser ses backblocs qui
passent à l'action donc les braves c'est
le fer de lance de du dispositif c'est
il gagne évidemment en réactivité en
percussion parce qu'ils sont à moto et
ils se font à mon sens l'objet d'un pas
forcément d'un bon procès dans la mesure
où à la différence des Voltigeurs avec
lesquels on fait une comparaison souvent
à vasardeuse les Voltigeurs qui avaient
été impliqué en 1986 dans le décès de
manicocykin les bras même descendent de
moto avant de de de
voltigeurs les Voltigeurs
continuait à continuer à faire du
maintien de l'ordre avec leur beat ce
qu'on appelait leur bidule leur matraque
souple depuis les motos inclables m eux
sont des spécialistes du maintien de
l'ordre et ils arrivent à moto juste sur
place pour pour régler un problème en
toute réactivité et ça rejoint notre
propos précédent c'est-à-dire que quand
les Black Blocs ou les casseurs passent
à l'action eux en eux ou alors ou les
compagnies ou les pelotons
d'intervention des gendarmes mobiles ou
des CRS
interviennent en quelques minutes en
deux trois minutes maximum rhum et donc
ça c'est des éléments assez importants à
prendre en compte et juste une dernière
chose c'est que les braves quand elles
ont été créées
la
les 15 jours avant leur création donc en
2019 il y avait eu l'utilisation de 1000
flash-ball 1000 tirs de flash-ball pour
calmer la foule parce que les policiers
n'avaient pas d'autres moyens que
d'utiliser les flash-ball avec les
conséquences que l'on avait connu et les
polémique qu'on avait connu sur les
blessés les éborgner etc la mise en
place de la brave m donc avec cette
nouvelle technique de maintien de Lord a
fait qu'on a fait décélérer de manière
énorme le paysage des flash-ball
d'ailleurs vous verrez qu'on n'utilise
plus du tout dans dans Paris ou même des
immenses ont un théâtre de manifestation
depuis début du conflit et et du coup là
par exemple dès l'entrée en vigueur des
des des des bravesm on était passé de
1000 tiers de flash-ball à 30 tirs de
flash-ball donc c'est à dire que en fait
paradoxalement les bras même si ils ont
des des techniques d'interventions qui
peuvent être spectaculaires
peuvent finalement essayer de faire
baisser l'attention allez avant de
rejoindre Vincent Rozon et d'accueillir
Guillaume Rocket dans ce studio une
dernière question vous dites que le 1er
mai s'annonce aussi à haut risque mais
avant ça il y a une manie des manifs qui
sont prévus demain en début d'après-midi
à l'heure où en tout cas au moment où
dit-on le conseil institutionnel devrait
rendre son avis et là vous dites que
c'est un avis de bourrasque vous écrivez
dans le Figaro ce matin qui est lancé
dans cette perspective avis de Bourras
quand c'est pas moi qui lance ce sont
les services de renseignement qui ont
travaillé sur la question
pourquoi parce que parce qu'on a vu que
le Conseil constitutionnel d'ores et
déjà et transformer un peu comme Fort
Knox il y a des il y a des policiers
c'est il est caparationné par par des
forces de l'ordre qui sont assez
conséquentes il y a eu des gens qui ont
déjà essayé de de de de d'empiler des
poubelles devant peut-être dans l'espoir
de les enflammer surtout que la collecte
des déchets est fortement perturbé à
Paris ce jeudi donc voilà ce jeudi et
donc et donc là d'ailleurs le parcours
d'ailleurs le parcours passe
effectivement sur ces images là bas de
Vincent roserand les le Conseil
constitutionnel on est à proximité
du Palais Royal voilà on passe à côté et
et d'ici demain la tension risque
d'aller crescendo dans le quartier du
Palais royal où sont donc installés les
sages du Conseil constitutionnel la
décision est attendue demain me dit-on
vers 19h donc
19h c'est souvent l'heure où les
casseurs généralement passent à l'action
entre chien et loup avant de partir dans
des cortèges sauvages dans Paris donc je
pense que le préfet de police a sa
précisément à l'esprit en tout cas les
l'avis de bourrasque a bien été donnée
donc la donc il faudra vraiment faire
très attention dans ce périmètre là
demain et merci beaucoup Christophe
Cornavin ont merci pour toute cette
précision on va justement retrouver près
du Conseil constitutionnel Vincent
roseron qui s'y trouve qu'est-ce que
font les manifestants là autour de vous
et qu'est-ce qu'il scande mon cher
Vincent
et manifestants il nous fait un petit
détour en fait sur ce parcours qui passe
sur le boulevard de l'opéra mais en fait
l'opéra comme il y a le Conseil
constitutionnel et le Conseil
constitutionnel et ce Conseil
constitutionnel comme vous le voyez avec
des manifestants qui sont devant avec
des des gendarmes qui sont qui qui est
je garde l'entrée en fait de
très qui empêche les de passer je vois
d'ailleurs Clémentine auteur qui est en
train de faire un direct de à côté de
moi justement pour en parler mais en
tout cas voilà vous avez sur ces images
des manifestants qui sont mis devant en
fait à dispositif assez léger devant le
Conseil constitutionnel avec des gens
qui scandent mais qui repartent après on
n'a pas vu de débordement il n'y a pas
de débris il n'y a rien qui a été qui a
été lancé en tout cas tout se passe
globalement bien c'est juste que le
Conseil pardon constitutionnel était sur
le parcours et donc les manifestants ils
sont passés
merci beaucoup Vincent effectivement on
va continuer à suivre justement
l'évolution de la manifestation qui a
commencé donc ici place de l'Opéra et
qui doit arriver place de la Bastille
bonjour Guillaume bonjour Vincent
[Musique]
si vous étiez vous allez me dire que
vous n'êtes pas parce que vous êtes un
homme modeste mais si vous étiez dans la
tête de ou si vous étiez un message dans
la tête d'un de ces conseillers
qu'est-ce que vous diriez en voyant
cette manifestation
je dirais que les gens se trompent de
combat que le Conseil constitutionnel
apparaît comme une espèce de super
Parlement en fait l'idée c'est que une
loi qui a pas été
rejeté à l'Assemblée pour elle être par
cet instant comme si elle n'était pas
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
dévoiements une instance juridique qui
est juste chargée de dire ok il y a la
Constitution il y a cette loi est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est conforme oui non
moi je pense que le Conseil
constitutionnel devrait dire ben oui
cette loi elle a été non pas adoptée
mais en tout cas pas voté mais elle n'a
pas été rejetée puisque l'article 49-3
est un échec et donc dans une démocratie
c'est les représentants du peuple ce
sont les représentants du peuple qui
doivent l'emporter et donc moi j'ai
toucherai pas à cette loi et je serai un
peu malheureux de voir tous ces gens qui
sont là et qui mettent de l'espoir dans
ma décision comme si j'étais une espèce
de de d'instance d'appel c'est là qu'on
voit à quel point nos institutions
marchent un peu sur la tête mais moi ça
fait longtemps que je pense que ce
Conseil constitutionnel en tout cas dans
les prérogatives qu'il s'est accordé est
une incongruité démocratique
ça veut dire que de votre point de vue
si on poursuit la le raisonnement
la charge en tous les cas
le l'espoir que peuvent mettre certains
dans les décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel ces espoirs cette
démesure finalement
et la faute d'une certaine pratique de
la part de ce même conseil
constitutionnel oui parce que la vérité
c'est que personne ne sait ce que sera
la décision du Conseil demain à peu près
aussi imprévisible que le positionnement
politique de Robert Ménard ou que la
météo au mois d'avril et bien c'est pas
normal effectivement si vous voulez
théoriquement quand vous êtes un juriste
moi j'ai fait un peu de droit public
même si c'était déjà très longtemps si
vous voulez je devrais être capable de
vous dire ben voilà Voilà ce que dit la
Constitution voilà ce que cette loi
voilà quels sont les motifs de recours
ils doivent être en toute logique
rejeter ou non et en fait le Conseil
constitutionnel aujourd'hui il juge de
façon politique il juge de façon
subjective et à mon avis c'est une c'est
pour ça que je parle de dévoiement parce
que c'est une vieille histoire depuis le
départ du général de Gaulle le Conseil
constitutionnel s'est dirigé en forme de
de défenseur des grandes valeurs de de
la République alors qu'à mon avis les
valeurs de la République elles sont
défendues au Parlement alors je vous
propose justement de poser peut-être
cette question à Clémentine Autain qui
se retrouve qui se trouve actuellement à
côté de Vincent Rozon Vincent si vous
nous entendez et si vous êtes toujours à
côté de Clément pilotin c'est peut-être
une question que qu'on lui pose est-ce
que finalement on n'attend pas trop du
Conseil constitutionnel qui est
finalement un organe juridique
constitutionnel et qui n'a pas à avoir
de vocation politique voilà si ça ne
fiche pas
je vais voir si c'est si le réseau passe
bien parce qu'il y a quand même pas mal
de monde comme on l'a dit alors j'ai pas
tout à fait bien entendu votre question
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de bruit autour
de moi mais je crois que avoir compris
que est-ce que aujourd'hui le Conseil
constitutionnel on se trouve devant
c'est c'est important pour vous de
manifester devant est-ce que il y a une
volonté de mettre la pression
non je pense que c'est un symbole de
passer aujourd'hui devant le Conseil
constitutionnel sur le parcours de la
manifestation même si là l'avenue de
l'Opéra c'est un parcours de délestage
parce que la manifestation est dans une
autre rue en tout cas pour son parcours
initial ça veut dire qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de monde et effectivement nous
avons déposé un recours devant le
conseiller constitutionnel parce que
nous estimons que le biais par lequel
Emmanuel Macron a voulu imposer cette
loi n'est pas conforme à nos principes
constitutionnels et c'est notamment
l'utilisation du 47-1 ces fameuse
articles les Français auront découvert à
l'occasion de cette contre-réforme des
retraites et bien c'est celui qui permet
de faire une ordonnance et de s'asseoir
non seulement sur la volonté du peuple
et même sur le vote de l'Assemblée
nationale donc on estime que là il n'est
pas passé par un biais qui est un biais
correct pour plein de raisons je vais
peut-être pas étayer ici mais notamment
parce que l'impact budgétaire ne
concerne pas que 2023 et même très peu
2023 mais les années suivantes or le 47
1 c'est le budget de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif pour 2023 pas vraiment
l'objet d'une loi aussi importante donc
pour vous ça n'y est pas il y a pas de
doute demain le conseil professionnel va
le refuser c'est
[Musique]
évidemment la contestation de la loi sur
les retraites mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est aussi une prise
démocratique que traverse notre pays une
contestation du pouvoir d'un seul homme
et donc je crois pas que ça va
s'éteindre comme ça faut pas que Macron
espère que les gens vont retourner chez
eux tranquillement ça sera pas le cas
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec vous
un commentaire peut-être de lancer un
étudiant grand public que vous avez été
il m'a semblé ce qui était intéressant
dans ce que disait clémentinotin c'est
un peu l'inverse de ce que vous disiez
Guillaume sert que elle elle considère
que juridiquement
cette loi n'est pas dans tous les cas
constitutionnellement cette loi n'est
pas tenable façon de procéder pas
tenable pour les raisons juridiques et
constitutionnels mais là où il y a un
doute elle va c'est parce que c'est
juges et c'est sages ne sont pas
justement que des juristes et que il
pourrait valider cette loi alors
j'entends le raisonnement
juridique tenu par Clément pilotin
effectivement cet article 47,1 de la
Constitution qui permet de faire voter
une loi en un temps limité qui contraint
en quelque sorte les parlementaires à ne
pas déposer trop d'amendements cet
article il est supposé ne servir que
pour les lois de de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
même temps qu'est-ce que c'est que le
régime de retraite sinon une des de la
sécurité sociale et qu'est-ce que c'est
que le report de l'âge de la retraite
sinon une mesure de financement donc
objectivement on peut en débat
attre cliquez si vous voulez c'est que
évidemment si la Constitution avait été
ouvertement violet par exemple si le
président de la République avait
promulgué la loi sans sans qu'elle passe
par le Parlement là ce serait simple
mais le le Conseil constitutionnel a une
marge d'appréciation et donc dès lors
qu'il y a marge d'appréciation il y a
soupçon et effectivement si le Conseil
laisse passer la loi on dira mais c'est
normal il est Président il est présidé
par Laurent Fabius qui est associé à des
démocrate au sein du conseil il y a
Alain Juppé qui lui-même a essayé en son
temps de faire voter une réforme des
retraites donc on sera dans l'ère du
soupçon en fait il y a pas de souci
enfin en tant en tout cas on entend
cette musique montée de plus en plus
fort depuis plusieurs jours on a
notamment certains activistes qui
déclarent dans les amphis ce n'est pas
neuf politiciens qui n'ont jamais bossé
de leur vie qui vont vous dire qu'ils
vont nous dire quoi faire si la loi
légitime a passé ou pas c'est à la rue
parce qu'il y a justement là on est pas
forcément dans cette crise démocratique
alors d'abord c'est assez intéressant
d'entendre des étudiants de donner des
leçons de de de vie active au membre du
Conseil constitutionnel sachant que eux
à part mettre des poubelles devant la
fac pour éviter de passer leurs examens
et espérer avoir la moyenne de donner
par la présidente de l'Université il
peut pas dire qu'ils aient fait
grand-chose non plus donc sur le fond
oui j'ai des âgés c'est vrai c'est c'est
ça ça demande un peu de un peu de
d'énergie pour faire taire les gens qui
sont pas d'accord avec vous mais sur le
fond je pense que le le Conseil
constitutionnel de toute façon
en fait je suis pas en désaccord avec ce
qu'ils disent eux mais non pas avec cet
argument de dire qu'ils n'ont jamais
travaillé c'est évidemment pas la rue de
décider c'est à c'est tout gens qui sont
élus vous savez le général de Gaulle
disait en France la Cour suprême c'est
le peuple le peuple il a amené à
l'Assemblée une majorité et cette
majorité certes elle est relative certes
elle a pas été suffisante pour voter la
loi mais en tout cas il y avait pas de
majorité alternative pour la rejeter
alors c'est intéressant je vous disiez
la Cour suprême c'est le peuple en
citant le général de Gaulle parce qu'il
m'a semblé que le président du Conseil
constitutionnel il y a un petit peu plus
d'un an c'était fin janvier 2022 a remis
un peu en cause cette lecture de
la l'article 89 je crois de la
Constitution qui permet donc au peuple
d'avoir recours au forum notamment pour
réformer réformer la Constitution et
blanc Fabius a dit ben non ça se passe
pas comme ça et il y a pas de on peut
pas complètement utiliser le référendum
comme ça toujours pour pour réformer les
constitutions alors c'est vrai que là
pour le coup en fait si vous voulez il y
a deux oppositions différentes il y a
l'opposition entre les élus et une cour
suprême avec des juges et puis il y a la
seconde opposition qui est entre les
élus donc c'est la démocratie
représentative et puis le peuple
c'est-à-dire la démocratie directe
c'est-à-dire le référendum et
classiquement
les gens du système on va dire dont leur
va bus est un représentant éminent se
méfie du peuple parce que souvent le
peuple il pense mal parce qu'en plus le
peuple en général il est plus à droite
que Monsieur Fabius et donc ça de lui
dit rien qui vaille mais sur le principe
moi je pense que on ne peut pas trancher
ce sujet autrement que par le peuple
mais Emmanuel Macron ne fera en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de référendum même si
le la proposition de référendum
initiative populaire est accepté par le
Conseil constitutionnel vous savez qu'il
existe des moyens pour le pour le
Parlement d'éviter de de de de
demander la vie des Français il suffit
en gros d'examiner le projet une
nouvelle fois au Parlement donc ça se
réglera tout ça par les prochaines
élections et c'est en ça que
Laurent Fabius se trompe évidemment il
aimerait bien l'idée que ce soit à lui
de décider mais en fait il ne peut pas
régler ce problème parce que c'est un
problème c'est un problème politique
mais il y a deux légitimités qui
s'affrontent il y a la légitimité
immédiate de l'opinion qui dit ben nous
on veut pas de très fort avec un accord
des syndicats et puis de l'autre côté il
y a impressionnant de la République élu
c'est l'un des rares éléments qu'on a
retenu de sa campagne présidentielle
l'année dernière qui a été complètement
étouffé par le conflit ukrainien c'était
c'était cette réforme des retraites donc
les gens ils ont voté Macron alors on
dit ah oui mais ils ont voté Macron
parce qu'il voulait pas de Le Pen c'est
possible mais ils ont voté Macron quand
même donc si Monsieur Macron qui a été
élu démocratiquement dit je fais passer
cette réforme parce que elle était dans
mon programme si l'assemblée n'est pas
capable de trouver une majorité
alternative pour voter la censure du
gouvernement et bien moi je pense que la
démocratie fait que cette loi doit
passer
si on prend un peu de recul et si on
regarde un petit peu dans les semaines à
venir dans les jours dans les jours à
venir Laurent Berger soutient que ce
sera de toute façon difficile de
réformer il cite d'ailleurs un sondage
Ipsos commandé par un groupement
d'associations initiés par la CFDT 83%
des Français selon ce sondage je pense
que ce ne sera pas possible de réformer
après cette réforme oui je pense que
c'est vrai parce que
d'abord il y aura une grande de
lassitude du pays mais surtout
les les l'absence de majorité qu'on a
vécu au Parlement à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce projet de loi on risque
de la retrouver pour pour d'autres
projets et en fait c'est ça le principal
problème moi je pense pas que le pays
est bloqué par cette réforme des
retraites elle finira par passer si vous
voulez il y a de moins en moins de gens
dans les rues on le voit bien vous êtes
toujours fidèle à votre ligne beaucoup
de bruit pour rien oui mais absolument
bah écoutez j'essaye de de j'ai cette
intuition j'ai peut-être tort mais quand
je vois qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
à Marseille les syndicats annoncent 130
000 personnes et la police 6500 ça veut
dire on est en charge dans un ratio de 1
à 20 ça veut dire que les ils ont les
syndicats ont perdu le contact avec la
réalité ils sont dans leur monde ils
sont dans leur bulle avec des gens qui
ont qui manifestent par culture par
habitude ou parce qu'ils en ont la
possibilité mais que globalement oui ce
n'est pas la fin du monde je persiste à
le dire en revanche je pense que c'est
la fin du du quinquennat de Macron comme
étant la la le l'occasion de réformer le
pays parce qu'effectivement je pense que
les 1 à l'état de la société de
l'absence de majorité fait que il va
être condamné à des mesures
consensuelles or les mesures
consensuelles c'est pas des réformes si
vous voulez distribuer des cadeaux tout
le monde est capable de le faire ça vous
rend populaire un peu de frais ce qu'on
appelle une réforme c'est un changement
et un changement qui est parfois
difficile à vivre voire même douloureux
et ça je pense qu'effectivement la
situation ne permet plus d'avoir de
nouvelles réformes alors puisqu'on
parlait de Laurent Berger et
effectivement des questions de
démocratie et de et de légitimité
d'abord est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire quand justement le patron de la
CFDT dit qu'il y a aujourd'hui une crise
démocratique
moi je ne le crois pas
je pense que
la crise démocratique elle réside dans
la volonté
de court-circuiter les institutions et
il y a une crise démocratique quand on
est obligé de s'en remettre de mettre
tous ces espoirs dans le Conseil
constitutionnel qui comme si c'était une
sorte de super Parlement ou de
superenseurs alors même que ce n'est pas
son travail le il peut il y a une crise
je pense qu'il y a une crise de
confiance dans la société française mais
je pense que cette crise de confiance
elle dépasse très largement la réforme
des retraites et ça objectif
effectivement c'est pas la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron Dieu sait qu'il y a
des choses qui fait pas bien mais mais
cette cette
inquiétude vis-à-vis de l'avenir le le
cette pression sur le pouvoir d'achat
qu'entraîne l'inflation tout ça
objectivement c'est pas la faute de
Macron donc
je pense que Laurent Berger en se
focalisant sur en gros c'est un son ce
sont les sondages qui lui font dire
qu'il y a une crise démocratique parce
que il y a une loi qui est votée alors
qu'il y a une majorité des gens qui sont
contre bah oui c'est possible n'empêche
que c'est la démocratie française c'est
ce pas les instituts de sondages qui
font la loi donc non je ne le pense pas
je pense que je pense qu'il se trompe
s'il y a un problème aussi c'est que les
syndicats eux n'ont pas la capacité de
de faire changer le pouvoir c'est-à-dire
que s'il y a un problème démocratique
c'est peut-être un problème de
représentativité de Monsieur berger de
ses amis après tout il y avait toutes
les conditions réunies pour retirer
cette loi c'est la première fois depuis
très longtemps qui a fait une unité
syndicale donc tout le monde manifestait
bras dessus bras dessous et pourtant le
le gouvernement n'a pas reculé donc
c'est bien la preuve que ce sont pas les
syndicats qui en tout cas aux yeux de
nos dirigeants représentent le pays
j'allais même dire plus les Français
sont assez d'accord avec ça pourquoi
parce que souvenez-vous qu'est-ce qu'a
dit la CGT elle a dit on va on va
bloquer l'économie certains leaders et
justice par les mêmes de la mettre à
genoux bon ils n'y sont pas parvenus
parce que les Français disent on est
contre cette réforme ça c'est clair et
on n'a pas changé d'avis là-dessus pour
autant faut-il déclencher une grève
générale faut-il mettre le pays à
l'arrêt faut-il paralyser l'économie non
ça n'a jamais pris la vérité c'est que
c'est ces journées de mobilisation elle
se succèdent il se passe quoi rien on a
l'impression que ça bégaye il faut tout
votre professionnalisme pour trouver des
sujets nouveaux à aborder d'une d'une
journée de mobilisation à l'autre et
votre location
donc du coup quand berger dit l'idée que
la démocratie s'arrête aux élections et
problématique je reprends cet air
c'est une réponse Emmanuel Macron qui
conteste la légitimité des syndicats à
s'engager sur le terrain politique
vous est plutôt Macron que berger sur ce
coup-là alors oui sauf que moi j'aime
bien cette idée du référendum je pense
que là effectivement
sauf que ça nous plongerait dans une
crise politique parce qu'évidemment
Emmanuel Macron le perdrait et que là
pour le coup il serait encore plus
impuissant après qu'avant mais je pense
que si les syndicats qui sont qui
représentent à peu près je crois 6 % des
des actifs dans notre pays
devaient prendre le pouvoir là il y
aurait un problème démocratique donc la
démocratie sociale elle existe dans ce
qui concerne la vie de l'entreprise la
vie des instits des organisations au
Figaro les syndicats en leur mot à dire
pour savoir comment est-ce qu'on
organise un déménagement est-ce que il
doit y avoir une augmentation générale
vous augmentation individuelle ça c'est
normal mais le régime des retraites
c'est un c'est un sujet collectif et
donc le cette collectivité elle est
représentée par les élus à mon avis et
pas par les syndicats donc c'est pas le
donc c'est pas la légitimité
ces derniers jours de façon dans un
autre domaine ont vu le retour de DSK en
particulier de MicroScan sur Twitter son
opinion c'est qu'il faut que Emmanuel
Macron cette réforme a été une erreur en
tant que jacket
et que il faut que Emmanuel Macron
arrête de s'obstiner sur cette réforme
curieux parce que je parlais de Jacques
Attali de xtroscan Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'il est pas lâché en ce moment
par des gens qui partagent ces valeurs
comment vous regardez ça c'est vrai que
moi j'ai lu avec intérêt le texte de
Dominique Strauss-Kahn qui était assez
long parce que il les numèrent les les
quatre erreurs d'Emmanuel Macron pour
lui il y en a une cinquième ce serait de
de persévérer dans son dans son projet
et il dit notamment que ce n'était pas
Emmanuel Macron s'abrête à exactement ce
qu'a fait c'est c'est je pense pas qu'il
compte l'écouter je pense que
Dominique Strauss-Kahn que comme Jacques
Attali et dans une forme de de de
d'interrogations et presque
existentielle devant ce qui est devenu
la France je pense que il ne comprennent
plus le pays il pensait que on pouvait
réformer raisonnablement avec le soutien
des gens et en fait ça ne fonctionne pas
parce que la France n'est plus sociale
démocrate la France elle est ou bien
mondialisé et et assez libéral ou bien
dans une dans une opposition
qu'on appelle populiste de façon un peu
facile à au changement mais que le la
grille de lecture sociale démocrate
aujourd'hui elle ne fonctionne plus et
de ce fait ils disent l'un et l'autre a
donc c'est parce que c'était pas le
moment mais je pense que c'est jamais le
moment c'est jamais le moment de faire
une réforme difficile alors on peut
écouter l'argument consultant à dire ça
le fait pas des économies immédiates et
donc on pouvait très bien attendre un
peu mais il y a toujours une broc bonne
raison de pas faire une réforme ça
s'appelle la procrastination donc moi je
je vraiment en ayant attentivement le
texte de Dominique strauss-kah j'ai pas
été convaincu par le par le
développement est-ce que
il est possible
de suivre le gouvernement sur un point
enfin tous les cas est-ce qu'il est
possible de trouver des coalitions et
des accords qui je cite transforme les
clivages c'est ce que en tous les cas ce
que souhaite le gouvernement sont sa
communication officielle écoutez le
constat qu'on vient de faire ensemble
depuis 25 minutes de la situation
d'Emmanuel Macron de son gouvernement et
de sa majorité franchement n'incite pas
à monter dans la barque donc
à moins d'avoir des des des cultures
suicidaires je je me vois pas qui aurait
intérêt à rallier la majorité donc il
peut y avoir des débauchages individuels
à des gens à qui on promet un poste de
ministre ou que sais-je mais on ne voit
pas la logique de de de nouvelles
coalition en revanche on peut avoir des
des
sur votre par vote des majorités de
rencontres c'est à dire des des gens qui
disent des parlementaires qui disent bon
bah ok ça c'est pour le nuclé exactement
ce qui s'est passé pour le nucléaire ou
à la fois le rassemblement national
peut-être se passer alors je ne sais pas
parce que là c'est pour le coup un vote
très très personnel et donc il y a pas
de logique de partie malheureusement je
n'exclus pas je crains fort que le
l'angoisse
qui compréhensible même si à mon avis
elle entraîne de mauvaises décisions
l'angoisse par rapport à la mort et au
grand âge ne incite les parlementaires
à voter une loi qui à mon avis est pas
la bonne réponse à cette inquiétude
légitime donc ça peut marcher là-dessus
mais honnêtement est-ce que le problème
de la France aujourd'hui c'est c'est le
problème du suicide assisté honnêtement
je pense pas donc
si si c'est ça la seule capacité de
réforme qui reste à Emmanuel Macron
c'est vraiment qu'on est tombé bien bas
une prise de parole est espérée par les
troubles du président doit-il a-t-il
intérêt à s'exprimer
écoutez la dernière fois qui Emmanuel
Macron a pris la parole c'était pour
expliquer que
le la Chine avait peut-être pas tort de
de vouloir encercler Taïwan j'ai
caricature un petit peu parce que c'est
pas ça mais en gros en disant monsieur
réagissons pas à la position chinoise le
monde entier a commencé par les
Européens on dit mais de quoi il parle
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça ça va plus
donc il faut d'abord que mon avis qui
Emmanuel Macron
et une perspective a donné et
aujourd'hui je vois pas quelle peut-être
d'ailleurs quand il a pris la parole au
Pays-Bas donc c'était en fait l'avant
dernière fois la prise de parole sur le
sur Taïwan il a dit bah écoutez voilà il
faut que cette réforme aille jusqu'au
bout donc
il peut nous parler mais si c'est comme
la dernière fois c'était quand le quand
il est intervenu à la mi-journée devant
nos confrères de de de chaîne de
télévision il a dit je suis droit dans
mes bottes pour faire court donc il a
aussi plutôt pas pour moi je pense que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est devenu
inaudible donc honnêtement ça ressemble
à ça ressemble à une impasse cette
histoire oui
ça c'est certain
Mafa il a dit des choses qui étaient qui
ressemblaient à rétropédalage quelques
jours plus tard donc le problème
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que il peut pas
reculer sur cette réforme mais il peut
plus avancer non plus donc qu'est-ce
qu'il fait
un remaniement justement ministériel ce
serait une bonne idée
je je pense que ça ne changerait rien
sauf si le gouvernement et le reflet
d'une nouvelle majorité mais je veux
honnêtement aujourd'hui je la vois pas
un excellent journal qui s'appelle Le
Figaro Magazine et dans lequel il y a un
portrait de Gabriel Attal on voit en
portrait en creux de quelqu'un qui
indique ne pourrait pas avoir
une pas avoir un remplaçant on se
demande quand même si c'est pas la
tentation à l'Élysée là en ce moment
alors c'est en tout cas ça fait partie
des des possibilités
Gabriel Attal est un des jokers de
d'Emmanuel Macron qui n'en a plus
beaucoup c'est pour ça qu'on a on s'est
intéressé à lui en plus c'est un c'est
un homme brillant qui fait jusqu'à
présent un parcours sans faute mais je
ne vois pas en quoi un changement de
Premier ministre provoquerait le choc
susceptible de nous faire sortir de
cette crise en plus Elizabeth borne bien
sûr est extrêmement affaibli par cette
séquence législative mais pour autant
s'en séparer aujourd'hui ce serait une
forme d'aveu d'échec pour Emmanuel
Macron donc je ne suis pas certain qu'il
le fera imm édiatement en tout cas il
faut qu'il le fasse il faut que ce soit
un paquet si vous voulez un mauvais
français c'est-à-dire il peut y avoir un
nouveau Premier ministre à condition qui
est un des réformes précises et
l'assurance d'avoir la majorité pour les
voter et aujourd'hui cette feuille de
route elle n'est pas écrite faut-il
qu'il poursuive si les dispositions sont
validées c'est à dire qu'ils promulgue
très vite ou qu'il respecte une forme
pour reprendre une expression je crois
des abats de borne de convalescence
c'est une bonne question
je pense que je pense que je pense qu'il
ça ne coûte pas grand chose d'attendre
un peu toute façon donc vous n'êtes pas
vous pensez qu'il faut pas faire une
promulgation rapide dès que je pense que
je pense que ça paraîtrait comme une
sorte de de provocation
vous savez on vit dans l'air de
l'immédiateté ou une crise en chassu
neutre un sujet un autre donc peut-être
que attendre attendre quelques semaines
je sais pas s'il faut attendre jusqu'au
grandes vacances c'est peut-être un
petit peu tardif mais en tout cas ce
serait une façon de calmer l'opinion
sans que le Président de la République
ne se dégage puisque sur le principe on
sait qu'il va la promulguer cette loi si
il continue
en tout cas si
ils réforme quelle réforme
il devrait entreprendre
tout cet ensemble est validé
je pense que les réformes indispensables
il ne peut plus les faire il est de
toute évidence il faut enrayer
l'immigration massive dans notre pays il
a expliqué que la loi n'allait pas être
vécue tout de suite alors on nous dit
qu'on pourrait avoir un changement sur
le RSA en le rendant en rendant le
versement de ce revenu
lié obligatoirement à une forme
d'activité
honnêtement ça va encore ouvrir un front
social donc non mais la seule chose que
tu vois oui absolument ce que je vois
simplement c'est des mesures
consensuelles par exemple la traduction
dans la loi de cet accord national
interprofessionnel qui fait que le
partage des bénéfices quand tu en as
sera plus facile à travers des
différentes mesures de d'intéressement
qui seront plus largement ouvertes au
PME qu'aujourd'hui donc je vois des
choses comme ça mais mais pour le reste
je pense que le le les syndicats sont
accro et on peut les comprendre puisque
Emmanuel Macron les a ignorés et la
majorité fragile donc je le vois mal
prendre des risques je suis désolé parce
que j'aimerais bien répondre à votre
question mais mais je pense qu'on est
vraiment dans une impasse là vous y avez
répondu merci beaucoup toujours avec
franchise avec clarté et avec éloquence
c'est pour ça qu'on se prive pas du
plaisir de vous avoir de nouveau demain
en direct à 17h pour point de vue pour
passer pour repasser la semaine en revue
ce sera avec l'excellente Timothée de
lait merci beaucoup Guillaume et je
signale donc le nouveau numéro du Figaro
Magazine qui cette semaine qui cette
semaine est consacrée à
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty avec les
bonnes feuilles du livre de Stephen ciel
le livre du du journaliste est
producteur Stéphane Simon qui a eu accès
à tout ce dossier et qui nous montre que
il y a vraiment eu un dysfonctionnement
majeur c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
scandale d'État parce que les les
menaces sur Samuel Paty étaient connus à
la fois par sa hiérarchie à l'éducation
nationale et par les services de
sécurité et pourtant il n'a pas été
suffisamment protégé et on essaiera de
revenir justement avec Stephen Simon
également merci beaucoup Guillaume donc
c'est à retrouver en une du figure au
magazine qui paraît ce week-end et dont
les premiers du papier sont accessibles
sur le site du Figaro on va retrouver
Vincent Rosemont qui me semble-t-il
n'est pas loin de la rue de Rivoli pas
loin du palais royal et du musée du
Louvre quelle est l'ambiance mon cher
Vincent
et bien l'ambiance est toujours festive
ici une ambiance assez calme assez
joyeuse vous pouvez le voir même devant
le Conseil constitutionnel il y a eu des
champs il y a eu des fumigènes qui ont
été craqués devant des devants des
policiers et pour autant l'ambiance ne
s'est pas tendus on a pas vu en tout cas
nous de débordements de ce qui s'est
passé on a vu une scène assez cocasse
c'était des gens qui étaient aux
fenêtres du Conseil constitutionnel qui
devait sûrement travailler qui ont vu de
leurs yeux c'est manifestants qui
étaient devant eux et qui et qui voilà
qui manifester qui qui chantait en fait
sous leur fenêtres et là vous voyez donc
ce cortège qui continue d'avancer vous
voyez sur les images je viens Leclerc
peut-être tout au fond là-bas c'est la
place de l'Opéra dont on est parti et là
on arrive au niveau du du musée du
Louvre et on va prendre le croisement
pour prendre la rue de Rivoli et en fait
effectivement c'est la fin du cortège
qui est ici mais il y a eu un autre
cortège un cortège de délestage on
appelle ça comme depuis le début des
manifestations pour que tout le monde
puisse atteindre le comment dire le la
place de la Bastille puisque nous sommes
partis depuis deux heures et nous avons
fait et nous nous avons dû faire un
tiers du trajet pour l'instant il y a un
deuxième chemin qui est ouvert par
exemple qui a emprunté la CGT
merci beaucoup Vincent et bien justement
la CGT et son parcours on va y revenir
alors qu'on voit Éric Coquerel qui est
derrière vous et toujours fidèle au
manifestations on vient dans en parler
et bien sûr si vous avez quelqu'un
d'autre vous nous le dites on est
jusqu'à 16h20 avec vous mon cher Thomas
en grand bonjour
vous êtes le spécialiste des syndicats
aux Figaro et au Figaro économie
attention vous voyez ça c'est tellement
de qualité que ça j'entends on va la
renverse ou en tous les cas sur mon
micro
on parlait justement de syndicats à cran
on parle de la CGT quel est l'état
d'esprit en ce moment des syndicats
alors ben officiellement ils sont
toujours aussi déterminés enfin après
mais faut reconnaître qu'ils en sont
alors 12e journée la participation a été
déjà en baisse lors de la dernière
journée la onzième le 6 et là les
chiffres pour le moment première remonte
tes terrains laisse encore présager une
nouvelle chute de la mobilisation donc
il y a quand même un sentiment de de
crépuscule en tout cas des mobilisations
voilà c'est sur sur ces dernières
semaines donc forcément est-ce que chez
certains sacrés de la résignation chez
d'autres ça peut peut-être créer de la
tension ou de l'énervement donc voilà ça
ait des sentiments mitigés entre les
différents syndicats aussi en fonction
de ce qui joue et de leur état d'esprit
eux-mêmes leur capacité à dialoguer
alors certains internautes je salue un
vol pas vu qui nous a rejoue rejoint il
y a vraiment peu de monde mais
[Musique]
et que il y a il y a peu de monde c'est
ce que souligne que de braves gens par
contre à défiler le monde du travail
alors ça c'est ce que nous dit Requiem
et ça on verra
avec Arthur bujota qui est en train de
faire des estimations c'est très
intéressant qui manifeste et qu'elle est
justement le profil des manifestants et
des manifestants est-ce que ces
syndicats malgré précisément cette cet
état d'esprit que vous décrivez
savent gré à Elisabeth borne de ses
prises de position un peu en rupture
avec Emmanuel Macron en clair son appel
à l'apaisement
alors on va dire que les seuls qui
s'expriment un minimum dessus c'est
plutôt les réformistes qui reconnaissent
plus facilement aussi quand il y a un
pas dans le bon sens de la part du
gouvernement effectivement Laurent
Berger s'était notamment exprimé pour
remercier et puis pour soutenir la
démarche d'Elisabeth borne après il est
vrai que
petit geste petit mot dans un sens dans
l'autre pour eux de toute façon il y a
qu'un seul et même et même s'objet c'est
le retrait des 64 ans alors oui les
réformistes sont plutôt tendance à
féliciter mais presque les plus radicaux
sont en train de dire attention ils y
voir en fait ils se voient une russe de
Elisabeth borne pour tenter d'amadouer
les réformistes pour tenter de les
caresser dans le sens du poil donc les
réformistes fecgc
voilà exactement
alors ce qui est un peu particulier
c'est comme on est en inter syndicale on
sent bien que en plus souvent en tête de
cortège où j'étais encore tout à l'heure
ils sont tous les uns à côté des autres
et alors ça montre une très belle unité
mais on a aussi un peu l'impression que
chacun surveille ce que dit l'autre et
donc forcément c'est pas du tout le bon
moment pour se laisser aller à des
confidences et
un peu des techniques des réflexions des
machins donc effectivement pour le
moment sur le papier la question ne se
pose pas 64 ans on en veut pas pour
l'instant donc vous restez bien affûté
pour que on sache bien qu'elle va être
l'état d'esprit oui oui non non bien sûr
pour l'instant ça reste ferme du côté
c'est quand même l'un des l'un des
phénomènes quand même les plus je
trouvais les plus intéressants de depuis
le 19 janvier c'est cette fermeté des
syndicats réformistes est-ce que
derrière ça ça ne traduit pas également
quelque chose de plus profond et une
évolution de une évolution de la société
pas une radicalisation mais en tous les
cas quelque chose qu'on peut peut-être
mettre en rapport avec le déclassement
avec la crise du pouvoir d'achat alors
sûrement il y a effectivement quelque
chose de si je puis dire de long terme
de réflexion d'évolution systémique de
la société il y a même il y a peut-être
quelque chose aussi de plus court terme
et qu'on sent bien qui édite souvent de
façon implicite jamais
en ne posant jamais des mots dessus mais
on sent quand même que il y a une sorte
de colère particulière chez les
syndicats et j'ai beaucoup de gens
envers Emmanuel Macron en particulier et
la méthode Macron Macron s'est fait
élire quand même avec une idée de
renouveau et en mettant en place des
personnes qui avaient pas forcément
d'expérience politique c'était
d'ailleurs ce qu'il l'a mis en avant en
disant des gens qui connaissent
l'entreprise des gens comme ça et c'est
vrai que résultat les syndicats qui
quand même aiment bien l'organisation
des discussions collectives avec l'État
enfin des choses un peu normées qui
depuis de nombreuses années là se sont
retrouvés à pas forcément être entendu à
avoir des en face d'eux des gens qui
avaient pas forcément la bonne méthode
et ça les a tendus il y a ils ont
l'impression de pas pouvoir s'exprimer
et donc je pense qu'aussi au travers de
cette retraite il y a un peu tout cette
colère accumulée cette frustration
accumulée aussi qui se libère voilà et
donc ça explique aussi pourquoi même les
plus réformistes se ont des positions
effectivement très dur
16h11 sur le site du Figaro deux
informations d'abord une tension qui est
en train de monter au niveau de hôtel de
ville c'est en tout cas ce que nos
rapports les autres journalistes du
Figaro qui sont sur place et qui
alimente notamment le lifetex qui est au
dessus de ce player et un chiffre on y
reviendra dans dans une dizaine de
minutes avec Arthur bijouta les
manifestants sont à 16 heures étaient
201000 dans les rues de la dans les rues
de France ils étaient presque 100 000 de
plus 291000 le 6 avril dernier et ils
étaient 719
000 à 7 heures là le 7 mars jour de
pique de la manifestant si on 719000
donc à 16h le 7 mars aujourd'hui ils
sont 220 000 très clairement
forte chute est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
influe sur le moral des syndicats et des
dirigeants syndicaux forcément ça a une
influence énorme et surtout c'est une
influence sur ce qu'ils vont décider
pour la suite parce que on a imaginé à
plusieurs reprises que l'Inter syndicale
a laissé friter que la mobilisation
enfin que les syndicats allaient un peu
lâché l'affaire et en fait effectivement
ils ont été plusieurs reprises rebooster
par une mobilisation qui ne faiblissait
pas notamment au moment du 49-3 et à
d'autres étapes aussi importantes
là en revanche on voit que il y a une
décrue de la mobilisation qui a l'air
cette fois c'est durable et qui qui
paraît être un point final et donc
forcément on se pose beaucoup à la
question est-ce que c'est la dernière
date aujourd'hui ce qu'il y en aura
d'autres la mauvaise mobilisation laisse
à penser que ça va ils vont être
moyennement motivés pour reprendre le
risque en faire une autre la semaine
prochaine
est-ce que il y a pas de phénomènes qui
peuvent faire évoluer d'abord la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel un
avis de bourrasque est attendu par les
services de renseignement et de lancer
par les services de renseignement c'est
ce que nous disait tout à l'heure
Christophe cornova deuxième chose
le 11 février dernier
ici on voyait on était un week-end de
vacances on voyait que la mobilisation
décroissée je vais retrouver les
chiffres dans un instant et puis il y a
eu la mobilisation du 7 mars et puis il
y a eu le 49-3 et ça relançait
éradicaliser la manifestation est-ce que
il y a pas aussi
ce scénario là en tous les cas qui est
en tête dans les états majors syndicaux
ah si c'est une éventualité surtout je
pense que c'est ce dont rêve les plus
radicaux qui ont pas envie de laisser
tomber donc toujours CGT solidaire eux
qui ont pas envie de laisser tomber peu
importe la réponse du Conseil
constitutionnel donc voilà après
cette fois effectivement d'autres font
le pari que cette décrue sera des
dernières de toute façon depuis le début
et comme tout comme dans tout mouvement
social on sait qu'il y a un début un
milieu une fin ça dure pas six ans un
mouvement social donc on savait qu'il
allait s'arrêter bon et il y a aussi
autre chose c'est que lors du 11 février
on avait effectivement vu une des décrue
progressif là ce qui change c'est qu'on
arrive quand même au bout de tout cette
processus législative légale qui va
amener
qui va amener en fait à l'aboutissement
et à la mise en application de la loi
donc il y a de moins en moins de sens de
continuer à mobiliser et à manifester
dans les semaines qui suivent je pense
que les réformistes si le Conseil
constitutionnel
leur laisse la possibilité de faire le
fameux RIP le référendum d'initiative
partagé il trouveront ça ils y
trouveront une sorte de porte de sortie
de moyen de dire bon on arrête les
mobilisations en plus ça arrête pas de
descendre donc on va se ridiculiser
maintenant on se concentre sur cette
nouvelle objectif et la et d'essayer de
réunir quasiment 5 millions de
signatures et voilà et donc on va se
diriger vers toujours une contestation
des retraites mais dans
d'une forme différente donc
effectivement c'est plutôt maintenant on
tape plutôt on parie sur
le rip et avec une possibilité enfin il
faut encore faut-il que la démarche soit
validée par le tout à fait ça c'est
l'autre décision qui est exactement
est-ce que le Conseil constitutionnel va
valider bon et puis après ils exclut
rien ça dépendra aussi de les remonter
le terrain voilà mais c'est vrai que on
peut se poser la question de savoir si
on n'a pas la dernière journée de
mobilisation avant éventuellement le 1er
mai journée du travail ou les syndicats
comptent déjà faire beaucoup de bruit
autour de ça de le faire de façon
unifiée pour voilà un peu marquer le
coup et toujours marqué leur présence
alors il y en a un qui persiste et signe
et j'ai vu ça en vous lisant
Thomas c'est Laurent Berger il y a une
crise démocratique il la redit hier et
on a l'impression qu'il est prêt à
élargir le débat et à rester surtout sur
le terrain politique en tout cas élargir
son propre terrain on l'a vu entière
avec une confiance de presse où il était
à côté du Réseau Action Climat et la
Fondation Abbé Pierre effectivement
c'est vrai que certains dans le milieu
politique
pensent que Laurent Berger réfléchirait
à une sorte de reconversion une attirée
par le monde politique c'est vrai qu'ils
jouent d'une très bonne popularité il a
l'habitude des caméras il a un
positionnement
particulier et un peu politiquement vide
je suis pas forcément un expert du sujet
mais c'est vrai qu'il se retrouve dans
une sorte de centre gauche qui est
aujourd'hui et à mi-chemin entre Macron
et la LFI et qui a pas forcément
d'espace donc effectivement ça c'est
beaucoup de conjonctions qu'il a sa
pensée que ça pourrait être intéressant
pour lui lui a toujours fermement
démenti cette idée là
il s'est dit pas du tout intéressé il a
toujours dit qu'on pouvait agir sur le
politique sans être un politique
donc c'est l'idée dominante après c'est
connu quelqu'un qui disait ça pas mal
mais c'était à droite ça s'appelait Éric
Zemmour donc
sur Laurent Berger en tout cas lui il
s'en défend il a bien conscience que
cette conférence avec le pack de pouvoir
de vivre qui réunit 64 associations dont
la CFDT ressemble à une sorte de de
tremplin ils ont les journalistes autour
lui ont fait remarquer il a botté en
touche en disant qu'il doutait que ça
provoquerait ça mais qui ils s'en fiche
quoi si je puis dire voilà donc il reste
fermement ancré sur cette position après
je suis pas encore allé sonder
l'intérieur de son cerveau j'ai pas
cette capacité mais bon il reste sur le
papier fermement il exclut fermement
cette possibilité de
de se lancer dans la politique après
16h18 il me reste pas moins de 2 minutes
et quelques petites questions à vous
poser chers Thomas est-ce que le front
syndical va rester uni va-t-il rester
unis parce que pour l'instant il y a
peut-être du désenchantement mais enfin
il y a toujours cette unité syndicale
alors sur la question des retraites
c'est fort probable parce que je pense
que même les plus radicaux même s'il y
aura des désaccords sur la semaine
prochaine sur faut-il faire de nouvelles
mobilisation ou pas tout le monde parmi
les syndicats à réaliser à quel point le
fait d'avoir été groupé avec permis
d'obtenir enfin de faire tout ce qu'ils
ont fait ils me racontait effectivement
un peu les coulisses de la rencontre
avec borne qui a eu lieu la semaine
dernière il disait on a très bien senti
je crois que c'était François omril de
la CFE-CGC le syndicat des cadres qui me
disait on a très bien senti même
physiquement la force qu'on avait quand
on était 8 parce que les 8 organisations
syndicales face à trois à trois
ministres quand c'est tout ça si d'un
coup quand on sait tous levé d'un coup
pour quitter la salle oui ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'aurait jamais eu
si on était en hors dispersé donc je
pense que même s'il y a des désaccords
même voilà sur cette question des
retraites en tout cas ils vont rester
très unis et dans le futur ils feront
sûrement d'autres projets mais est-ce
que il resteront éternellement comme ça
j'en sais rien
les syndicats quand ils répondent
favorablement ça sera ma dernière
question à la proposition de rencontre
d'Emmanuel Macron après la vie du
Conseil constitutionnel alors pour le
moment ce qui répète c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas eu d'invitation en bonne et due
forme il y a eu un communiqué de presse
de d'Emmanuel Macron pour dire qu'il
laissait à portes ouvertes donc déjà ils
attendent l'invitation et s'il la
reçoivent bien qu'en fait beaucoup de
disent que ils avaient la ils doivent en
parler entre eux ils n'ont pas encore
fait mais ils adopteront la posture
qu'ils ont eu quand ils ont rencontré
Elisabeth borne à Matignon c'est-à-dire
nous on y va parce qu'on ne refuse pas
une main tendue maintenant qu'on soit
très clair on y va pour parler retraite
pour parler 64 ans si au bout de 10
minutes le Président nous dit c'est pas
possible
voilà donc c'est probablement
effectivement ce qui va se passer mais
encore une fois ils attendent
l'invitation en bonne et due forme et
pour cela il faut qu'il d'abord la vie
du Conseil constitutionnel on disait
tout à l'heure c'était les informations
tous les cas de Christophe Cornavin
demain vendredi aux alentours de 19h
merci beaucoup Thomas André c'est d'être
venu encore nous expliquer nous donner
vos informations vos explications votre
éclairage sur le plateau du Figaro et
bien voilà caméra de Julien Leclerc qui
avance avec la dextérité même d'une
GoPro ce qui prouve l'agilité de celui
qui détient ce qui nous étonne pas de ce
cher Julien et on va retrouver Vincent
roserand il me semble que Vincent Rozon
était avec Julien Bayou alors s'il était
avec Julien Bayo et bien on va les
écouter et sinon on va demander des
éléments d'ambiance
oui on va on va on est avec Julien Bayou
député Europe Écologie merci d'être avec
nous déjà comment vous jugez le nombre
de personnes qui sont là aujourd'hui
c'est très très encourageant c'est à
dire que on nous avait prédit que tout
allait s'effondrer et en vérité
aujourd'hui on sait bien que c'est une
mobilisation
qu'elle avait de la décision fatale du
Conseil constitutionnel la décision
cruciale et il y a beaucoup de monde
voilà moi j'étais tout à l'heure à
l'Opéra là on voit la fin du premier
cortège il y en a un deuxième qui est
passé plus au nord il y a du monde voilà
il y a du monde on nous avait prédict ça
tient ça tient et vraiment l'Inter
syndical ça tient la nouvelle union
populaire réfugiée sociale ça tient on
se sent bien que on n'est pas prêt à
passer à autre chose il faut pas mettre
en place cette réforme et vous disiez
demain c'est une journée fatale sur le
sujet pour Momo le Conseil
constitutionnel si ils disent de la de
la valider vous pour vous ça va
continuer quand même
moi je suis très inquiet voilà en 2003
en 2006 Jacques Chirac a eu
l'intelligence de retirer le contrat
premier embauche après la fin de tout le
parcours législatif je dis intelligence
parce que le pays était sous le stand
tension et ça n'avait rien à voir avec
aujourd'hui le pays était crispé braqué
contre cette réforme qui à l'époque
était vraiment une un camouflet à la
jeunesse là aujourd'hui j'ai pas le
sentiment qu'Emmanuel Macron et la
moindre intelligence sociale vous voyez
collective déjà j'ai l'impression qu'il
fuit le pays
qui profite d'être à l'étranger pour
insulter ou encore provoquer j'ai vu à
l'Assemblée la première ministre en
perte de vitesse complet même pas
applaudi par ces troupes il y a pas de
cap on a l'impression que le
gouvernement c'est un bocal de
grenouille il y a plus de couvercle
chacun déjà est candidat pour 2027 ou
avant enfin vraiment c'est pas tenu vous
voyez et le pays est sous tension encore
une fois les syndicats et laupes
tiennent une responsabilité
mais c'est vrai que si
demain le Conseil constitutionnel envoie
comme ça valdinguer tous les moyens
qu'on a soulevés je pense qu'on peut
basculer dans quelque chose d'inquiétant
voilà je le souhaite pas je suis avocat
et député deux raisons de respecter la
Cour suprême le Conseil constitutionnel
mais vraiment si par exemple le
référendum d'initiatique partagé et pas
validé
ça va être très compliqué de comprendre
en fait ça n'est pas compréhensible donc
c'est aussi ça le futur recours ce sera
ce référendum vous appelez Emmanuel
Macron finalement à accepter ce
référendum lui aussi
c'est ça la vérité en fait et d'ailleurs
c'est deux breaks qui disait et c'était
pas quelqu'un de la mups c'était pas non
plus un syndicaliste mais il disait
quand il y a comme ça un blocage aussi
complet entre l'exécutif et législatif
il faut élargir la discussion ça veut
dire retour au peuple dissolution nous
sommes prêts ou référendum c'est le plus
simple oui non à cette satanée réformes
on connaît la réponse donc en fait c'est
ça veut dire que c'est le président qui
s'entête et il s'entête contre l'intérêt
du pays voyez je prends deux exemples si
vous me laissez ça peut paraître
anecdotique mais le président qui se
déplace au Pays-Bas et qui est hué c'est
notre diplomatie qui est mise à mal
c'est notre réputation internationale
qu'on soit pas en mesure d'accueillir le
roi Charles quoi qu'on en pense
c'est notre principal allié sa mère
Elisabeth était venue en France pour sa
première visite d'État et nous nous ne
sommes pas capables de l'accueillir il
va à Berlin
signal faible mais sadique quelque chose
que l'entêtement du président mais le
pays sous tension dans son ensemble tous
les actifs y compris les entreprises et
les salariés mais même jusqu'à
l'international et je trouve vraiment
que c'est déraisonnable de la part du
Président c'est pas seulement grave pour
lui c'est grave pour le pays et s'il y a
une nouvelle joie immobilisation la
semaine prochaine malgré ce qui se passe
au Conseil constitutionnel il y en aura
pour vous c'est inévitable moi je
souhaite que le référendum on en est pas
besoin puisque la loi soit censurée il y
a tous les motifs pour censurer la loi
il y a eu des détournements de procédure
il y a eu un musulman de l'assemblée il
y a eu un verrouillage du Sénat il y a
pas d'étude d'empathe c'est pas vrai on
ne sait pas vous dire il y a eu des
mensonges il y a beaucoup de gens qui
croient encore que comme le disait du
soft c'est 1200 euros pour tout le monde
en fin de carrière c'est pas vrai il y a
eu des mentions j'ai eu c'est mal
embauché c'est mal organisé bon il y a
toutes les raisons de censurer
profondément ce projet de loi à défaut
de faire le référendum initiative
partagé
moi j'y vois une très belle peur de
sortie là où le président décide tout
d'en haut nous parlementaire organisons
avec la population 5 millions de
signatures voyez ça ça monte d'en bas et
il veut verrouiller la cinquième on
offre la sixième il veut asphyxer la
démocratie on veut la revivifier c'est
c'est 5 millions il va falloir aussi les
obtenir
je demande que ça c'est pour ça que je
vous dissolution on est prêt référendum
on est prêt vous voyez c'est quand même
plus simple de signer une pétition pour
un référendum que de manifester il y a
eu des millions de personnes qui ont
manifester il y a eu des millions de
personnes qui ont donné un jour de
salaire contre cette réforme nous allons
y arriver mais simplement la vérité
c'est que cette réforme elle ne doit pas
passer et le plus simple c'est de la
censurer c'est bien merci Monsieur voilà
Vincent nous étions donc avec Julien
Bayou et on est sommes à la fin de la
manifestation c'est pour ça que vous
voyez vous voyez derrière l'interview il
y avait les membres de robocopie levers
qui rangeaient les affaires puisque
comme on vous le dit aussi depuis le
début de cette manifestation il y a eu
deux cortèges un premier cortège qu'il a
et rue de Rivoli et qui se dirige vers
Bastille et un deuxième qui passe plus
au nord ou par exemple il y a force
Ouvrière ou encore la CGT effectivement
il y a aussi merci beaucoup Vincent des
heures au niveau du de l'hôtel de ville
en tous les cas il y a eu des des
lacrymos qui ont été tirés à ce
moment-là donc bien entendu vous prenez
soin de vous et on va continuer à suivre
cette situation
au fur et à mesure que le cortège
continue d'avancer alors j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à côté de moi outre les
internautes du Figaro alors qu'on voit
justement la le lieu d'arriver qui la
place de la Bastille pour l'instant où
le cortège n'est pas encore arrivé
Arthur bijouta du Figaro dateur qui
nous a rejoint et je salue grumeaux pas
de 75 et
déjà qui nous ont également rejoint
Arthur à l'instant on entendait Julien
Bayou qui lui disait mais c'est ce qu'on
voit est très encourageant en tous les
cas de son point de vue tout a laissé
fonder il y a encore beaucoup de monde
quels sont les chiffres quelle est la
mobilisation à Paris et puis dans le
reste de la France on va peut-être
tempéré un petit peu l'enthousiasme de
de Julien Bayou en regardant les images
on a plutôt tendance à penser c'est ce
qu'on a tendance à penser aux images les
chiffres que vous donnez on a tendance
également à affirmer avec les chiffres à
l'appui chiffre collectés auprès auprès
des préfectures tout au long de la
matinée du début d'après-midi je viens
avec des chiffres très récents puisqu'à
16 heures on avait 20000 manifestants
dans toute la France c'est 90000 de
moins que la semaine dernière que je dis
6 avril et pour donner un ordre de
grandeur et un point de comparaison le
mardi 7 mars jour de la plus grosse
mobilisation il y avait à la même heure
719 000 manifestants donc on est
vraiment sur l'une des mobilisations les
plus faibles depuis le début du
mouvement
on est sur une baisse d'un tiers par
rapport à la semaine dernière et on
estime on estime ré on
on s'approche on irait vers une
mobilisation autour de 380 000 personnes
ce qui en ferait l'une des moins des
moins fortes pour rappel la plus faible
c'était le 11 mars avec 368 000
manifestants donc on se situerait
11 mars 11 mars effectivement
pas vous travaillez et puis de toute
façon si on a des problèmes de mémoire
on a vos chiffres voilà je les je les
ressort et effectivement
alors moi j'avais sur le 11 sur le 11
mars effectivement 368 000
manifestations on se manifestants votre
mémoire mon cher Arthur est excellente
alors en région on voit il y a eu des
tensions alors que voilà on signalé des
tensions près de l'Hôtel de Ville à
Paris des violents heures entre forces
de l'ordre et manifestants à Nantes ou à
Rennes et
est-ce que
dans ces villes là il y a toujours
beaucoup de mobilisation ou bien dire
beaucoup de radicalisation mais moins de
mobilisation il y a ce sera plutôt la
deuxième option chez mon cher Vincent ce
sera plutôt beaucoup de radicalisation
et très peu de mobilisation puisque dans
de nombreuses grandes villes vous
parliez à l'instant de Nantes et Rennes
mais je peux aussi vous parler de
Marseille Montpellier ou Toulouse tour
la mobilisation est au plus bas dans ces
villes tournent dans les grandes
métropoles dans les grandes métropoles
préfecture de super c'est la plus faible
mobilisation je pense à Tours seulement
3000 personnes c'est parfois monter à
plus de 10000 au plus fort de la
mobilisation je pense également à
Marseille je pense à Nantes Rennes à
peine 6500 personnes alors que Rennes a
parfois été très mobilisé
atteignant parfois je crois 28
000 personnes donc dans ces grandes
métropoles dans ces grandes villes on
assiste vraiment à une très très faible
mobilisation c'est la plus basse depuis
le début du mouvement la seule les seuls
exceptions entre guillemets c'est
Saint-Étienne qui se maintient plutôt à
un chiffre honorable
3800 manifestants si ma mémoire est
bonne et l'exception c'est Nice ministre
qui est traditionnellement une ville où
on manifeste très peu ni son est passé
de 2300 à 2700 manifestants
certes une augmentation mais ce n'est
pas grand chose à l'échelle nationale
alors il y a donc si je vous suis une
baisse générale et c'est certain point
jaune je crois dans votre carte
et il y a qu'un point vert il y a que un
ou deux points verts et notamment le
Nice mais enfin c'est assez anecdotique
en tout cas en terme de d'augmentation
je parle bien évidemment
ça c'est pour les grandes villes est-ce
que dans les villes moyennes parce que
ça c'est le phénomène que l'on a auquel
on a assisté que l'on a vu émerger au
cours de ces
dans notre contestation contre la
réforme de retraite est-ce que sa
manifeste beaucoup dans les villes
moyennes non ça suit un petit peu le
mouvement des grandes villes si la
tendance et je pense légèrement moins
forte c'est à dire qu'on n'atte pas
toujours dans ces villes moyennes le
point le plus bas de la mobilisation
mais la baisse reste néanmoins très
sensible dans les villes moyennes
Châteauroux Guéret Agen Quimper
Mont-de-Marsan Reims Périgueux toutes
ces villes là qui ont défilé ce matin
entre 10h 11h et midi on a une forte
baisse de la mobilisation par exemple au
Mont-de-Marsan il n'y avait que 1000
personnes pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée au plus fort de la mobilisation
je crois c'était le 31 janvier à
Mont-de-Marsan vous aviez entre 5500 et
6000 personnes vous avez 6 fois moins de
personnes qu'au plus fort donc c'est
quand même une nette baisse et c'est le
message à retenir de de cette douzième
journée de mobilisation c'est une
mobilisation quand même qui qui diminue
et qui s'affaiblit quelle est la
sociologie des manifestants
c'est assez compliqué à dire puisque
quand on voit nos envies spéciaux dans
dans la manifestation parisienne vous
pouvez rencontrer parfois des jeunes qui
manifestent pour la première fois au 12e
jour de mobilisation et ça ça peut vous
paraître assez bizarre si on n'a pas
manifesté sur les 11 premières c'est dur
à comprendre d'aller manifester sur
cette douzième qui s'annonce un peu plus
faible mais là la sociologie des
manifestants elle se resserre vraiment
au niveau de de des professions très
mobilisées au niveau syndical je pense
au fonctionnaires je pense aux
fonctionnaires de l'éducation nationale
etc etc donc vraiment là c'est ce qui se
mobilise c'est le c'est le noyau
syndical et on voit moins les personnes
qu'on voyait fin janvier même même le 7
mars ou le 23 mars
on voit moins des vraiment on voit on
voit moins ces personnes qui
manifestaient pour la première fois qui
se disait bon allez on va aller
manifester une bonne journée de salaire
pour pour se battre contre cette réforme
des retraites ça on le voit moins et on
peut dire on peut on peut l'expliquer
assez simplement c'est que l'inflation
frappe très durement ses salariés et
perdre une journée de salaire à la fin
du mois si vous en perdez une deux trois
quatre ça peut commencer à faire
beaucoup sur la fiche de paye une autre
une autre question Arthur puisque c'est
un instant on vient de me voir la CGT
qui revendique 400 000 manifestants ici
à Paris bon a priori je ne sais pas en
tous les cas on aura un chiffre bien
différent celui de la police le point
qui est intéressant ce que ça rejoint
peut-être ce que disait Julien Bayou
c'est que c'est un niveau en tous les
cas ils avaient revendiqué le même
nombre de manifestants à Paris le 6
avril alors est-ce que à Paris alors que
on voit décroître le mouvement dans le
reste du pays est-ce que à Paris ça
reste étal ou pas non il faut
en tout cas ils ont relativistes
toujours les estimations de de la CGT
puisque là je parle pas des chiffres
par exemple juste pour vous donner un
exemple vous avez la CGT avait annoncé 2
millions de personnes la dernière fois
000 pour les autorités 2 millions de
personnes l'avant-dernière fois 740 000
pour les autorités donc effectivement
c'était pas du tout la même tendance
donc on prend toujours avec des
pincettes les chiffres syndicaux et le
chiffre de 400 000 personnes à Paris
pour travailler sur les mobilisations
depuis très longtemps on l'entend assez
régulièrement c'est c'est souvent le
chiffre annoncé la dernière fois le
chiffre était de 57000 la semaine
dernière je pense que au vu des images
même s'il faut se méfier parce qu'il y a
eu deux cortèges donc on n'a pas
l'ensemble des manifestants je pense
qu'il sera il sera plus bas il y a moins
de famille il y a moins de personnes en
tous les cas d'actifs dans les
manifestations je voudrais Vincent que
dans pour une partie des Français qui
est la zone A
il y a les vacances scolaires vous
pouvez tout à fait soit prendre des
vacances aller voir la famille ou tout
simplement ne pas ne pas pouvoir
manifester
à Paris c'est plus rare quand même parce
que Paris n'est pas encore en vacances
en tous les cas pas cette zone est-ce
que mais est-ce qu'il y a un
rajeunissement à ce qu'on observe encore
un rajeunissement de la des manifestants
ou bien là on est plutôt sur l'âge moyen
des
militants syndicaux qui manifestent donc
plutôt
je parle souvent de contrôle mais plutôt
au-delà de la cinquantaine quoi c'est
assez difficile à dire ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut faire remarquer c'est que
l'utilisation du 49-3 par le
gouvernement avec donné un coup de boost
à cette mobilisation et le coup de boost
était principalement venu de la jeunesse
on se souvient que la plupart des
observateurs avaient été surpris de voir
ce million 0,8 personnes défilées à
Paris le enfin à Paris dans toute la
France le 23 mars c'était en grande
partie liée à une surmobilisation de la
jeunesse une surmobilisation qu'on
pensait
qu'elle allait durer au fil des jours
mais ce qu'on constate à la fois dans
les défilés des grandes villes et à la
fois à Paris c'est que la jeunesse quand
même est un peu moins présente et c'est
ce qui explique c'est ce qui explique
c'est un facteur explicatif de la baisse
de la mobilisation
est-ce que il y a un effet inflation sur
la mobilisation oui très clairement très
très clairement quand on consulte les
sites de nos confrères de la presse
quotidienne régionale qui interview des
manifestants sur de petits
rassemblements où vous avez trois quatre
cinq cent personnes vous voyez vous
entendez les gens dire oui je n'étais
pas là la dernière fois parce que perdre
un jour de salaire c'est beaucoup avec
l'inflation etc on fait attention donc
oui il y a vraiment un effet inflation
et puis il y a eu aussi un effet
inflation je pense dans la mobilisation
et certaines personnes se sont certes
mobilisées pour les retraites mais il y
avait de manière sous-jacente le coût de
la vie
le travail le bien-être au travail etc
et l'inflation faisait partie de ces
raisons alors on a parlé des chiffres
des manifestations mais dans une
mobilisation il y a deux aspects il y a
les manifestants il y a aussi ceux qui
lèvent la crosse c'est-à-dire qu'ils
font la grève là aussi quels sont les
tendances est-ce que on voit quand même
que en termes de grève ça décroît
notamment dans les transports est-ce que
on observe encore cette tendance
aujourd'hui oui pour tous nos
téléspectateurs qui habitent
l'Île-de-France ils ont du s'en rendre
compte ce matin alors que il y avait de
nombreux blocages lors des journées
précédentes de manifestation aujourd'hui
le trafic était quasiment normal un
chiffre également me vient me vient en
tête c'est celui des grévistes à
l'éducation nationale qui est autour de
5% très très faible le 7 mars c'était
autour d'un tiers donc vous voyez quand
même une grande une grande différence
donc non effectivement le la grève enfin
le fait de faire grève s'étiole s'étiole
complètement
en termes de blocage maintenant et en
particulier le blocage sur un point qui
est toujours gaieté c'est celui du
carburant de l'essence où en est-on il
n'y a plus de blocage depuis mardi c'est
à dire mardi le dernier blocage sur la
dernière racinerie qui est celle de
Gonfreville-l'Orcher en Seine-Maritime
qui appartient à Total énergie a été
levé donc il n'y a plus aucun blocage
que ce soit dans les dépôts au niveau
des ports au niveau des raffineries mais
reprendre la production faire arriver
les bateaux faire décharger les bateaux
qui attendaient ça prend du temps donc
on a encore une situation
tendu mais pas dans tout le pays au
niveau national on a à peine une station
sur 10 qui est en difficulté en revanche
c'est en Île-de-France que se concentre
les difficultés et vous avez une station
sur trois en Île-de-France qui a des
problèmes qui a soit pas de sans-plomb
95 pas de sans plomb 98 pas de diesel
c'est un chiffre qui monte même autour
de 44% dans le Val-de-Marne 38% à Paris
donc les automobilistes franciliens
vraiment connaissent des difficultés
pour faire le plein
est-ce que
on perçoit dans les données à travers
les données qu'on a que le mouvement
pourrait repartir comme il est reparti
après le 49-3 c'est un mouvement très
compliqué à appréhender qui a commencé
très fort qui ensuite un sait maintenu
il y a une longue pause avec les
vacances scolaires qui repartit cette
mars pour mieux redescendre avant de
repartir le 23 mars après le 49-3 donc
c'est un mouvement qui qui fluctue
beaucoup et on est difficile de prédire
ce qui pourrait se passer mais une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel qui
est très attendu demain on l'a entendu
avec Thomas en grand juste avant qui a
annoncé annoncé pour 19h cette décision
du Conseil constitutionnelle pourrait
entre guillemets remettre un petit peu
de carburant dans la machine là il y a
pas de blocage dans la machine des
manifestants ça reste à voir ça reste à
à attendre cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel savoir s'il y a
validation totale censure totale ou sans
sursielle enfin beaucoup de choses
dépendront et puis on a le premier mai
syndical qui qui s'annonce également
alors on voit le cortège qui est en
train de remonter sur la qui est en
train de remonter la rue de Rivoli on a
effectivement la pour l'instant des
également ces images les forces de
l'ordre qui sont qui se sont un peu plus
rassemblés un peu plus compact que dans
les images que dans les flux que nous
avons vu jusqu'à présent on nous signale
également des heures
au niveau des en tout cas des tensions
et des charges un peu plus haut de sur
la rue de Rivoli en direction de
Bastille au niveau de l'église
Saint-Paul au niveau de la station de
métro Saint-Paul et c'est effectivement
la situation que nous rapporte les
journalistes du
du Figaro et pouvoir retrouver toutes
les dernières informations sur le le
site du Figaro sur le live texte qui
nous tient au courant et qui vous tient
au courant en temps réel les
manifestations près du Conseil
constitutionnel également seront
interdites à partir de jeudi soir c'est
ce que nous dit
en tous les cas c'est ce que nous dit
cette dépêche de l'agence France Presse
ambiance calme sur ce qu'on voit mais un
petit peu moins sur
ce qui en tous les cas un petit peu plus
loin sur la direction en direction de la
place de la Bastille qu'est-ce que vous
allez guetter c'est ma dernière question
Charles dans les minutes dans les heures
dans les jours qui viennent évidemment
le chiffre de la mobilisation à Paris à
Lille à Nancy à Strasbourg qui sont les
quelques grandes villes qui défilent
l'après-midi et dont nous n'avons pas
encore le nombre de manifestants on va
guetter la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui sera sûrement suivi
d'une réaction de l'intersyndical faut
voir ce que décide d'intersyndical
pendant les vacances scolaires de
février elle avait décidé de s'abstenir
ou de mobiliser en le samedi en plein
week-end est-ce qu'elle va faire la même
chose pour les vacances scolaires de
Pâques c'est une question et puis est-ce
qu'elle va attendre plutôt le premier
mai pour pour une grande mobilisation
c'est que les syndicats n'ont pas été
unis au niveau du 1er mai depuis plus
d'une décennie donc à voir et à suivre
on observera ça et effectivement quand
avec les annonces de l'Inter syndical un
grand merci Arthur et un grand bravo
pour tout ce travail tout le travail du
Figaro data vous pouvez retrouver c'est
passionnant les classements également
les les données qui nous permettent de
mettre en perspective et de mettre à
jour un certain nombre de phénomènes et
s'est retrouvé sur le fil data on va
revenir bien rue de Rivoli retrouver
Vincent roseron et Julien Leclerc
Vincent quelle est l'ambiance où vous
trouvez il y a quelques images où on
voit un petit peu de de fumée alors
est-ce que c'est peut-être des fumigènes
ou bien
au loin de la lacrymo vous êtes en train
de vous rapprocher de la place de la
Bastille dites nous comment ça se passe
alors nous on avance rue de Rivoli alors
on est au niveau avec le cortège de là
actuellement de la Mairie de Paris qui
est juste à côté de nous et donc là nous
avançons et l'ambiance est toujours au
calme la seule fumée qu'on a vu c'est la
fumée des fumigènes ici mais je sais
pour avoir vu d'autres d'autres choses
de mes collègues plutôt à l'avant tout à
l'heure au niveau de l'hôtel de ville il
y a eu quelques débordements nous tout
ce qu'on voit c'est des tags qu'on peut
retrouver comme à chaque manifestation
vous voyez ce tag avec marqué akab il y
en avait marqué t'accélérer je veux
aller les vitres des magasins rue de
Rivoli qui ont été tagués mais de
l'autre côté en tout cas le cortège
continue d'avancer rue de Rivoli à une
bonne vitesse vraiment
on a ça presque accéléré quand même
depuis un petit moment on a l'impression
que les manifestants vont arriver place
de la Bastille d'ici une heure ou deux
avec à ce rythme là et en tout cas de
notre côté de ce qu'on a vu c'est une
ambiance calme festive des gens qui
dansent mais pas de débordement
merci beaucoup Vincent merci pour ces
précisions et on va continuer de suivre
ça avec vous on va faire un premier
bilan avec jacolivier Martin directeur
de la rédaction du Figaro.fr Le
Figaro.fr sur lequel vous pouvez suivre
en temps réel toutes les informations et
avoir toutes les informations non
seulement ici à Paris mais également sur
toute la France et grâce également à nos
correspondants parce que vous le savez
le Figaro est également présent dans
plusieurs régions à Nantes à Bordeaux à
Nice à Lyon et également avec des mêmes
vous allez pouvoir vous pouvez le
recevoir dans certaines de ces villes
par la radio puisque il y a désormais le
Figaro radio animé par l'excellente
haute CRS où vous pouvez retrouver
également une partie une grande partie
des émissions qui sont qui se déroulent
sur figarolive le Figaro live et puis
également un certain nombre de podcasts
bonjour mon cher jacolivier il y a
encore
je sais bien que c'est moi enfin il y a
quand même encore du monde dans la rue
il y a encore beaucoup de monde même si
c'est beaucoup moins et qu'on s'en
essoufflement on sera probablement
autour de 300000
manifestants ça reste pour une deuxième
mobilisation quand même alors que le
texte a été
adopté comme on l'a pu le constater j'ai
presque envie de dire c'est c'est un peu
c'est trop peu pour faire bouger les
choses mais c'est encore assez nombreux
pour ne pas décourager les
manifestations et les mobilisations des
syndicats d'entretenir l'espoir on est
dans un entre deux oui ça s'essouffle
mais reste encore on peut voir un petit
peu de misère plat 300 000 personnes ça
reste une une mobilisation quand même
à ne pas négliger c'est c'est est-ce que
c'est c'est bien ce signe qui a une
colère qui s'est installée je vois les
mouvements dans les universités j'ai vu
le on a assisté tout au long de la
journée sur notre sur notre site et avec
vous au Figaro live on a vu quelques
mobilisations assez dures des entre les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants
donc on sent de la colère quand même et
ça il faut en tenir compte de quoi cette
colère selon vous jacolivier le nom
je pense que ça en tout cas j'ai envie
de dire que elle
il y a un problème frustration terrible
de ne pas avoir réussi malgré des très
grosses mobilisations à ne pas avoir
réussi à faire réfléchir le texte alors
qu'il y avait une interditale tout était
mis en place pour faire pression et
pousser le gouvernement à revenir en
arrière donc ça c'est le véritablement
le premier point il y a ce sentiment
avec l'exercice de ce 49-3 un peu
flottant qui a pas toujours été bien
expliqué qu'on a volé on leur a volé
quelque part la possibilité
qu'on a empêché à un vote franc et
massif ou en tout cas un vote classique
d'une loi et donc que les institutions
alors que le font
que tu ne sais pas passer comme ça
aurait dû se créer une colère politique
sociale politique
et puis
il y a crise politique aussi qui
s'installe tout ça c'est nourri aussi
par des parties cette organisation assez
tripartite aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée où
il y a des constatés des contestations
très fortes notamment auprès de
l'extrême gauche qui a envie d'attiser
de mettre
que que tout ça s'afflambe et donc je
pense que c'est la conjonction de tout
ça donc difficile de dire de donner un
seul nom pour pour justifier cette
colère c'est la somme de plein de choses
ce sentiment que c'est pas fini ce
sentiment que peut-être que le Conseil
d'État va rebatter car ce sentiment
peut-être que un référendum pourrait
également faire que ce texte cette
réforme ne passe pas c'est plein de
choses moi je pense que c'est une colère
sociale c'est un état général en France
qui est pas très positif et puis c'est
il y a quelque chose un peu de crise
politique c'est la somme de beaucoup de
choses
on ne va pas passer à autre chose c'est
ce qu'a dit Laurent Berger en début
manifestation alors deux questions
autour de ça d'abord est-ce qu'on peut
passer à autre chose pour passer à autre
chose il faut réussir à convaincre les
Français leur porter déjà un projet
politique la première ministre
apparemment quand on regarde les
sondages on va y revenir dans un instant
avec les résultats et les révélations du
sondage au doxa bac bonne Consulting
avec Gaëlle Slimane et enfin convaincre
les Français sur ça sur la réforme des
retraites c'est peine perdue je crois
même que le gouvernement est l'Élysée
n'y croient même plus sur la réforme des
retraites peut-être pas mais les amener
à la suite de l'histoire cette réforme
n'est passée ou imaginons qu'elle soit
que le Conseil constitutionnel de la
censure pas et qu'on puisse la mettre en
oeuvre d'une façon d'une autre bon il
faut aujourd'hui offrir des perspectives
et continuer quand on est en début d'un
mandat essayez d'engager d'autres
réformes qui sont nécessaires la France
et loin d'être un pays
en pleine forme sur plein de sur plein
de sujets donc il faut pouvoir donner
d'autres
perspectives de réforme ou pas en tout
cas des perspectives aux Français
j'ajoute quand même que des creux le
chef de l'État parce que aujourd'hui
c'est le chef de l'État qui est
largement attaqué il en a connu au pire
moment des gilets jaunes il était très
très bas puis il a réussi à remonter
dans l'opinion et puis c'est fait
réélire donc
on peut pas dire que la situation
actuelle le condamne définitivement il
faut pas que ça le condamne j'ai envie
de dire je parle pas pour l'homme mais
il faut on en est au début d'un
quinquennat il y a encore quatre ans en
fait simplement le premier anniversaire
de son élection il faut qu'on puisse
continuer à gouverner le pays et à
engager les réformes qui sont
nécessaires ça c'est c'est impératif
voilà ce que je j'imagine
la deuxième question je voulais vous
poser par rapport à que je voulais vous
poser par rapport à la déclaration de
Laurent Berger c'est si on assiste pas
et si on n'a pas assisté à tout au long
de cette tout au long de cette
séquence et d'un leader plus que un
leader syndical un leader politique
alors
c'est sûr qu'il occupe une place très
importante
c'est lui l'opposant finalement qui
incarne cette opposition véritable plus
que les politiques du reste à cette
réforme et Emmanuel Macron à côté de ça
moi si je l'ai entendu encore quelques
jours il affirme il réaffirmé qu'il
allait arrêter son son mandat de et
qu'il allait tourner la page et qu'il
avait pas d'ambition politique
voilà moi je peux on peut s'en tenir à
ça
aujourd'hui
difficile de savoir
moi je pense que oui alors je pourquoi
pourquoi je pense ça
parce que en tout cas l'homme que j'ai
pu connaître et croiser
j'ai toujours senti vraiment un
syndicaliste quelqu'un qui était engagé
dans le monde syndical
bon je pense qu'en plus de ça le combat
politique bon bah syndical est compliqué
dans une France où il y a de moins en
moins de gens qui sont syndicalisés mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le combat
politique est quelque chose encore plus
difficile on est et je suis pas sûr il y
a eu beaucoup d'énergie depuis une
décennie pour faire tout ce qu'il a fait
au sein peut-être même plus qu'une
décennie au sein de la CFDT je pense
qu'il peut aspirer à toi en nulle part
on voit la mais bon ça vous arrange pas
elle vous dit ça mais voilà non mais
effectivement votre point de vue est
intéressant ce qu'il est pas forcément
évident et il est pas partagé par
d'autres donc
c'est c'était pour ça et comme vous avez
été quand même également rédacteur en
chef du Figaro économie c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre analyse et
votre expérience est-ce que le
référendum d'initif partagé de l'indice
citoyenne je sais plus d'ailleurs au
bout de trois heures de live mais
partager le rip et non pas le rythme
n'est pas un risque pour l'exécutif si
ça va remettre une pièce dans la machine
à discutablement
si on s'engage dans ce référendum
voilà dans ce processus on va savoir
dans quelques instants s'il a des
chances un jour de voir le jour s'il
était validé on le saura dans 5 minutes
je vois Gaëlle Slimane qui s'est préparé
donc il va nous donner les résultats le
sondage fait paradoxal et bac bonne
Consulting donc on va pas spoiler non
mais en tout cas c'est absolument
certain que ça pourrait redonner de
l'espoir et à partir du moment où il y a
de l'espoir on aura du mal à tourner la
page donc ce référendum ça peut
empoisonner l'exécutif ça peut
entretenir l'espoir auprès des des
syndicats et des Français donc
euh sans être certain ou demeurant que
d'ici quelques mois si même on a
obtenait les les le nombre de les 4
millions et quelques de signatures
nécessaires qu'on aboutisse pour autant
à la mise en place du référendum donc
c'est extrêmement complexe c'est
effectivement ça empoisonnerait
terriblement
l'exécutif tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
aujourd'hui images de ce qui se passe en
ce moment pendant que on parlait alors
là c'est parce que là c'est ce que vous
avez pu voir en direct pendant qu'on
voilà ces nouvelles images qu'on pouvait
voir en direct donc sur la rue
Saint-Antoine il semble effectivement à
Paris
Vincent roserand vous êtes sur place on
a vu des on voit du lacrymo qui est tiré
mais apparemment c'est pas autour de
vous
non c'est pas du tout autour de nous
effectivement nous on a vu une poubelle
qui brûlait mais ça avait pas l'air
d'être le fait de manifestants on a vu
bien sûr des des panneaux publicitaires
cassés comme ça arrive très souvent lors
de ces manifs mais on voit surtout des
gens chanter des gens avec des bas des
porte-voix pour se faire entendre mais
en tout cas pas de pas de comment dire
pas de tension à part dans ce cadence
cortèges ou en tout cas de l'endroit où
nous nous trouvons peut-être plus en
avant mais là où nous sommes en tout cas
c'est-à-dire rue de Rivoli on arrive en
fait
niveau de l'Hôtel de Ville dans on est à
50 mètres de tête de ville là où il y
avait tout à l'heure des tensions là où
nous sommes actuellement il n'y en a pas
merci beaucoup Vincent continué à suivre
savourer bien sûr en alerte et on va
revenir vers vous dans quelques minutes
que peut faire que va faire Emmanuel
Macron jacolivier
on a un peu l'idée avec le calendrier
déjà il y a le Conseil constitutionnel
et après
là je pense que la semaine prochaine
elle va être une semaine clé ou la
suivante les 15 jours qui viennent
lui va devoir
probablement on peut imaginer avoir des
relations avec les syndicats c'est
quelque chose d'une façon d'une autre
qu'on peut imaginer il va falloir il a
il a demandé aussi à sa première
ministre il va falloir qu'il fasse mieux
que Elisabeth borne si s'il la revoit
parce que ça a duré juste une ça a duré
juste une heure ça sera pas simple il va
falloir qu'il bouge et ce qu'il va
falloir qu'il engage à remaniement mais
un remaniement finalement plus que le
remaniement et les hommes en eux-mêmes
alors c'est vrai que ça peut permettre
symboliquement de tourner une page il
faut je reviens ce que je disais
afficher une feuille de route assez
claire de quelle réforme on parle d'une
réforme sur le marché du travail et
l'amorceler la réforme qui était qui
devait s'engager sur l'immigration enfin
je pense qu'il faut qu'il fixe un cap
c'est compliqué déjà de fixer un cap
aujourd'hui et en plus de ça qu'il
arrive à fixer un cap et de créer une
adhésion ou en tout cas un début
d'adhésion
c'est pas simple alors est-ce qu'on va
vers un remaniement
c'est pas exclu du tout est-ce que ça
sera avec ou sans Elisabeth borne ce
qu'on entendait c'est que finalement au
monde a sondé même on a
les internautes du Figaro qui disaient
que c'était pas finalement
de voir qu'il pense pas que c'est pas
Lisabelle qu'il faut forcément changer
je pense que la colère elle est
largement contre Emmanuel Macron oui
alors il faut qu'il arrive je pense à
fixer un cap apaiser et à donner une
direction sur la grâce sur laquelle il
va pouvoir
calmer entraîner redonner quelque chose
qui donne de la qui apaise et qui donne
de l'envie peut-être de d'aller de
l'avant de tourner une page
j'ai du mal à m'exprimer parce que je
pense que c'est pas simple à ce qui sait
ce qu'il va faire je suis pas sûr non
plus
urgent à traiter c'est tout ce qui est
le dossier question d'ancien directement
chef du Figaro économique vous êtes mais
est-ce que c'est le dossier pas urgent
c'est l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat
oui c'est la première préoccupation des
Français à discutablement donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet là-dessus il a il a
il y a beaucoup d'attentes je rappelle
quand même que le gouvernement même
avant l'élection depuis depuis plus d'un
an a fait déjà beaucoup de choses en
matière d'inflation c'est pas le
gouvernement qui fixe les prix qui
décident si on peut les stopper
aujourd'hui le gouvernement peut aider
et aller encore peut-être plus loin dans
l'aide des gens qui en souffrent le plus
mais c'est pas lui qui décide des prix
de l'énergie ou des prix alimentaires ça
j'insiste là dessus la deuxième donc il
faut là aussi la marge de manœuvre est
pas forcément énorme la deuxième chose
c'est que si c'est un guichet qu'on met
en place ou des aides faut bien penser
qu'un jour ou l'autre il faut les
financer alors il y a plusieurs façons
pour les financer la dette
on le voit c'est à ce à quoi on procède
les impôts je suis pas sûr que les
Français soient forcément absolument
partants mais tôt tout tard il faut
payer l'argent qu'on distribue ça c'est
une chose importante donc oui c'est une
préoccupation oui il faut savoir
accompagner ce et aider les Français les
écouter là-dessus mais il faut pas
croire que le quoi qu'il en coûte
peut-être activé à tout moment comme ça
éternellement non là-dessus aussi on
risque d'être surpris si c'est surtout
qu'en ce moment il y a quand même nos
voisins qui sont confrontés à des hautes
inflations souvent supérieures à celles
qu'on vit en France
et des pays comme l'Allemagne qui
commence à redire qu'il va falloir se
remettre sérieusement
à essayer de réduire les déficits à
l'échelle européenne donc d'avoir une
politique
en tout cas qu'il ne fasse pas la part
belle ou quoi qu'il en coûte éternel
merci beaucoup jac-olivier pour toutes
ces précisions donner votre éclairage et
votre point de vue sur cette journée de
manifestation et bien on vient
d'apprendre que Emmanuel Macron ira
vendredi sur le chantier de Notre-Dame
de Paris après l'incendie et ça c'est
une alerte lancée et donner par Le
Figaro.fr dont vous êtes le directeur et
donc c'est ce que on vient on vient
d'apprendre merci beaucoup
jacolivier pour pour toutes ces
précisions et on va continuer à suivre
la situation dans une minute on se
retrouve avec Games Slimane et les
résultats du sondage au doxa backbone
Consulting vous restez avec nous parce
qu'ils sont extrêmement intéressants et
extrêmement édifiant
concernant justement les attentes des
Français par rapport à la réforme par
rapport à la mobilisation et surtout par
rapport au référendum d'initiative
partagée le fameux RIP puisque une
demande a été déposée et le Conseil
constitutionnel doit rendre aussi son
avis sa décision sur la validation Laval
et c'est la validité ou la validation ou
non de cette procédure Vincent rosera on
vous retrouve on avait encore un peu de
lacrymonde on a eu encore un peu
d'agitation mais je pense que c'était un
petit peu plus devant vous c'était au
niveau de la rue Saint-Antoine au niveau
de Saint-Paul alors que vous vous êtes
au niveau de l'hôtel de ville alors à
l'hôtel de ville il y a eu des heures
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'on voit encore
les les stigmates les traces de
de ces violences dont on a parlé qu'on a
évoqué
oui effectivement on a vu des magasins
qui ont été avec la vitre qui a été
cassée alors pas cassé pour que les
petits gens puissent y rentrer mais avec
en tout cas des brides glaces on a vu
des panneaux d'affichage et des abribus
détruits également on voit des forces de
l'ordre mais nous alors on est pas loin
effectivement de Saint-Paul on est à
hôtel de ville c'est à un arrêt de métro
on va dire mais nous en tout cas là où
on est il n'y a pas en tout cas de
tension on est toujours avec un cortège
qui conduit avancé vous voyez sur les
images je garde Leclerc d'ailleurs les
ballons de la CFDT qui sont un peu plus
loin le cortège qui progresse petit à
petit le long de cette rue de Rivoli
mais oui effectivement comme vous l'avez
pu vous dire tout à l'heure il y a eu
des tensions tout à l'heure mais nous
nous avons pas été témoin elles sont
plus en amont de la manifestation par
rapport à nous
merci beaucoup Vincent merci pour toutes
ces précisions ben vous remontez le
cortège on continue de suivre ça avec
vous on est avec Gaëlle Slimane en
direct depuis le siège de doxa bonjour
Gaëlle
bonjour
[Musique]
Vous venez de rendre on vient de publier
un sondage au doxa bac bonne consulting
pour Le Figaro et on voit que il y a
deux fois moins d'opposants qu'il y a un
mois 10 ans participé Activ activement
au mouvement c'est intéressant je peux
commencer par là parce que ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que le nombre
manifestement de
manifestants baisse également le nombre
de grévistes et ça se voit également
dans les sondages
absolument on a un double indicateur
Vincent et si on se focalise sur la part
de
la soutiennent la mobilisation nous
disent qu'elles y participent à leur
manière d'une façon ou d'une autre on
suit ça depuis janvier en fait et
singulièrement ce qu'on observe depuis
un mois depuis le 15 mars c'est une
amende de la part de ses français qui
disent je soutiens en participant d'une
manière ou d'une autre ça peut être en
allant manifester ça peut être en
faisant grève ça peut être d'une
quelconque façon souhaitait à 26 % le 15
mars dernier de participants nous ne
sommes plus qu'à 13 donc c'est une
division par deux en l'espace d'un point
une division par deux en l'espace d'un
mois
il n'y a pas de lacrymo dans le studio
nous dit je réponds à pas de 75 qui me
dit est-ce que j'ai du mal je ne sais
pas en tous les cas on essaye de faire
au mieux
il y a un autre chiffre intéressant
effectivement on découvre les chiffres
en même temps que on les donne parce que
le sondage vient d'être rendu public la
moitié des Français 48% dites avoir
confiance en la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel ce qui est intéressant
parce que on entend quand même que il y
a une forme de défiance qui est en train
de monter par rapport au Conseil
constitutionnel et par rapport à la
décision qui pourrai rendre
bah c'est plus partagé donc quand on le
voit dans le dans les sondages
tout à fait juste une chose Vincent je
voulais dire deux choses sur le soutien
et la participation pour revenir à la
question précédente on a un effondrement
de la participation mais on a un niveau
extraordinairement constant
tient à la mobilisation on est toujours
à 60 la première mesure que nous avions
faites ensemble le 20 janvier on était à
trois mois plus tard le 13 avril on est
toujours à 66 il y a eu des montées à 69
70 des descentes à 64 mais de façon
constante les deux tiers des Français
soutiennent cette mobilisation donc
quand même le fait qu'il est moins de
manifestants c'est plutôt le signe que
les gens se disent ça ne sert plus à
rien de manifester une partie d'entre
eux doivent le penser ça ne veut pas
dire
sur le Conseil constitutionnel voir le
faire à moitié vide ou à moitié plein on
est sur un résultat en gros à 50
confiance les gens qui n'ont pas
confiance on sait qu'on sait pour pour
rendre une décision comment dirais-je
juste sur le sujet moi je suis comme
vous Vincent je suis
étonné autant de français alors qu'il y
a un tel
rejette nos institutions à tel sentiment
que elles ne fonctionnerait pas qu'il y
ait quand même un Français sur deux qui
nous disent j'ai confiance dans le
Conseil constitutionnel pour rendre une
décision finalement impartiale et quand
on sait aussi combien de ces membres ont
eu une expression liée à des politiques
il y a Emmanuel Macron notamment je
trouve que c'est pas mal et du coup que
ça met une certaine pression au Conseil
constitutionnel dans la décision qui
rendra
12% des sondés seulement disent ne pas
du tout avoir confiance dans le Conseil
constitutionnel effectivement c'est peu
c'est pas une fronde anti-institution en
tout cas contre le Conseil
constitutionnel alors ce qui sera
peut-être intéressant de voir c'est
comment ça va évoluer après moi je
reviens sur un autre point à Lac vous
venez de souligner Gaël parce que je
trouve qu'il est effectivement en tous
les cas c'est un point qu'on voit
apparaître très fortement depuis le
début de la manifestation depuis le
début des manifestations c'est à dire
que effectivement
la surprise de cette séquence c'est que
il y a pas eu les blocages à part le 19
janvier dans les peut-être les premiers
jours de mobilisation n'ont pas
fonctionné entre guillemets c'est-à-dire
que la France n'a pas été bloquée en
particulier le 7 mars ou des syndicats
on va appeler la France bloquée ce qui
est une première dans un mouvement de
cette ampleur et quand il y a ces appels
là en revanche en revanche il y a ce
constant soutien aux
manifestations et même à attribuer on
voyait dans certains sondages que
attribuer la responsabilité des
violences au gouvernement ce qui est le
narratif en tous les cas des syndicats
et le narratif de la gauche dans la rue
question est-ce qu'il y a pas un point
commun justement entre le fait qui est
ce fort soutien dans les sondages et ce
peu de monde dans les dans les dans les
rues ce point commun ça s'appelle
l'inflation ça s'appelle le pouvoir
d'achat qui diminue et qui ne permet pas
justement de faire des grèves et qui
conduit par contre un nombre croissant
de Français à soutenir ces mouvements
sans doute vous l'aviez évoqué
avant que j'intervienne je vous ai
écoutais attentivement et bien
évidemment que c'est une préoccupation
majeure que c'est ce sujet de
l'inflation
sans doute aussi que pour les personnes
qui se mettent en grève ça représente
des jours de paye en moins et que ça les
fait réfléchir
plus encore que l'inflation ce qui
atténue depuis quelques temps déjà le
sentiment d'une efficacité au fait se
mobiliser c'est cette impression qu'on
les Français que d'une certaine manière
peu importe que les sondages disent que
70 ou 80 % des gens soient opposés peu
importe que l'on soit des millions dans
la rue nous sommes persuadés qu'à la fin
le gouvernement nous nous écoutera pas
c'est ce qu'il nous disent dans les
enquêtes et du coup ça a été très mal
interprété à mon avis par le
gouvernement ce sentiment là ça a été
interprété comme de la résignation alors
qu'en fait on le voit dans les enquêtes
qu'on a réalisé pour vous chaque semaine
c'est plutôt que les Français nous
disent il faut peut-être passer à un
autre mode d'action et même si nous
réprouvons les débordements et la
violence peut-être que comme il a écouté
les gilets jaunes par le passé à cause
des violences peut-être le gouvernement
se résoutra-t-il à nous écouter si le
mouvement devient plus spectaculaire
plus violent même si nous répondons la
violence et ça c'est très dangereux
parce que c'est une façon qu'on les
Français maintenant même si on peut les
comprendre mais de cautionner le
violence en se disant c'est pas bien
mais c'est le seul moyen de se faire
entendre et c'est sans doute pour ça
qu'ils sont aussi moins nombreux à
manifester et à faire grève parce qu'ils
se disent de toute façon on a eu la
preuve que quel que soit le nombre de
manifestants que nous étions ça n'avait
aucune incidence
[Musique]
une question qui est intéressante qui a
été posée dans votre sondage c'est
que
c'est autour du référendum pardon
d'initiative partagée donc trois quarts
des Français attendent une invalidation
totale ou partielle de la loi sans donc
pourtant y croire vraiment ce qui est
intéressant dans sondage en revanche il
pousse pour que le Conseil
constitutionnel prône le recours à un
référendum d'initiative partagé 69% qui
demandent un RIB
ouais c'est une question qu'on avait
posé pas cette fois-ci de ce qu'on
connaissait déjà le résultat la semaine
dernière ensemble sur ce sondage sur
notre sondage hebdomadaire où on avait
vu que cette français sur demandait ce
RIP
sur
partager et cette semaine on a été un
petit peu plus loin on a voulu savoir si
jamais demain le compte professionnel
valide ce fameux référendum d'initiative
partagé est-ce que on attend du
gouvernement qu'il suspendent
l'application de la loi sur les
retraites dans l'attente de ce possible
référendum parce que le gouvernement n'y
est pas obligé on peut aussi appliquer
sa loi qui a été votée même si c'est au
49-3 et puis une fois que l'éventuelles
référendum s'il a lieu à lieu et bien
tenir compte du résultat là les Français
sont formés ils sont 82% à nous dire si
le Conseil constitutionnel nous permet
ce référendum d'initiative partagé le
gouvernement
sa loi donc on verra ce qui se passe
demain on verra éventuellement les les
décisions que prendra le président de la
République à la suite de cela mais il y
aura une très grande frustration une
très grande colère probablement si une
demande de RIB du Conseil
constitutionnel n'était pas suivi des
faits
alors ça c'est extrêmement intéressant
c'est que il y a ce soutien donc en tout
cas une suspension en cas de
promulgation en cas de validation par le
Conseil constitutionnel ce que la loi
n'oblige pas pour l'instant le président
peut tout à fait promulguer sa loi tout
en permettant que le processus du Rip se
fasse ce qui est intéressant également
c'est que la question que vous avez
posée
pour savoir si les Français
et bien s'ignoraient la pétition en
faveur d'un référendum d'initiative
partagée il faut 4,8 millions de
signatures pour que le référendum
d'initiative partagée voit le jour
est-ce que si le Conseil constitutionnel
valide le processus du du référendum
d'initiatif partagé le texte
recueillerait ce qui n'a jamais
recueilli
recueillerait les 4,8 millions de
signatures
oui il y a aucun doute là-dessus dans
notre sondage dans notre sondage on a
posé la question aux Français et on a
les trois quarts d'entre eux qui disent
oui oui alors en sondage vous savez
Vincent on a des questions d'opinion et
des questions de projection sur des
actions et notamment des actions qui
coûtent un petit peu un minimum
d'efforts donc on sait que pour être
prudent on ne prend pas l'ensemble des
gens qui nous disent oui oui je le ferai
mais on va uniquement sur les gens
absolument certain on est à 37%
d'absolument certain et donc
usuellement c'est ce qu'on observe
notamment dans les intentions de
participer à des primaires à la primaire
de la droite prix d'un de la gauche
auparavant on retient entre la moitié et
la totalité des gens certains on est
dans une fourchette où on ne se trompe
pas et en l'occurrence ça produirait 9 à
18 millions de signataires alors on ne
connaît pas encore pour comprendre
précaution parce qu'on ne connaît pas
encore les conditions et les personnes
interrogées non les conditions qu'il
faudrait remplir pour faire cette
signature est-ce que les gens seront
bien informés est-ce qu'ils seront où
elle etc
au pire on aurait 9 millions de
signataires et peut-être même pas au
mieux 18 millions c'est donc 2 à 4 fois
plus que le nombre requis de signataires
pour que ça ait lieu ça veut dire que si
demain le Conseil constitutionnel
demande ce RIP il y a aucun doute sur le
fait qu'il y aura les signataires
suffisants et qu'il aura bien lieu
si le rip avait lieu voilà si Emmanuel
Macron dit qu'il en fait un parce qu'il
y a encore une possibilité pour pour
téléspectateurs qui est que curieusement
pourrait-on dire le président même
soumis à cette injonction du Conseil
constitutionnel d'organiser un
référendum d'initiatique partagé
pourrait dire mais on va très bien je
vous suis mais en fait je vais le faire
autrement je vais le soumettre aux votes
au Parlement et là aussi on n'a pas posé
la question dans le sondage cette
semaine mais on sait que si tel était le
cas ça pourrait générer une très très
grande colère de la part de nos
concitoyens
maintenant si le référendum d'initiative
partagé avait lieu
est-ce qu'on sait quel serait le
résultat à quel résultat il fallait il
faudrait s'attendre
alors on en a une petite idée là aussi
il y a aucun doute sur le fait que le
oui donc au refus de la loi si vous
faites donc le nom à la réforme de
Manuel Macron à la réforme le oui au
référendum qui conteste cette réforme
serait archi écrasante est-ce qu'on
serait sur deux tiers trois quarts 80%
c'est difficile à dire parce qu'on a
posé une question d'opinion la semaine
dernière à ce sujet avec vous avec
paquebot et consulting et le Figaro et
on était autour de 60% de Français qui
nous disaient bah moi j'irai et je
voterai pour ce référendum et donc
contre cette loi à la fin il faudra
regarder le vrai corps électoral qui se
déplacera et il y a pas beaucoup
d'ambiguïté si RIP il y a
et bien loi il n'y aura
9 à 18 millions de voix qui pourraient
être de signatures qui pourraient
recueillie en cas de validation du
processus de référendum 9 à 18 millions
de signatures en clair qui pourraient
être recueillis pour que soit organisé
un référendum sur la réforme des
retraites c'est le principaux
enseignements c'est le grand
enseignement de ce sondage backbone
consulting pour Le Figaro et bien sûr à
retrouver les autres chiffres les
analyses également la perception des
avis du Conseil constitutionnel c'est
sur le site du Figaro sur le site dodoxa
et le site de backbone Consulting merci
beaucoup Gaëlle d'avoir été avec nous
pour nous commenter et nous donner la
primeur des résultats de ce sondage on
va retourner maintenant sur le terrain
le terrain parisien le pavé parisien en
tous les cas plutôt le
goudron puisque c'est là où se trouve
Vincent roseron quelle est l'ambiance là
où vous trouvez ça a l'air assez calme
beaucoup plus calme en tout cas que
certaines informations qui nous
parviennent de la tête du cortège
cortège qui est arrivé déjà place de la
Bastille
[Musique]
qui a pris par exemple la CGT ou encore
FO et qui est passé plus au nord que la
rue de Rivoli et qui lui aussi va
arriver place de la Bastille
merci beaucoup
Vincent effectivement on voit quand même
quelques
lacrymo quelques fumigènes encore tiré
sur
ces images donc quelques heures dans la
manifestation bonjour Christophe de
Vogue quelques heures mais il y en a eu
quand même en tous les cas dans ce qu'on
a vu à Paris nettement moins que les
jours précédents
je crois qu'il faut pour les questions
de de violence vous pensez ça c'est que
jusqu'ici tout va bien ou bien c'est
aussi parce qu'il y a moins de monde et
moins de mobilisation oui mais j'en
viens puisque évidemment vous imaginez
bien qu'avant d'arriver au Figaro je
vais manifester et je trouve que
j'habite n'imagine rien il se trouve que
j'habite juste à côté donc il y a quand
même beaucoup moins de monde que tout ce
qu'on entend mais vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de monde en revanche c'est une
une foule très jeune visiblement elle
est quand même beaucoup de militants
donc les activistes voilà on explorerait
pas que on est inné que 5 heures de 17
heures je pense que on peut avoir une
soirée un peu plus chaude surtout avec
avec les incertitudes juridicaux
politiques on va continuer
à suivre ça moi je voulais vous faire
réagir bien justement sur les chiffres
qu'on vient d'entendre les chiffres de
doxa et de backbone Consulting
effectivement deux fois moins
d'opposants qu'il y a un mois 10 ans
participé activement au mouvement sans
qu'il y a effectivement une
essoufflement mais par contre il y a un
soutien qui est absolument constant et
on en a parlé ensemble depuis le début
de cette de cette mobilisation un
soutien constant mouvement 66% des
Français qui soutiennent les mouvements
oui comme disait mais pas dans ce
sens-là Valéry Giscard d'Estaing de
Français sur trois effectivement c'était
même le sens inverse exactement
d'ailleurs c'est un chiffre il faut le
retenir parce que je trouve que le
président avait quand même une très
bonne intuition sur le fond c'est à dire
que deux Français sur trois c'est
vraiment
quand même quelque chose de décisif
quelle que soit l'opinion ces deux
Français sur trois sur l'immigration
plutôt contre l'immigration c'est de
Français sur trois sur les questions de
sécurité et là il y a un blocage en
effet des deux tiers des françaises sur
cette réforme
bon qui que moi j'attribue évidemment à
[Musique]
la mauvaise présentation de cette
réforme à son mauvais contenu aussi à
son ex dans le contenu le report de
l'âge non mais le fait que le fait que
on avait on avait annoncé justement pas
de report de l'âge et puis report de
l'âge donc c'est à dire la contradiction
et c'est pour ça la faiblesse
c'est-à-dire la contradiction rhétorique
flagrante et jamais reconnu c'est ça le
problème c'est à dire que les Français
n'ont jamais entendu le chef de l'État
où les gouvernants dire on a changé de
pied ou d'avis non jamais est-ce que le
problème Christophe justement ne vient
pas du fait qu'on a fait trop de
rhétorique dans cette affaire on a fait
trop de com et pas assez de politique
attends j'avais une grande très grande
distinction entre la comme et la
rhétorix l'argumentation c'est quoi la
différence la rhétorique c'est
l'argumentation cette réforme a été mal
argumentée rappelez-vous c'est une
réforme juste c'est une réforme
nécessaire c'est une réforme je ne sais
plus elle a eu toutes les couleurs
rappelez-vous les 1200 euros ça c'est
pas de la com ça c'est de l'AR
augmentation qui a été mauvaise mais il
y a d'autre part c'est à dire que on a
trop changé dans les arguments et dans
les dans les en tout cas les objectifs
de cette dans le formulation des
objectifs de cette réforme absolument
c'est ce qu'on appelle la logique du
chaudron en rhétorique c'est-à-dire vous
arrivez avec des arguments qui se
contredisent les uns les autres ça
marche pas
rappelez-vous comment vous alliez à
l'école oubliez y aller vous arriviez
avec des arguments contradictoires
j'ai pas regardé ma montre d'ailleurs je
vois que je oui j'ai oublié ma montre ah
je vois qu'il est à l'heure
vous voyez ce que ça veut dire donc des
arguments contradictoires donc ça c'est
vraiment de la rhétorique au sens noble
du terme et puis il y a ce problème de
fond
comment expliquer à un peuple qu'il faut
faire des efforts que je considère comme
indispensable
et économiser allez on va dire plus que
10 milliards quand même 13 milliards 13
milliards 17 milliards alors qu'on leur
a dit on a dit au même peuple pendant
deux ans quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est ce qu'on appelle une dissonance
cognitive ce que c'est intéressant ce
que c'est je pense que c'est la première
fois que la vous me dites ça vous me
dites ça mais en fait
le tournant c'est le confinement le quoi
qu'il en coûte et qui finalement fait
perdre de vue
qu'il y a des réformes à faire qu'il y a
des dans tous les cas qui a une rigueur
à retrouver il y a le confinement mais
il y a un billet structurel français qui
rappelez-vous c'est gratuit c'est d'être
à qui payent François Hollande et puis
un très long biais de l'État-providence
le non dit tout quand même cet
État-providence qui va sortir de
l'argent magique c'est de l'argent
public
comme vous le savez comme nous sommes un
certain nombre mais malheureusement pas
tous les Français à le savoir c'est
d'abord de l'état de l'argent des
contribuables
il y a un autre point je trouve très
intéressant dans le sondage qui a été
fait par backbone et paradoxa et bac
bonne Consulting c'est ce chiffre qui
montre que 69% des français demandent un
référendum d'initiative partagée
commentaire analyse alors là il va
falloir
sonder le cœur et les reins du Conseil
constitutionnel puisque est-ce que ce
référendum là il y a c'est un peu en
quoi le Conseil constitutionnel parce
que ça c'est une question qu'on a moins
posé alors qu'on est en train de voir
des heures devant le siège de la Banque
de France place de la Bastille au
croisement de la rue Saint-Antoine vous
avez un beau symbole vous imaginez bien
qu'ils allaient pas passer de la Banque
de France devant la Banque de France
c'est 68 et c'est mai 68 là
la Banque de France était sous enfin en
tous les cas elle était
une monnaie souveraine
bâtiment
mais effectivement qui est en train de
subir quelques attaques en ce moment je
reviens donc sur le référendum pourquoi
le Conseil constitutionnel pourrait
en quoi le Conseil constitutionnel
pourrait ne pas valider
la procédure du référendum d'initiative
partager parce qu'on se fasse trouver
enfin là vraiment il faudrait les
juristes vous savez d'ailleurs ce
discute beaucoup entre eux même si on
sait que sur la réforme elle-même je
crois que tout le monde a une
probabilité forte d'une validation de
l'essentiel et d'une censure peut-être
assez sévère ça tombe de dispositions
mais disons que sur l'essentiel seniors
par exemple oui il y a plus que ça il y
a pas mal de choses qui peuvent
disparaître est-ce que le contrat senior
et aussi le contrat senior vous savez ce
que ça ça a vraiment sa place bon il y a
les négociations avec les syndicats
enfin tout ça n'a rien à faire dans un
projet de loi de finance les deux
questions c'est évidemment 43 ans enfin
la réforme Touraine accélérée et les 64
ans
j'ai tout lieu de penser quand même que
le s'arrête validé par le Conseil
constitution avec de gros de gros coups
de baguettes sur les doigts sur la
procédure suivie le véhicule législatif
mais le véhicule législatif ne serait
pas censuré selon vous
bah censuré pour certains pour certaines
dispositions
du budget de la Sécurité sociale je le
dis en français courant
sera validé
écoutez serait validé je pense que oui
avec avec gros en faisant les les gros
yeux attention et en excluant du coup
tout ce qui serait ce qu'on appelle le
savait les cavaliers c'est-à-dire les
dispositions qui n'ont rien à y faire
alors maintenant vous imaginez un
conseil qui valide la loi ou l'essentiel
de la loi et qui valide le référendum
des initiatives partagées
c'est inédit je crois c'est à dire que
devient de la loi en attendant
bref
théoriquement juridiquement elle peut
être promulguée et peut-être promis mais
avec une épée de Damoclès car à la
différence de l'aéroport de Paris vous
savez qu'il y avait eu une procédure
engagée sur l'aéroport de Paris et qui
avait échoué faute de signature là je
suis prêt à parier qu'on aura nos 4
millions 500 000 et c'est ça que je
voulais vous faire réagir c'est que
notre sondage en tout cas le sondage de
sa bague bonne Consulting donne en
fourchette basse 9 millions de
signatures et en fourchette haute 18
millions je l'ignorais mais en tout cas
qui peut le plus peu de moi vous voyez
ce que je veux dire donc
il y aurait en tous les cas une un
nombre bien suffisant bien au-delà du
nombre suffisant de signature alors
qu'elle va être le destin politique
juridiquement la loi peut être
promulguée dès demain enfin les
dispositions acceptent nous mais quel
serait son statut juridique et de statut
politique de la majorité et du pouvoir
en attendant ce référendum bref on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge je veux dire du
point de vue politique le point de vue
politique donc effectivement le Conseil
constitutionnel pourrait faire du en
même temps
une question justement spécialiste de
rhétorique au kénesseurs du monde
politique de ces mœurs
et des mœurs de ces magistrats un peu
particuliers de ce qu'on appelle ces
sages puisqu'ils le sont
les magistrats sont considérés comme tel
[Musique]
comment comment quelles sont les quel
pronostics que vous faites sur
l'ensemble de
enfin sur la vie qui sera rendu demain
soir je le disais un petit peu et
d'ailleurs sur le timing parce que quand
même
ils ont pris un mois et c'est le maximum
que ils ont pris le maximum oui parce
que mais à ma connaissance le
gouvernement n'a pas non plus prononcé
l'urgence vous savez que le gouvernement
a la possibilité de demander que et
intelligemment je trouve parce que ça
aurait du coup la soirée vraiment fait
beaucoup le fait d'avoir fait justement
attendre
nous respectons etc ça aurait été et
puis ça aurait énervé le conseil
je pense que la probabilité vous savez
en rhétorique que disait Aristote on
peut parler que de probabilité la
probabilité vu la composition du conseil
qui n'est pas fondamentalement
anti-machroniste
ne pas se raconter d'histoires non
jusqu'à présent ce conseil a été
extrêmement comment dirais-je amical
avec le Président on l'a vu notamment au
moment des passes sanitaires alors le
Pass sanitaire c'est une chose mais ce
qui avait beaucoup frappé les les
juristes ça avait été la validation sans
problème du passe vaccinal
parce que là il y avait une atteinte
majeure ou liberté qui était l'évidence
disproportionnée puisque à ce moment-là
vous souvenez on était à eau micron on
avait toutes les indications pour savoir
que
que vraiment il y avait pas de quoi
comme on dit et puis à d'autre part que
la vaccination n'empêchait pas la
contamination bref l'extrême
complaisance du Conseil constitutionnel
contre sa tradition sa jurisprudence
quand même de défense de liberté
me fait penser que une va pas chercher
trop fortement l'opposition au président
mais il va marquer le coup il va marquer
le coup mais même sur les passe
vaccinage
sanitaire il avait marqué le coup quand
même aussi sur ça
dans tout pays à peu près démocratique
le Pass vaccinal ne passait pas
je dis bien vaccinal sur la question sur
la question maintenant
est-ce que il serait tenté de faire
justement du en même temps ce serait la
réponse du berger à la bergère
je crois qu'on peut tout à fait aller
vers ça c'est autre pronostic
dernier point est-ce que
une fois que le Conseil constitutionnel
aura rendu sa décision
Emmanuel Macron devra prendre la parole
et dans quel délai je prends au
spécialiste de rhétorique je crois que
c'est prévu
alors justement pourvu qu'il ne fasse
pas de la com c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'il fasse une intervention pas trop
longue
au bon moment et sous la bonne forme
mais ça quel est le bon moment le bon
moment c'est de laisser passer quand
même le week-end
d'attendre aussi le retour d'un certain
nombre de Français qui sont en vacances
parce que attention la baisse de la
mobilisation elle est aussi beaucoup due
aux vacances notamment vacances de Paris
ils ont pas encore commencé les vacances
de Paris donc
la semaine prochaine
je connais beaucoup de gens qui sont en
vacances alors moi je sais que j'ai
donné cours hier c'est vrai mais je
crois quand même qu'il y a pas mal de
gens partis non
donc il y a à penser que la mobilisation
pourrait reprendre notamment s'il y
avait cet ombre du fameux référendum
d'initiative partagée mon pronostic je
crois l'avoir exprimé devant vous de dès
le début
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
dès le début je vous ai dit nous en
aurions pour longtemps
je vous ai dit nous aurions pour
longtemps plusieurs semaines je vous ai
dit même je crois plus d'un mois de
difficultés et la preuve et je pense que
nous aurons nous ne sortirons pas de
cela sans solution politique
évidemment un changement de gouvernement
et peut-être ça si vous le savez si la
crise ne se dénoue pas et si la
possibilité de gouverner n'est pas
possible n'est pas là notamment s'il y a
un blocage avec elle
je pense qu'on va vers une dissolution
au moment opportun pour le Président on
va continuer à ça vous allez revenir
comment ça mon cher Christophe et puis
je serai sans doute confronté à mes à
mes fausses prédictions pas du tout
c'est toujours ça qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est de faire des hypothèses
et de voir comment justement la réalité
s'opère pour voir pour pouvoir analyser
le delta entre les hypothèses et la
réalité en probabilité en probabilité et
non pas en prophète merci beaucoup
Christophe peut-être une question
j'étais étonné de voir ces
manifestations
contre Emmanuel Macron dans un pays que
vous connaissez bien qui est le pays les
Pays-Bas et avec avec
alors il faut savoir deux choses d'une
part que les Pays-Bas ont aussi des
activistes pas aussi nombreux notamment
tout ce qui est le mouvement comme on
dit wok extrêmement puissant au Pays Bas
il y a tout un courant de la population
qui a été un peu choqué par la violence
je veux pas dire la violence policière
mais la violence parce que c'est très
anti hollandais ça cette violence vous
savez dans la rue et puis il y a
toujours des gens pour dire c'est la
faute à la police là-bas aussi et puis
de façon générale le côté un peu dur des
mœurs politiques françaises et très très
surprenant pour les Néerlandais
cela dit le président a bien répondu
vous savez que je le soutiens pas
toujours a bien répondu en disant
écoutez en matière de retraite c'est que
les Néerlandais vont vers 67 ans et en
matière de gaz à effet de serre vous
nous battez largement donc
je crois que c'est la bonne réponse à
faire plus de gaz à effet de gaz
lacrymogène exactement donc il a il a il
a il avait un bon un bon dossier on peut
dire mais
dans cette simple jeté une ombre sur une
visite qui s'est bien passée avec un
pays du vis-à-vis duquel on se on se
rapproche
en permanence merci beaucoup Christophe
d'être venu nous donner votre éclairage
d'avoir répondu de n'avoir donné votre
point de vue et on continuera bien sûr
de suivre la question avec vous parce
que c'est très intéressant on va voir
vraiment là une séquence rhétorique
importante dans les dans les jours et
dans les semaines à venir merci beaucoup
Christophe on va retrouver Vincent
roseron qui est rue de Rivoli toujours
il me semble à Paris en tous les cas sur
la route de la place de la Bastille
alors que on a quelques rues
Saint-Antoine oui on va voir il va nous
dire il y a bien de la chance et si
et surtout si on voit que au bout de la
rue Saint-Antoine place de la Bastille
par contre la situation est beaucoup
plus tendue mais ça ça l'est beaucoup
moins à votre niveau mon cher Vincent
alors nous sommes actuellement dépassé
le métro Saint-Paul et la prochaine
station de métro c'est la station
Bastille on se retrouve à peu près je
pense à 500 mètres de la place de la
Bastille vous pouvez peut-être voir sur
ces images tout au bout de cette rue
vous voyez le premier ballon de la CFDT
qui est là puis celui de la cFECGC le
cortège est en train là il vient de
stopper mais il va reprendre sa route il
a avancé jusque là nous sommes du coup à
cet endroit là et toujours dans le calme
toujours une une ambiance festive de la
musique bien sûr on a vu ces vitrines
fracassées on a vu des poubelles brûlées
des restes où elle brûlées mais là où
nous sommes en tout cas à 500 mètres de
la place de la Bastille l'ambiance est
encore festive pas de débordement en ce
moment
merci beaucoup Vincent a bien on vous
retrouvera en fin de en fin de
manifestation en tous les cas après ce
cette échange qu'on va avoir avec
Mathieu Valley du syndicatoires
commissaire de peu les commissaire de
police le SIP connaissait merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on va ben voilà
regardez les images qui nous parlent de
la Bastille alors là effectivement
ça se passe de façon un peu mieux que ce
qu'on voyait tout à l'heure m'envoyer
quand même des g de projectiles au moins
contre les murs de la Banque de France
on voyait des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes
comment ça se passe comment ça s'est
passé côté policiers ben écoutez il y a
eu des dégradations qui ont été commises
dès le début de cortège qui est parti
d'opéra en prenant la rue de Rivoli donc
pour les non parisiens c'est cette
grande rue où il y a beaucoup de
commerce c'est-à-dire le parcours est
assez casse-gueule si je peux me
permettre parce qu'on a beaucoup de
boutiques on a beaucoup d'institutions
on a la mairie qui était de Paris qui
était à proximité du cortège et pourquoi
on met ses parcours là alors c'est des
discussions qui sont sur la préfecture
de police et les syndicats et vous savez
que c'est une congestion en termes de
planification de parcours mais la
préfecture de police ne peut pas imposer
toutes ses exigences aux organisateurs
que sont la CGT de la CFDT et tout
l'interdicale qu'on connaît avec les
interlocuteurs qu'on a au moment où je
vous parle il y a 25 interpellations on
a fait de très belles manœuvres là sur
vos images on voit que le dispersion à
plat alors là je vois des des
on voit des g alors peut-être qu'on va
mettre cette image sur
en tous les cas sur les policiers qui
refusent vers la rue Saint-Antoine tout
à fait donc là ces place de la Bastille
si j'y passe avec la Banque de France ça
manque de la rue Saint-Antoine donc là
vous avez en première ligne des
compagnies d'intervention de la
préfecture de police de Paris ce sont
des policiers qui sont dans la direction
de leur public et de la circulation qui
sont spécialisés dans leur public aux
côtés des CRS et des gendarmes mobiles
et là effectivement il y a une ligne qui
a été mis en place par nos collègues
puisque en fait ils font face à des
Black Blocs des individus qui se
grimpent en noir pour commettre des
exactions des violences et des
dégradations d'ailleurs on avait un bloc
d'environ 200 individus qui tirent des
mortiers qui jettent des cocktails
Molotov et qui envoient des projectiles
à nos collègues comme on peut le voir
actuellement sur sur vos images et je
vous le disais il y a 25 interprétations
les images que nous nous voyons parce
que les internautes
pour vous donner la physionomie depuis
le début du cortège on a des groupes
très épars de 200 300 individus qui se
constituent en Black Bloc donc grimé de
noir avec des techniques aujourd'hui on
connaît bien pour attaquer pour frapper
et agresser les policiers et détruire
les outils des commerçants et on a 25
interpellations moi j'ai vu de très
belles manœuvres on a eu des projections
de policiers sur des individus qui ont
été ciblés comme et auteurs
d'infractions notamment d'exaction sur
les policiers gendarmes et de
dégradation sur les commerces et on a
les plus les prendre en flagrant délit
donc on a moins d'interpellations que la
dernière fois mais on a des
interpellations en flagrant délit avec
une caractérisation des éléments
matériels qui sont à mon avis très
bonnes pour la suite de la procédure et
dont on espère qu'il y aura des suites
judiciaires puisque c'est ce qui nous
permet derrière d'avoir une solidité en
terme de réponse pénale et de assise
est possible de notre action de police
on voit donc à ce moment donc l'arrivée
une partie du cortège donc place de
place de la Bastille
c'est vrai que la dispersion
d'habituellement c'est le moment le plus
critique parce qu'on a les gens honnêtes
qui viennent revendiquer pacifiquement
qui évacue rapidement le lieu de
dispersion sans faire de difficulté et
ensuite on a les éléments les plus
radicalisés qui se matchnent sur place
pour faire face à nos collègues en
termes de confrontation et puis pour
qu'on met des dégradations afin de les
attirer en deux sortes des guet-apens
pour pouvoir faire le plus de blessés
parmi neuron on voit bien que les engins
utilisés des cocktails Molotov des
engins incendiaires sont faits pour
blesser grève à nos collègues et les
faire tomber alors on va demander à la
Régie si on peut justement changer les
images là pour l'instant on voit voilà
exactement les images de la place de la
bassive à ce qu'on était en train de
commenter donc peut-être en revenir un
petit peu pour nos internautes pour
qu'ils comprennent un petit peu ce qui
est en train de se passer donc ça c'est
quand même une foule de la vitesse c'est
compactée autour de la colonne de la
place de la Bastille envoyer tout à
l'heure une charge donc vous disiez que
c'était
on ne on était on voyait des policiers
des compagnies d'intervention en fait
vous avez la rue Saint-Antoine vous avez
la Banque de France enfin une annexe qui
est à l'angle et le but des policiers
sur cette place de la Bastille sur les
images qu'on voit à votre écran j'espère
que les spectateurs les voient c'est de
protéger cette édifice institutionnel de
manière à ce qui est pas dégradation qui
soit commise par les individus grimés
noirs et qui forment ce qu'on appelle le
black bloc de 100 à 300 personnes de ce
que on me donne comme élément direct et
en réalité pour l'instant on tient les
positions il y a un barrage qui fait par
nos collègues avec quelques charges
lorsqu'il s'agit de faire reculer ces
éléments radicalisés qui veulent en
découdre avec nos collègues et qui
veulent atteindre ce bâtiment pour qu'on
met des dégradations et faire des images
choc parce que si vous voulez ces
individus radicalisés le but c'est de
détourner le cortège et les
revendications initiales pour en faire
des images de guerre et en faire des
trophées de guerre derrière sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans les groupes
auprès desquels ils partagent leurs
éléments alors je sais que les images
sont un petit peu gelées mais on va
recommencer à revoir ces images là
justement la place de la Bastille parce
que ça nous permet quand même de de
et d'avoir le pouls un peu aussi de ce
qui se passe en dans ces fins de cortège
d'ailleurs le sentiment qui m'intéresse
et en tout cas de votre point de vue
bien sûr un point de vue particulier qui
est un point de vue de syndicaliste et
quel est le sentiment à l'heure actuelle
chez les forces de l'or bah les
policiers sont fatigués parce que
d'abord fatigués d'être blessé je
rappelle que depuis le début de la
mobilisation n'a plus de 1200 policiers
gendarmes qui ont été blessés par
majoritairement des éléments radicalisés
ce qui est inquiétant aussi c'est qu'on
voit qu'au fur et à mesure des journées
de mobilisation on a des individus
radicalisés qui sont souvent de l'ultra
gauche à savoir des mouvements
anarchistes des mouvements antifascistes
tels qui se revendiquent mais aussi des
mouvements de l'ultra gauche avec
parfois des connivence avec l'extrême
gauche qui font qui s'adapte de plus en
plus à nos schémas de tactiques de
maintien de l'ordre à nos interventions
à notre organisation et à notre manière
de les faire reculer des interpeller là
cet après-midi on voyait des groupes
épars qui commettaient rapidement des
exactions sur nos collègues ou sur nos
camarades de la gendarmerie rapidement
des dégradations et à l'intervention des
policiers arrivent à s'exclipser par non
plus rapidement et ce qui est en plus
difficile les interpellations néanmoins
on a 25 interpellations et à l'heure
actuelle le chiffre monte encore puisque
sur la place de la Bastille on me dit
que nos collègues des compagnies
d'intervention des CRS des gendarmes
mobiles procède encore à des
interpellations flagrant délits puisque
là c'est vrai qu'on a des manœuvres très
coordonnées très rapides avec des
policiers notamment des braves des
briques de répressionnante qui ne sont
pas Kamoto c'est possible vous voyez sur
vos images se sont aussi des braves
images elles sont au fond tout à fait
ils ont des casques avec des liserés
bleues et en fait ils font des
interpellations d'individus qui
dégradent en flagrant délu ou qui
jettent des projets qui sont nos
collègues donc là je pense qu'on aura un
bilan déjà en terme d'interpellation et
un ratio judiciaire qui risque d'être
intéressant et qui pourra donner quand
même des bons résultats en matière
pénale si la justice suit nos
interpellations alors effectivement on
va peut-être maintenant changer de plan
et regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe
rue Saint-Antoine parce que c'est juste
à côté de là où des des autres images
que l'on a vu les autres scènes qu'on en
a vu effectivement ça c'est l'arrivée
vers la place de la Bastille
un effet marquant c'est que vous disiez
notamment aussi les braves c'est le
soutien de constant de Gérald Darmanin
le ministre de l'Intérieur aux policiers
est-ce que vous et est-ce que les
policiers et les membres de votre
syndicat ils sont sensibles oui les
autorités de tutelles qu'elles
soutiennent nos policiers c'est très
important le soutien moral si j'ose dire
et politique est important on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une partie de
l'extrême gauche et de tous les
chéquiers politiques qui aiment pas la
police notamment la France insoumise qui
fait de la police bouc émissaire et
l'entreprise a démolir notre institution
est à démolir pour ces gens-là quand on
dit la police tue quand on dit que nos
policiers doivent aller se faire soigner
qu'il faut absolument les dissoudre on
voit bien que pour eux le problème c'est
la police c'est pas les délinquants
alors que la réalité ça devrait être
dénaquant et pas la police ce problème
ensuite je dis dernier lorsqu'on avait
eu la manifestation à notamment devant
la rotonde on avait eu peut-être un
commentaire alors en fait si vous voulez
là c'est les compagnies d'intervention
puisque vous voyez il y a deux liseret
bleu sur vos images c'est ce que je vous
disais donc là il y a une charge puisque
le but c'est d'aller quand même elle est
violente alors une charge je vais vous
dire en Nord public à jamais de belles
images parce que quand la police qui a
le monopode de la légitime violence
lorsqu'elle fait usage de cette violence
c'est d'abord à la plus chouette c'est
en dernière nécessité en dernier recours
proportionnellement aux attaques dont
elle fait face là vous voyez vous avez
des gens qui ont le visage caché les
gants sur leurs mains mulet à d'autres
personnes qui ne se désolidarisent pas
et c'est très difficile lorsque vous
avez ciblé un groupe d'individus hostile
radicalisés qui sont là pour commettre
des exactions de dégradations de pouvoir
les cibler sans pouvoir par exemple
toucher des personnes qui restent à
proximité et d'une certaine manière qui
complique le travail des fers de l'ordre
et qui se mettent en danger c'est pour
ça que nous on donne à chaque fois un
conseil et une consigne basique est très
pratique quand il y a des violences
quand il y a des exactions quand les
policiers interviennent il faut que les
gens pacifiques les gens qui ont rien à
voir se désolidarisent quittent les
lieux et laissent les policiers
manœuvrer pour qu'on puisse aller au
contact et interpeller les photos de
troubles
oui c'est très difficile les gaz
lacrymogènes qui sont lancés servent à
faire reculer les personnes qui viennent
au contact de nos collègues vous avez
tous ceux qui filme vous avez tous ceux
qui veulent admirer si j'ose dire la
scène il y a ceux aussi ceux qui filme
aussi
sur le terrain non mais les journalistes
je vous parle pas des journées ça je
peux regarder on voit très bien enfin
j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir sur vos
images des journalistes avec des
téléphones portables brandi les
journalistes sont souvent des éléments
ciblesses d'ailleurs c'est toujours
compliqué de détecter les vrais
journalistes de ceux qui viennent faire
du sensationnalisme ou en tout cas qui
peuvent parfois se faire passer comme
journaliste pour écouter nos manœuvres
sur les ondes radio et pouvoir anticiper
les actions qu'on va entreprendre et
donc du coup moi effectivement tout le
monde peut filmer tout le monde peut
regarder tout le monde peut rester
présent sauf que Ben après quand les
policiers chargent pour disperser les
fauteurs de troubles pour arrêter les
exactions et pour faire cesser les
dégradations et ben il peut y avoir des
dommages collatéraux et je vais même
aller plus loin je retournerai là quand
les policiers restent attentiste et
qu'ils attendent le dernier moment comme
ils le font souvent pour interpeller
parce qu'il y a plus que ce dernier
recours pour faire cesser les exactions
on dit qu'ils sont violents et quand ils
ne font pas assez vite on dit qu'ils
sont laxistes donc vous voyez le juste
milieu est très compliqué à trouver
c'est des commissaires de police sur le
terrain qui jauge avec la salle de
commande de la préfecture de police de
Paris le meilleur moment pour intervenir
et pour faire les manœuvres que je vous
ai indiqué
vous parlez d'enregistrement
d'enregistrement qui a été il y a un
certain nombre d'enregistrements qui
sont parvenus qui sont diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux qui montrent qu'un
certain nombre de policiers quand même
veulent en découdre avec les
manifestants c'est quand même
difficilement défendable ah bah moi j'ai
pas vu énormément d'images où en fait on
avait des difficultés à interpréter
l'action des policiers d'abord suivant
on n'a pas à l'avant et la prise
enregistrement ou quand même alors
souvent ces enjeuxrement qui sont dans
ce que j'appelle des bribes d'images
d'abord moi ce que je regrette c'est
qu'on peut toujours pas utiliser les
drones dans la police et la gendarmerie
nationale à Sainte-Souline dans les
Deux-Sèvres lorsqu'il y a eu la
manifestation violente en tout cas
interdite puisque on dit manifestation
mais elle l'était plus à partir de cet
interdit nous on pouvait pas utiliser
les drones mais les individus vivants
les ont utilisés là sur les cortèges
mais vous savez je suis pour que la
préfecture de police la direction Jean
de la police à l'intérieur recrute des
caméraman et des personnes qui filment
sur le terrain qui font que ça et qu'on
diffuse en direct nos images avec nos
drones avec nos reporters avec nos
outils de communication puisque vous
avez des spécialistes du désordre qu'ils
arrivent à Cap des images pour en faire
des bribes d'images pour discréditer nos
collègues après quand il y a un doute
sur la légitimité l'action de nos
collègues il y a une saisine
systématique de l'inspection générale de
la police nationale et on nous dit
souvent oui mais les policiers sont
violents et manifestations des
manifestants sont par exemple d'abord
les manifestants sont pas violents par
nature c'est les individus radicalisés
qui le sont les manifestants ils
viennent revendiquer et souvent on n'a
pas de problème avec eux ce sont souvent
les organisations syndicales d'ailleurs
dont on voit alors je sais plus quelle
image je vois mais en tout cas le ballon
de la FDT derrière ou même la CGT et
derrière on peut pas laisser insinuer et
faire croire dans l'idée dans la dans la
tête des gens qu'on a une impunité chez
les forces de l'ordre on représente 5%
de la fonction publique et on sacralise
55% des sanctions rien que ces deux
chiffres là font taire en fait les
personnes et les directeurs qui disent
qu'il y a pas de sanctions de contrôle
de l'action de police est-ce que vous
êtes
favorable à une évolution de la doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre on a un schéma
NASA qui a été adopté il y a quasiment
un an et demi donc vous savez les
policiers c'est un peu comme les gens au
plus on change les règles au plus on
changeait doctrine au moins on s'y
retrouve et au plus c'est compliqué son
terrain de faire des actions et des
manœuvres simples il faut un cadre clair
là je pense que la doctrine a changé
parce qu'on n'avait pas le choix quand
on parle de désescalades la des escales
c'est quoi c'est qu'on intervient
uniquement quand il y a des dégradations
et des exactions et qu'on a plus le
choix d'utiliser la force que pour faire
cesser les troubles ensuite on se retire
immédiatement là sur la place de la
Bastille vous voyez que c'est compliqué
de revenir de repartir de revenir on est
obligé de se maintenir sur place parce
que les individus violents radicalisés
je vous l'ai dit s'adapter énormément de
schémas tactiques ce qui fait que dès
qu'on quitte les lieux ils reviennent au
contact ils reviennent faire des
dégradations donc on maintient les
forces mobiles et les forces locales sur
place mais ce schéma la salle de l'achat
l'ordre il faut être agrémenté
effectivement d'une formation
supplémentaire sur les groupes de la
police nationale donc les braves
notamment mais aussi les pelotons
d'intervention de la gendarmerie ou les
sections de protection et et
d'intervention des CRS qui sont
spécialisés dans la projection
l'interpellation parce que c'est là où
c'est le moment le petit critique
d'ailleurs quand vous parlez des images
où on veut mettre à mal l'action de
police et souvent sur des
interpellations ou sur des contacts avec
les manifestants qui deviennent violents
ou avec les individus radicalisés qui
est le plus sensible pour nous
est-ce que la police va parvenir à
relever le défi black bloc
alors c'est une très bonne question pour
qu'on puisse relever ce défi alors les
Black Blocs ça y est c'est une méthode
d'action il s'agit derrière ces Black
Blocs d'anarchistes dont il fasciste et
d'éléments d'ultra gauche il faut qu'on
mise absolument sur le renseignement en
amont et sur la judasarisation par les
services spécialisés comme l'entité
terroriste pour lutter contre
l'islamisme radical par exemple
notamment qui débouche en terrorisme on
a mis le paquet sur les enquêtes
judiciaires sur le renseignement sur le
suivi des personnes qu'on connaît que
trop bien puisque une partie s'en
fichier est il faut que pour ces
éléments radicalisés qui cassent notre
démocratie qui casse les cortèges et qui
sème le K-Way la violence en plus avoir
des mêmes outils juridiques dont on ne
dispose pas actuellement pour lutter
efficacement contre ces groupes muscules
et vous avez raison de poser cette
question on a eu le terrorisme islamiste
durant les 15 dernières années qui
aujourd'hui ayant encore très présent
mais qu'on gère parfaitement bien
puisque nos services de renseignement
des jouent des dizaines d'attentats par
an mais la menace de demain qui commence
déjà aujourd'hui c'est deux trois à
droite et du tout à gauche
c'est une menace qui est très très
dangereuse et sur laquelle je le dis nos
politiques n'ont pas encore pris la
mesure parce que des outils
juridiquement la priorisation
politiquement et finalement l'enjeu
aussi pour les magistrats à la justice
de traiter avec la même sévérité ces
mouvements comme on l'a fait sur des
sujets comme les stupéfiants le
terrorisme ou même le proxénétisme il
est vital parce que ça va être l'enjeu
d'aujourd'hui encore plus celui de
demain avec le terrorisme islamiste
quand vous dites pour le perturbateur
vous Twitter c'est spécialistes du
désordre sont connus ils sont souvent
anarchistes antifascistes dont certains
fichiers s cette idéologie radicale est
violente nécessite un cadre juridique
dédié comme pour les dealers par exemple
vous mettez donc ces gens là vous les
mettez sur le faites un parallèle avec
les dealers alors en fait ce que je vais
expliquer c'est que dans la loi vous
avez trois infractions principales qui
permettent d'avoir des pouvoirs un peu
plus importants pour les policiers pour
mieux traiter la délinquance organisée
et qui est une véritable défi pour nous
institutions il y a le proxénétisme des
personnes qui s'adonnent à de la
prostitution en tout cas mettre des
personnes ça dans la prostitution vous
allez le stupéfiant les trafics de
stupéfiants c'est à dire que les dealers
qui font du trafic demain ont aussi pris
avec ce cadre dérogatoire et vous avez
enfin le terrorisme ces trois cadres
dont effectivement on a l'impression
qu'ils n'ont rien à voir en fait
permettre par exemple 96 heures de garde
à vue permettent des perquisitions de
nuit permettent de suivre avec des
outils beaucoup plus importants et
développer les personnes qui s'adonnent
à ces infractions donc si vous voulez ah
mais moi ce que je dis c'est qu'il faut
aujourd'hui que le législateur le
politique donc le député de sénateur et
le gouvernement prennent l'ampleur de
l'enjeu qui s'annonce à nous et
qu'aujourd'hui on a pris beaucoup de
retard c'est-à-dire pourquoi on constate
beaucoup de violence et comme vous
l'avez dit ça date pas d'aujourd'hui et
je le dis et pas non plus d'hier depuis
des années on a des cortèges qui sont
sapés par ces mouvements il faut qu'on
puisse avoir un état de droit qui
protège les gens honnêtes aujourd'hui en
l'état actuel de nos droits on n'est pas
en mesure de protéger suffisamment les
jeux honnêtes face à ces groupuscules
violents alors qu'on s'est donné les
moyens de lutter contre ceux qui font
des morts dans les quartiers avec le
stupéfiant on l'a encore vu hier soir à
Marseille on s'est donné les moyens
lutter contre le proxénétisme on voit
que ça chose on a de plus en plus
majoritairement de jeunes filles qui
sont mis si je veux dire sur le marché
de clients prédateurs qui en fait les
les consomment comme si que c'était de
la consommation en grande surface et
ensuite vous avez le terrorisme dont on
a pris l'ampleur avec notamment les
attentats de Mohamed Merah quand ils ont
commencé en 2012 en France donc il faut
aujourd'hui avoir un cadre dédié pour
lutter contre ces casseurs et ses
agresseurs qui ont une vraie idéologie
derrière c'est ça que je veux faire
comprendre c'est qu'on parle pas
d'individus qui génère qu'aucun Molotov
parce qu'ils veulent pas voir les
policiers on parle de personnes qui se
réunissent sous une idéologie commune de
renverser les institutions de faire des
victimes chez les policiers légendes et
finalement d'être dans ce qu'ils
appellent ni dieu ni maître qui est la
devise des anarchistes et des
antifascistes merci Mathieu vallée pour
ces précisions et pour ces réponses on
vous restait avec nous on va rester
encore quelques minutes
on va aller place de la Bastille
retrouver Vincent roseron
on a vu effectivement quelques images de
de tension très forte tout près de là où
vous trouvez
les images qui nous reviennent sont des
ont maintenant sont plus calmes en tous
les cas il y a moins de moins de tension
est-ce que c'est le cas autour de vous
Vincent
oui effectivement autour de la rue
Saint-Antoine en fait toujours le trouve
qui donne sur la place de mastic vous
voyez juste là en fait l'arrivée de la
place de Bastille par les syndicales
vous voyez le cortège CFDT qui arrive
petit à petit sur cette place et
effectivement il y a eu des tensions
tout à l'heure on voit encore derrière
sur certains magasins avec les images
Leclerc alors trop cher sur cette
boutique qui est là il y a eu pas mal de
tension à ce moment-là il y a eu des
charges de police déjà place de la
Bastille ben nous de notre côté
effectivement on continue à avancer dans
le calme en tout cas les manifestants
continuent à avancer dans le calme il y
a toujours dans un premier temps à une
tête de cortège où tout est assez tendu
mais ensuite on a l'impression que les
il y a cortège calme et festif qui prend
sa place et c'est une nouvelle fois si
on est en train de se passer aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à la fin de ce live quelques questions
avant de se quitter encore est-ce que
vous avez eu des nouvelles de la
commissaire qui a reçu un pavé en pleine
tête il y a trois semaines il y a qui a
28 ans qui d'ailleurs va changer de
poste dans les prochains mois était en
fait touché par un pavé au niveau de la
rotonde de la semaine dernière avec son
casque alors qu'elle avait son casque
assez écroulé elle a perdu connaissance
quelques instants elle a subi des
examens à l'hôpital elle a eu un léger
traumatisme au niveau de la tête et
aujourd'hui elle va beaucoup mieux et à
la reprise évidemment son service
les bras même n'ont pas eu la main trop
l'est ces derniers jours les brigades de
répression d'action violente en moto
sont indispensables et essentielles pour
faire face à des cortèges à des
individus violents excellents et
radicalisés qui s'aiment le chaos et qui
peuvent engendrer des victimes en
mettant des insectes réponses en termes
de d'éléments de langage est-ce que
quand même il y a pas d'éléments de
langage je vous dis ce que je pense de
mes collègues si j'ai estimé une
modestement mon humble rôle parce que
vous savez qu'à côté de mes fonctions
syndicales je suis encore en activité
puisque j'exerce dans le Val-de-Marne en
brigade anti criminalité si j'estimais
que c'était une unité qui ne
fonctionnait pas qui était violente et
qui faisait pas le taf je vous le dirai
moi j'ai une lecture tout autre de
détracteurs d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué
qu'on a des députés de la France
insoumise ce qui aiment bien jouer les
Street reporters en les harcelant en les
provoquant et en faisant les agitateurs
j'avais eu des vous avez eu des
remontées ah oui j'ai eu des remontées
ils ont eu ces risques de provoquer nos
collègues que de les filmer à quelques
mettre du visage que de tenir des propos
qui sont désagréables que de dire qui
servent à rien donc ils ont adopté un
comportement tel qu'on peut constater
sur certains qui veulent en des coudes
avec nos collègues là ils ont suivi nos
collègues ils les ont harcelés ils les
ont provoqué et moi j'estime que quand
on porte les charges tricolore c'est pas
un totem d’immunité ça donne normalement
appliquer le respect d'exemplarité et le
soutien à ceux qui nous protègent parce
que sur ces policiers à moto c'est pas
des Sanguinaires avec une matraque qui
viennent faire des victimes c'est des
policiers à moto républicains qui sont
formés à leur public qui donne
d'excellents résultats et qui ont
procédé à des interpellations notamment
au moment où c'était le plus dur et des
cortège sauvages le soir à Paris vous
avez des délinquants qui ont mis le feu
à des poubelles qui ont fait ils se
propage à des habitations et donc
parfois nos collègues ont même réussi en
plus d'interpellations à sauver les
personnes qui étaient dans les
habitations qui auraient pu être victime
de ces agissements de ces criminels
parce que je rappelle que quand on
incendie un une poubelle à proximité
d'un d'une habitation et que ça se
propage on peut avoir des effets très
graves avec des victimes derrière et
donc ces policiers je leur en match
parce qu'ils sont courageux et j'estime
que dans la panade dans lesquelles nos
détracteurs veulent les mettre je trouve
que bah c'est une entreprise de
démolition qui est une pierre de plus à
ceux qui nous aiment pas c'est tout
après qu'on ait des formations
supplémentaires à donner à ses collègues
qu'on est des choses à améliorer c'est
toujours possible par contre j'estime
que quand on nous démonte pour détruire
votre institution on n'avance pas qu'on
nous critique pour construire là je
est-ce que vous en voulez la Ligue des
droits de l'homme
ah bah la Ligue des droits de l'homme en
fait elle considère que tout le monde
sont des hommes sauf les policiers quand
on a 1200 policiers gendarmes qui ont
été blessés elle a jamais un mot pour
ces policiers ces gendarmes donc
visiblement elle estime que ce sont pas
des hommes ou tout du moins des hommes
vous êtes favorable à ce qu'on lui
stocke les suivants non vous savez moi
j'ai pas un prononcé sur ça j'estime que
par exemple les associations d'aide aux
victimes les associations par exemple
civil la Commission de la dignité des
victimes d'animalisation pardon la CIVI
la commission gendarmerie
d’indemnisation des victimes souffrent
d'un manque de budget pour indemniser
les victimes dans les auteurs ne payent
pas les dommages intérêts que la justice
a rendu donc j'estime par exemple qu'on
pourrait prioriser les subventions à ces
structures d'ado victimes dont je
rappelle que les victimes ne demandent
jamais à leur bourreaux d'en être les
victimes donc quand on aura en tête que
la priorité ça doit être les victimes et
pas les délinquants je pense que on aura
changé en fait d'air peut-être de monde
et que finalement on mettra en avant
beaucoup plus ceux qui ont souffert
grâce à l'inaction si je veux dire des
délinquants et qui seront protégés grâce
à l'action de des pouvoirs publics et
qui mettront les subventions au bon
endroit après la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme qu'est-ce que je voulais vous
dire elle défile avec le CCIF notamment
qui prône quand même un islamigoriste et
qui prennent pas clairement les valeurs
de la République elle a jamais un mot
pour les collègues et les policiers
gendarmes qui font respecter la
déclaration de droits de l'homme blessé
son terrain donc j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait c'est des droits de l'homme elle
protège tout le monde elle défend tout
le monde sauf ceux qui sont chargés de
faire respecter la loi et les droits
pour qu'elle puisse exprimer librement
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup Mathieu vallée
avec beaucoup de franchise à nos
questions et également d'avoir nous
avoir et justement éclairer sur les
scènes que on a vu c'est le but
également de Figaro live on va retrouver
avant de se quitter Vincent roseron sur
place les derniers manifestants
les derniers ou pas d'ailleurs est-ce
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
manifestants qui arrivent place de la
Bastille
oui oui il reste encore beaucoup de
manifestants qui arrivent pas à la
Bastille on vous le rappelle il y a deux
cortèges cortège principal qui a fait
qui venait par la rue de Rivoli mais il
y en avait un deuxième avec notamment la
CGT et FO là pour l'instant c'est la
CFDT et CFE de les exploits arrivaient
déjà sur place mais il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui vont qui
vont arriver je pense que pour l'instant
là où on est il n'y a qu'un tiers de de
notre cortège qui soit pour l'instant
arrivé place de la Bastille il y a
encore du monde qui va arriver petit à
petit je pense que d'ici une demi-heure
trois quarts d'heure tout le monde sera
passé
si beaucoup Vincent va continuer bien
sûr de suivre ça les derniers chiffres
il nous parviennent à 17h les
manifestants étaient 252
000 dans les rues de France c'était
c'est beaucoup moins c'est plus de
100000 de moins en fait que le 6 avril
où il y avait à cette heure là 361
manifestants dans les rues de l'hexagone
et c'est nettement moins beaucoup moins
que au mois de mars le 7 mars à l'époque
à cette heure là il y avait
886 milles manifestants il y a
quasiment quatre fois moins aujourd'hui
252000 dans les rues de l'Hexagone
mobilisation quand même qui reste
massive on parle selon la police
justement de 42000 manifestants ici à
Paris en tout cas à 17h on va vous
laisser la fourchette que avait prévu
les services d'enseignement 40 000 à 70
000 défilant à Paris et d'ailleurs pour
terminer mon propos si je peux me
permettre vu que votre pote a sur le
terrain en parler les éléments radicaux
qui ont malheureusement désormais pris
les têtes de cortège en fait quand on
voyait vos images tout à leur place de
la Bastille le but de nos collègues
c'est de les disperser pour justement le
cortège alors on parlait de la CFDT de
la CGT tous ceux qui suivent derrière
puisse arriver tranquillement sur la
place de la Bastille et pouvoir quitter
les lieux si possible sans encombre et
en ayant pu exprimer leur revendications
sociales et c'est aussi sur sa dernière
note que je veux terminer c'est que les
policiers gendarmes protègent le droit
inalial de ces gens de pouvoir
manifester de pouvoir s'exprimer de
pouvoir dire ce qu'il pense parce que
c'est ça aussi pour lesquels les
révolutionnaires de 1789 les vrais
passant en carton parfois qui peuvent
grandir une écharpe préparation et qui
exprime leur revendications et c'est
pour eux qu'on qu'on se baille qu'on a
beaucoup de blessés d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup Mathieu Valley 1500 policiers
qui ont été presque 1500 on a eu
beaucoup de blessés effectivement on
verra à la fin de la journée le bilan
que donneront nos autorités
effectivement le chiffre n'est pas
encore tombé mais bien sûr il figurera
dans le live texte qui est en ce moment
alimenté par tous les journalistes du
Figaro un grand merci merci aussi
également à l'équipe sur place
Vincent roseron et Julien Leclerc et
merci également à l'équipe mobilisée aux
équipes mobilisées en régie
Riad Becky à la réalisation Sacha Baudry
Augustin morio Virginie le trianonaire
infatigable programmatrice de ces de ces
lives et bien sûr merci à tous les
contributeurs notamment bien sûr Mathieu
vallée et merci et pardon à ceux que
j'ai oublié j'oublie pas Reine-Marie du
GRU du loup Faustine Claret toutes les
équipes des Figaro live autour
d'Alexandre boursier Mathilde serra qui
se sont mobilisés et animalisa qui sont
mobilisés pour cet après-midi on
continue à suivre les images et les
autres infos bien sûr demain on
reviendra également sur la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel vous n'oubliez
pas la suite des programmes 18h ça va
commencer c'est l'excellente Cécile bois
qui incarne Candice Renoir notamment
euh mais également euh un nouveau
téléfilm sur France 2 qui est l'invité
du bus TV et puis à 19h dans une heure
notre nouvelle émission bienvenue en
Île-de-France avec victoire sicora et à
19h le club Le Figaro
ID avec un très beau thème sur la
littérature et la politique autour de
l'excellente Eugénie Bastié et vous ne
ratez pas non plus à partir de 21h un
nouveau numéro du Figaro la nuit c'est
en direct c'est avec Thibault Gauthier
qui sera ce soir avec Frédéric Beigbeder
vous restez avec nous vous avez toutes
les arguments et toutes les raisons de
rester avec nous sur le site du Figaro à
très vite